foreign
everyone
this is uh make just to confirm this is
the house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs my name is
Wayne McDonald I want to welcome you
here this morning and thank you for
being here before we get into the
business of the day I'd like to ask you
to join me in the Pledge of Allegiance
excited
thank you everybody
we have a number of bills to be heard
this morning uh the first one is house
bill 91-5n-a
I'd like to recognize representative
Edwards the prime sponsor for the
purposes of presenting this bill
uh thank you Mr chair good morning to
the members of uh my original committee
three terms ago
um I I'm here today uh representing
Auburn or District 31 in Rockingham
that's Auburn Candia Chester and
Deerfield
for those of you who have skimmed or
read House Bill 91 if you were here last
term this is going to seem eerily
familiar uh you you probably voted for
it and the half session two years ago
and and you may Wonder well what are we
doing and what we're doing is it was
such a successful Bill coming out of the
house
that in the budget negotiations it got
taken hostage and the Senate attached
um a spending bill that had never come
to the house and so on that committee a
conference I refused to accede to the
Senate demand and they they killed the
hostage so so this bill is uh is is what
we've already seen it's actually a
little bit simpler than the last time uh
what what does it do the main main
things it does there are three things it
establishes
at the department level a governance
board with the governance
responsibilities and this is standard
corporate behavior these days and it's
something that does not exist currently
in the department and in my six I guess
six plus years now technically
um my perception of the Departments
um compliance with the spirit of our
constitutional amendment from 2018 the
one establishing a right to privacy in
our constitution is that they've been so
busy that this is a major subject area
that they've just not been focused on
and by establishing this governance
board it's meant to you know clarify
their mind gather their focus and
provide them with some privacy expertise
to help them manage privacy issues
within the department
um
it implements a risk mitigation
technique in the corporate world they
call it a privacy impact assessment but
it's a risk mitigation technique and so
that before any I.T system gets
implemented there's meant to be a
thorough analysis of the processes and
procedures and Personnel issues around
that I.T system to anticipate any risks
to individual privacy and then to the
extent that there are are identified
risks that they then have a mitigation
plan and and so this bill basically
requires that this risk assessment and
mitigation plan be done prior to the
implementation of an I.T system so that
we can proactively do what we can to
assure privacy
it establishes two classified positions
to to assist with uh you know basically
training and supporting the governance
effort and to handle the workload of
these risk mitigations
um one might think that
um the the IT staff could have people
already on board that could handle this
but this is really a I think a a new job
description for the Department in that
to be really good at these risk
mitigations you have to understand I.T
systems you have to understand
workflow and process you have to
understand you know the Privacy
principles and and in some cases the law
uh and and you need to understand
I.T security because all of those things
have to come together to really come up
with a good risk mitigation plan so so
that's what this bill does what it
doesn't do the last time you you it
included something on the closed loop
referral system but that issue got dealt
with separately in the last term so it's
it's not in this bill I have to
um point out
that in the drafting I made an error I I
apparently got feedback on this that got
by me but on so I I have to bring an
amendment or I don't know I'll do
whatever you tell me to do I can either
do the amendment or this is now your
bill and you can do the amendment I'm
willing to do my part but on page three
line four
it says uh 2023 at the end of that line
that that needs to be 2024.
because I think that's just a carryover
from the old bill
um and then on line 20
uh the job title uh is is not correct
instead of a business systems analyst
too it's an I.T manager 4 and it's a
labor grade step 30 or excuse me labor
grade 32 instead of a step five it's a
step seven
uh it doesn't have a financial impact on
the fiscal note this is just a
correction of the legislative language
and then on uh line 22 and 23 I repeated
the error of calling them Business
Systems analysts instead of the proper
term of it manager
so so I I can get that Amendment started
today with the with the permission of
the chair so that by the time you exec
it it would be available to you for your
consideration
with that I'm willing to take questions
thank you questions from committee
members yes sir
thank you chairman
um my first question is is there a
current problem with
um
this information being leaked are there
are we are we seeing lots of people
suffering from their information being
leaked right now
I'll let Mr wieders address that
um I I would be reluctant to to put on
the public record if we're having a lot
of problems in that area I I
being a former privacy and security guy
uh it's it's it's best not to Signal
That You're vulnerable because that
tends to attract flies
um what what I would say in a more
generic way to your question is that uh
in 2018
uh the state of New Hampshire
established the right to privacy and in
the department uh I by working with them
it seemed to me fairly clear that uh
they they were not very far along on the
maturity cycle or maturity level of for
privacy operations and and and that in
itself is a strategic weakness that this
bill addresses
ask a follow-up follow-up okay
um thanks you said that you um have i t
background yourself I do and I also am a
bit of a techie nerd and um
I will say that one of my biggest beefs
with information technology
um operationals
it is it is
um
that um
they often use Microsoft and other
non-free proprietary corporate software
uh closed source and being an open
source free and free and open source
software Advocate because I understand
it's just so much safer what are the
chances that these two Security
Professionals would actually retailer
the system and start using free and open
source software instead of Microsoft
which quite frankly is not trustworthy
thank you I think that's a fascinating
question that goes Way Beyond the the
scope of this bill this bill is to
establish a framework that does not
exist today and the capacity to exercise
within that framework the future
architectural design is a strategic
question we have the director of doit
here today maybe he could talk about his
intent for the future architecture of
the New Hampshire I.T systems and Mr
wieders from the Department of Health
and Human Services who's their CIO is
also here so they they'd be better in a
position to address future architecture
representative Weber
thank you
um
in the department there is the concern
and there was the concern last time
around of balancing the important
privacy concerns that you've recognized
here
with ensuring that a vulnerable
population that has a hard time
navigating uh government government
systems can also receive the services
that they need in a timely fashion
is that something that has already been
addressed with the closed loop system or
is that something that we need to be
sure we are balancing here
uh thank you for the question I uh okay
so we we explicitly took the closed loop
out and and so it's a little it's
outside my boundaries but but since I've
tracked that issue as well I I am in a
position to tell you that uh all of the
concerns that the legislature
communicated to the department about you
know the um and you're right there was a
balancing act to what extent can we
easily provide additional services to
our clients
um while maintaining their privacy that
that is a trade-off decision and
um and based on those conversations the
department
took their own initiative to shut down
the RFP that was underway for that
closed-loop referral system because you
know the perception that the RFP had not
put enough into it regarding
requirements for privacy and security so
they pulled that back and think I think
they've reissued it I don't know what
the status is but I'm sure that the
without having read it I'm sure that the
requirements and the updated RFP sort of
address that better
thank you representative Merchant
thank you chair and thank you
representative Edward's taking the
question
is the appropriate place for this to be
housed actually in the department of
Information Technology versus it in the
department of
DHHS we talked about that last time on
the bill it just seems that we're
looking at privacy
an asylum mentality versus looking at it
broadly within the state itself
I I that's an excellent question and
um two years ago the director of the
commissioner of I.T made the same
observation and and the Committees made
the same question and so what my answer
was then is that as the chair of
division three as a graduate alumni of
hhsea you know I uh I perceived that my
credibility scope was within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and given that that is probably
the predominant place where we handle
personal data I thought it was
nevertheless a great place to get
started there's there's nothing
um in in the legislation uh that that
would prohibit the commissioner of I.T
to go ahead and begin to implement these
things on his own and I've I've told him
I'm here to support him in that regard
and so far the only request has been on
a separate bill to create
um of to to put into statute the role
that they created already or a chief
information security officer so so Mr
Goulet is I think uh on on top of that
this this is specifically the Department
of Health and Human Services because I
felt like that was my my boundary and my
scope and that it was probably solving
80 percent of the state's personal data
security issues
follow up thank you Mr chair
in saying this
do we actually need to have legislation
to mandate something I think the
department would do anyways
um I I think given the level of what
you're talking about and so forth and
privacy being so important to those here
in New Hampshire
why do we need legislation to tell the
department to do something I think they
would do on their own
while they could do it on their own the
governance board requires the active
participation of Department leadership
at a level that did not exist when this
bill was drafted they weren't doing it
and so oftentimes if we see the
executive branch failing to do something
that the legislature perceives to be
important we we codify the requirement
so so there's that they weren't doing it
there's also the authorization for two
very specific types of people to help
provide the support to the governance
board and to conduct these uh these risk
mitigation
investigations and and what is also new
is requiring a specific risk mitigation
process be implemented the the
department
I think to your point had had done quite
a lot in the security area and and and
if you looked at their workflow there
were there were several points in their
I.T acquisition process where they were
doing major portions of what would come
in in this risk mitigation strategy
um but it but what this does is is
essentially says you know let's
aggregate that let's get it all together
let's clean up the workflow and make it
a a significant part of of what we do to
protect personal data in New Hampshire
any other questions
go ahead
a little bit of a
I've been involved
I've heard several times now
everyone in New York Health and Human
apartment
promises
um everything in this bill is I've had
to do
pictures to protect them
my question is seems to me there's a
Private Practice the private private
sector in the
little bit lost why this
first I first I agree with your
observation that this is an attempt to
take the uh the benchmarks established
externally in the corporate world and
apply
the similar level of assurance to state
government so so it is kind of raising
the bar on the external benchmarks that
we should follow within the state
um and I'm sorry I spoke so long I
forgot the your actual question
[Music]
sorry
um I'm struck with what seems
[Music]
serious
I I can't speak for the decades past but
I can speak for a little bit to the
challenges that the the department
leadership has had during the pandemic
to to actively switch their focus to
trying to manage uh you know the the
real and perceived threats of the
pandemic uh within the state and that
that Drew their attention so so since we
really have had this conversation in the
last two years they've been busy so so I
I do I do agree this is an attempt to
eliminate the double standard that
you've you've observed
other questions from committee members
representative redwoods I actually had
one
um
quick one the membership Quorum on page
two and uh me on the actually the page
one talks about the governance board and
so forth the reference
Department's privacy officer uh is that
a new position or is that one that
already exists I
think that's a good question they they
do have a privacy officer now who's an
attorney uh she's not specifically
certified by the uh the information
Association of privacy professionals or
the international I'm sorry
International Association of privacy
professionals but she's steeped in
Privacy Law and so she's she's been
focused and on board for about four or
five years so uh her role is I think is
vital uh assuming that she stays on
whoever replaces her would be a big part
of this governance board
thank you and then and then a question
for you um Mr chair if I may
um what would you like to do about the
amendment do you want me to go get an
amendment for the committee so you can
consider it an exec session that'd be
great yes sir I'll do that thank you
very much
okay thank you representative Edwards
um next person to testify and going
forward the plan this morning uh and
today
because of the very heavy agenda we have
are going to be recognizing the prime
sponsors to
playing the the Genesis of the bill and
and get into the background and then
we're going to be asking subsequent
testimony to be limited to three minutes
uh following the prime sponsor
just in the interest of time to make
sure we can give everybody a fair chance
to uh to testify
next up we would uh recognition of that
would like to ask representative Tony
Lucas to come forward he's a response of
this bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you the
committee
um I don't expect to take more than that
amount of time
I agree with uh the reason for this um I
come from uh you know over 40 years
working in I.T business often
almost always dealing with very
sensitive information
and and the issue is that
unless you have somebody who really
understands this you know the software
end of controlling information in the
Privacy end
um and is monitoring what's going on not
only in the I.T systems but also the
workflow and how who has access to the
data how it's handled the department
cannot know if any of the information
has been mishandled
wouldn't be I don't I don't know if
there's been a release I haven't heard
anything major in the news but that
doesn't mean that information isn't out
I'm not saying it is I'm saying the
department cannot know
if it is or is not unless they have a
very good organized process in place
to deal with the handling of information
and the it's find it
um and that has to be something which is
uh put in place reviewed regularly
updated and then
has to be a close look at the training
of handle the information what access
they have and all of that and that
requires you know real expertise
in areas Beyond just you know the legal
privacy and although that's important
part of the whole thing
um that's why I support this that you
need that to be very well organized for
example I
and and the data has to be segregated
who can access it what they can do with
it there are times that I supported
customers where
um I couldn't look at their data but I
could support their systems for example
things with National Security
implications where I didn't have a
security clearance but if you set things
up right that is possible
and the department handles the most you
know by far the most private and the
largest volume in a variety of private
information of any part of the state
government so um that's why I'm
sponsoring this
and I can briefly take questions but I
thank you representative any questions
for representative leakis
it's not
thank you very much thank you
okay next up to testify is that Mr David
widows from the Department of Health and
Human Services
foreign
thank you very much chairman and members
of the committee my name is David
Wieters Information Services director
for Health and Human Services here at
the State of New Hampshire and thank you
for having the time for this bill today
we worked in a collaborative partnership
with the committee and the coach sponsor
and the co-chair to
edit and look at this bill in in support
of this bill we were looking at how do
we enhance the privacy and security of
our our department and the data that we
manage on behalf of the individuals in
our state so to address some of the
questions that came up the department
does have a very robust privacy and
security plan we go through risk
assessments on every contract we have
incident response teams that respond to
any type of privacy or security
components however this bill essentially
codifies as representative Edwards
indicated what the legislature is
looking for in terms of a privacy and
security governance board and provides
the appropriation for additional
resources to do what is called a privacy
impact assessment so privacy impact
assessments are done both in the private
sector as well at the federal level
but at the state level they're not
always called privacy impact assessments
sometimes we call them security risk
assessments or we have other terms but
this privacy impact assessment is very
key to Bringing privacy on the Forefront
one of a previous representative
representative Neil Kirk indicated in
one of the committee meetings privacy is
what you protect and and security is how
you protect it and I I fundamentally
agree with that statement that we need
to know what we're protecting and then
we use cyber security and I.T technology
to protect that data so going through
this bill we we appreciate the
opportunity to have this heard and
discussed and we hope that it will be
moved forward as it goes as it goes
through
and I'll take brief questions if you
have any thank you very much
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
today
um it sounds like this will
this will structure and make it so that
survives through different legislatures
and different changes in leadership so
that there's a consistent plan and a
consistent structure that continues on
is that a correct understanding that is
correct thank you and just as a
follow-on we do have a data governance
board
um this formalizes a board above that so
right now we're managing it at my level
and the director's level this takes it
to a commissioner level in partnership
with doit as well
any other questions from we've yes the
representative Merchant thank you Mr
thank you for taking the question
same question
I asked before to representative Edwards
is the appropriate place for this in the
department of health Team and services
or actually in the State Department of
Information Technology because I'm
looking at this and saying privacy is
not contained within one Department of
the state but it should be done
Statewide so help me understand why it
should only be in Department of Health
Human Services versus it being something
done throughout the whole state
and that's a good question
representative Merchant um I I would
agree that it's actually two-fold so the
Department of Health and Human Services
is a very large department and so we
have some other programs like we have in
information security officer which not
all the other departments do in order
for us to actually address the concerns
of all the programs and services at the
department so I think it's an
opportunity for us to look at how do we
stage it at Department Health and Human
Services in partnership with doit to
then figure out how do we move that
across the state as we go forward so
it's a in in it we do a lot of
prototyping or piloting of solutions so
we can try to get something off the
ground make sure it works and then
expand and and move it across an
organization this is an opportunity that
we could do that with with this bill
any other questions from Mr leaders
all set okay thank you thank you very
much
okay I know of I have no other cards
filled out as anyone else here who
wishes to testify on this bill
okay seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 91 and
proceed to the house bill uh the public
hearing on House Bill 587. I would like
to recognize the prime sponsor of this
bill representative Jose kimbrils
by the way representative am I
pronouncing your name right
okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
I am representative Jose cambrils of
Merrimack County District 4 serving
Louden in Canterbury New Hampshire
I speak to you today on this organ
donation Rights bill as someone who
received a life-saving kidney transplant
three years ago so I am very
knowledgeable about the organ
distribution system and how it works
I like to say up front that there is an
amendment to this bill that should have
been uh distributed by OLS what's going
around now thank you and uh the other
thing is I'd like you to note that it is
a bipartisan Bill equally co-sponsored
by Republicans and Democrats
House Bill 587 is necessary for two very
important reasons
first I think everybody in here would
agree that an individual owns their body
and therefore should be able to will
that body or any of its parts
as they see fit just as they would be
able to do with any other asset when
they die
secondly New Hampshire citizens on the
transplant wait list have been
discriminated against and unfairly
punished by the new organ distribution
policy that Unos United Network for
organ sharing
put into place on March 15 2021.
the previous policy was fair and
Equitable and used a long-standing
regional scheme for distribution
New Hampshire was part of the New
England region along with Maine
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
and half of Vermont
the new distribution policy changed all
that and instead went to an arbitrary
250 nautical mile radius from where the
organs are harvested as a key
distribution Factor
by doing this the vast majority of
organs harvested in New Hampshire are
now going to large out-of-state cities
in New Jersey and New York
and because their populations and their
their transplant wait lists dwarf those
of New Hampshire and the other small New
England states we have virtually no
opportunity to get deceased donor organs
now
the new policy has devastated our New
Hampshire citizens on the transplant
waiting list it was like a gut punch to
those that had already been waiting for
years and had hoped that they were
getting close to getting an organ
with this new policy the average wait
time
to get a deceased donor organ in New
Hampshire will shoot up from a
reasonable three to five years
to another to a likely unsurvivable
eight to ten years
as a data point I received information
from Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
regarding the effects of the new policy
at their facility
uh this is a summary comparing kidney
transplants from 2019 compared to to
this recent year 2022.
the number of people on the waitlist has
gone up from 81 to 131 it's a 61.7
percent increase
deaths while waiting for an organ have
gone up from one per year to five per
year
that's a 5x increase the number of
decree the number of decreased deceased
donor transplants are significantly down
and and worse worst of all the organs
that they are getting are of much lower
quality and less viability as New
Hampshire is only getting the organs
that have been passed up by the other
states
out States outside of New Hampshire
this bill is very simple as amended it
does two things to try to somewhat level
the playing field for our New Hampshire
citizens
one
it will add a secondary check box
to the existing New Hampshire driver's
license slash ID application that will
allow our New Hampshire citizens to
choose New Hampshire first for their
organ donations
two
the bill gives instruction to the
director of the DMV
to request that the New Hampshire first
designation becomes part of the Uno's
distribution algorithm
as a tie-breaking decision point all
other deciding factors being equal so
it's only a tiebreaker
make no mistake New Hampshire is being
used as an organ Farm by the big
out-of-state cities
transplants are big business and big
money
so when you hear the lobbyists behind me
today and some maybe even well intended
but misguided Representatives
taught bring up their past talking
points and misdirections
please challenge them on this
they will tell you that the bill
conflicts with federal law not true
there is no law that can govern an
individual's right to donate their body
as they wish
they will tell you that the bill is
unethical because it uses geography as a
decision Factor
that and they'll compare it to it being
like using race or religion as a factor
false
the policies have always been
geographically based first by region and
now by the 250 nautical mile radius
they will tell you that other New
England states might follow our model
and pass similar legislation and that
that would hurt New Hampshire
false again Unos has already done the
maximum damage they could possibly do to
the New Hampshire citizens with their
new policy in fact we welcome other New
England states to join us so that may be
the pressure will return us to the near
perfect regional scheme for distribution
that we had before
please ask them if this new policy has
helped New Hampshire weightless patients
in any way
ask them if the organs are are now more
viable now that they're traveling longer
distances and spending more time on ice
ask them how and why they came up with
this arbitrary 250 nautical mile radius
policy that only affects our small New
England states in a negative way
and see if they can look you in the face
and give you a straight answer and an
honest answer
last session the house Transportation
committee passed House Bill 583 which
was similar but less clean than this
bill by a unanimous 19-0 vote it then
passed the New Hampshire house on a
unanimous consent
it was then put into an interim study
unfortunately by the Senate HH and S
committee where it eventually died
this bill should address any issues that
were questioned then
I hope and pray that this committee will
recommend that this very bipartisan bill
will be ought to pass as amended and I
thank you all very much
thank you representative questions about
uh yes yes sir representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question with the new policy
of 250 nautical mile radius
how our organs prioritized
how come they how come so many more go
to cities the reason would be since the
250 nautical miles is a major factor in
their algorithm naturally you you can
imagine New York City has a population
of 10 million 12 million I don't even
know anymore it's uh 10 times the entire
population of New Hampshire so therefore
their wait lists are much longer and
their people have been waiting on the
list much longer and again due to their
own issue their issue there is that
they're not a donor State relative to
the population they have very few people
it's that sign up to be organ donors
whereas New Hampshire is one of the top
donor States relative to our population
we have many many more people sign up to
be organ donors so they're taking
advantage of our system
thank you
other questions yes representative
so one of the objections that we are
getting is uh that it's based on New
Hampshire driver license but a person
with New Hampshire driver license can be
at least Temple leaving let's say in
California and if he has a New Hampshire
driver license but if he
they say it would be in this scenario to
Buddhism to move the organs from
such a distance can you
speak to this scenario I'm I'm not quite
sure I apologize that I understand the
question does it have to do with uh
driver's license and notification on the
driver's license or so
the objection is that uh
um we specify New Hampshire
residents but maybe even though by
document the New Hampshire residents
maybe they temporarily live in a distant
state
and if
this uh I think I can answer that
question by so first of all the when you
sign up to be an organ donor at the
register the the real record is held at
the registry of motor vehicles on their
database
the driver's license has an indicator
that you're an organ donor however that
does not really mean anything all that
does is it alerts uh emergency Personnel
that you are a potential donor they
still have to check the registry at the
DMV so if somebody has moved out of
state uh and they no longer have a New
Hampshire Drive
the record is held at the DMV database
so that would be updated as required if
somebody in fact you can sign up as an
organ donor have the designation the
little heart on your license and three
months later if you decide you do not
want to be an organ donor you go to the
DMV and have them remove it from the
from the actual database so everything
is controlled in a database and not
necessarily what's on the driver's
license
thank you
any other questions sir representative
Gambrills
yes go ahead
um you kind of
address oh I'm sorry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm getting better at this so
um
you kind of addressed this a little bit
in your testimony but what I'm wondering
is is this ceremonials and enforceable
what are the barriers to actually making
this real
to be honest the main barrier is that um
when our director of the DMV sends the
request to have New Hampshire as part of
the algorithm it's going to be incumbent
upon the Unos who is a federally
contracted organization to follow their
direction if they do not follow it then
um we'll see where the chips fall after
that because they will be violating a
New Hampshire statute so
what's that yes thank you
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um it was actually
um kind of a spin-off from uh
representative Paul zav's question uh if
a patient if a New Hampshire resident is
in an accident and
um who's a an organ donor is in an
accident or something in another state
far away
um is it going to be
a challenge you know for them to donate
to an appropriate donor if they're in a
you know what I mean if it's very far
then there's an added layer of getting
it to New Hampshire if that's the only
place that they want their organs to go
yeah uh so thank you and that also helps
to clarify what representative pulls up
said no um uh not at all because
remember all the other criteria still
are in place before that this is not a
New Hampshire only this is a New
Hampshire first where possible as a
tiebreaker so uh the New Hampshire
Factor does not Trump any of the
existing of course you have to match by
tissue type you have to uh the amount of
time that the per people have spent on
the wait list all that supersedes this
this is simply a tie breaker and quite
frankly the reason this bill is put
forth is to bring attention to the
situation that we went from a near
perfect distribution scheme to one that
is punishing to our citizens and this is
going to raise awareness
any other questions for representative
cambrell's
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question
it's a sort of a follow-up on what
representative Cushman has spoken to if
you're out of state but at the same time
do we need to have something like this
if it's in fact housed in the Department
of Motor Vehicles could that be added
there because it sounds like that's the
controlling Factor no matter what I put
on my driver's license
it's going to have to go back to the
Department of Motor Vehicles to validate
that I didn't revoke it
so should this be more in the Department
of Motor Vehicles in their database
versus it being on the driver's license
itself no this is exactly what this
build does uh the the little icon so
when you see the applications today for
the driver's license or the New
Hampshire ID right now there's one check
box that doesn't that give makes you an
organ donor what this bill does is it
adds a second box that directs the DMV
that you are a New Hampshire first organ
donor and that's what will go on the
record in their database so the the
driver's license does not change at all
the driver's license still has the same
icon if you're an organ donor but what
this does is it adds the second uh level
so that the DMV will have in their
database that you are a New Hampshire
first organ donor so that you'll have
that designation in the algorithm so
this in fact does go to the database it
is controlled by
bye-bye
other questions for yes follow-up just
unclear
um no matter what I do with my driver's
license when I sign up for the driver's
license itself I still have the
opportunity
to call the Department of Motor Vehicles
to revoke that on my driver's license is
that correct that is correct your
driver's license will continue to have
the little heart on it until you renew
it however the database will reflect
that you are no longer an organ donor
any other questions for representative
cambrell's
thank you representative thank you
okay again we'll be limiting testimony
here on on this bill up to three minutes
uh the next step to speak is
representative Mark Pearson
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Mark Pearson I am
chairman of the children and family law
committee and a member of the health
human services and elderly Affairs
committee Alumni Association it should
be recognized the previous chairman of
this committee so welcome back thank you
it's great to be back sir and so good to
see this committee still in good hands
thank you
at first glance House Bill 587 commends
itself
and for that reason I jumped on last
session
as a co-sponsor
because the bill spoke of a fixing a
decal or symbol on a person's driver's
license or a non-driver's picture ID
that bill was sent to the transportation
committee which evaluated it on the
basis of could we put a sticker on the
driver's license and they said yeah we
can do that so they passed it
unanimously and it went on its merry way
on the way to the Senate however several
people looked at the bill I was one of
them I'm married to a physician I talked
with many of her colleagues I believe
I'm a well-guided representative in
terms of the research I've done
and I looked at it from the perspective
of politics ethics legality and
practicality
at that point several issues came to the
surface which led me then to speak
against the bill
before the Senate
the Health and Human Services Committee
of the Senate voted 5-0 to itl the bill
and it was then tabled
the bill is back appropriately this time
before this committee and I must again
speak against it under those four
criteria
first of all politics
if this bill were to pass
I'm sure Massachusetts would pass
something similar
last time before the Senate a New
Hampshire resident testified she
received a transplanted heart of a
deceased Massachusetts resident at toss
Medical Center
ahead of a Massachusetts resident no
tiebreakers
she was according to the criteria at the
top of the list if we have such a law as
this bill proposes and Massachusetts
then had reciprocated that New Hampshire
resident would now be dead but she's not
secondly ethics there is an established
protocol that provides organs go to the
person most in need who is the best
match who is within the time window
needed and so on and so on
while is it is ethical for one to name a
close relative as a recipient
we do not discriminate on other bases
it is considered unethical
thirdly law federal law governs the
allocation of organs donated under the
Uniform Anatomical Gift Act and it
preempts the state from deviating from
the organ procurement and transportation
networks system of organ distribution
the place to change that is in
Washington
practicality the federally designated
organ procurement organization has
designated New England donor Services
Neds as the organization responsible for
coordinating organ and tissue donation
for transplant in the six New England
states
Federal Regulations require hospitals to
refer all inpatient deaths to the local
opo in our case nads for the assignment
of medically suitability and conveyance
to the recipients according to
established criteria as to who's on the
top of the wait list let me put this
bluntly if this bill becomes law nothing
will change the hospitals will still
call Neds Ned's will still follow the
federal regulations
we could argue whether those regulations
are now good the place to change them is
Washington
representative you could start wrapping
up I am okay thank you and I have a
handout and the handout has testimony
from the Senate last year and it has a
variety of Articles which cite the
various regulations and laws may I hand
that out sure go ahead
okay representative do you want to take
questions are you prepared to take
questions
any questions for representative Pearson
representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
former chairman
um I have a question about the
transplant patient down in Massachusetts
uh do you know if that patient if those
two patients were completely tied and
then in a tiebreaker if Massachusetts
adopted the same process this resident
would have lost out or if when you
trickle through the entire Matrix of
decision factors there was a significant
difference between the two which is
question I don't know the specifics of
that except she was on the top of the
list
from New Hampshire and that's why she
was given her heart I think the top of
the list from everybody thank you
thank you any other questions for
representative Pearson
yes
I'm sorry go ahead thank you chairman
McDonald thank you representative
Pearson my question is do you agree with
the representative cambrell's that there
was a near perfect scheme a few short
years ago a few short years ago and that
it changed to something much worse if
you and if you do agree with that how
would you go about changing it is there
anything that could be done at the state
level thank you hey I don't know if the
system previously were bet was better or
not and B since this is what we have the
place to change it is at that Federal
level with the appropriate federal laws
and regulations and so on we cannot
unilaterally make a difference on that
in a given state
okay another question representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative it's good to see you
again
in regards to
what I call organ escalation in one
state trying to protect itself another
state following suit
what I heard before from the sponsor
that New Hampshire has an active donor
program and other states do may not
so how do we somehow ensure that because
we have such an active program in our
state that our residents actually
benefit from that active program versus
the donuts our organs being sent out of
state because they don't have such the
same level of activity in their program
I'm a pretty strong 10th Amendment
person and I love New Hampshire with the
Zeal of a convert
um I would encourage other states to do
this this is this whole thing is a
regional thing not a state thing this is
not a time to assert state rights
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
Pearson thank you Mr chairman
okay next up to testify is Alexandra
grazier from the New England donor
services
hopefully I pronounced your name
correctly
okay
a microphone
hit the button for the microphone how's
that that's great wonderful
I am Alexandra Glazier I'm the president
and CEO of New England donor Services we
are the charitable non-profit
organization the Oregon procurement
organization the opo that is responsible
for coordinating deceased organ donation
for transplant in the New England states
and of course importantly here in New
Hampshire
I do want to I I have submitted written
testimony that's quite extensive and I
don't want to take the time to repeat
that here but I do want to address a
couple of pieces of significant
misinformation that have been presented
this morning the current allocation
system already has a tiebreaker built
into it that's based on proximity and
what I mean by that is if you have two
patients that otherwise are similarly
situated in terms of the medical urgency
in terms of the time waiting in terms of
the biological match with an available
organ then the patient who is closer to
where the donor organ is available will
be prioritized and is currently
prioritized that is the tie breaker keep
in mind that organ allocation is for the
benefit of patience not States so that
the entire higher system of organ
allocation and regulation thereof is
focused on how to prioritize patients
most in need and do so fairly let me
talk about fairly
since this policy was changed and
actually let me take a moment and just
say why the policy was changed because
in fact the service area was imperfect
and patients important patients were
disadvantaged like pediatric patients
who were not seeing the the same volume
of transplant across the country also
other disparities racial ethnic and
Geographic disparities existed and so
the change to move to a 250 mile circle
for kidneys which was also replicated
for other organs was done in order to
standardize the unit of distribution of
organs but again
circled around where the donor is so the
idea of proximity remains a key
component of all this what did the data
show since this policy was implemented
kidneys from deceased donors that were
transplanted in New Hampshire went from
12 in 2020 to 9 in 2021 to 11 in 2022 22
percent increase has occurred since this
policy was implemented in 2021 through
the end of this prior year those are
transplants in New Hampshire please keep
in mind that New Hampshire has a single
transplant program and only kidneys so
any New Hampshire resident requiring a
heart requiring a lung requiring a liver
or pancreas is going to have to travel
outside of New Hampshire so while the
sponsor may not be concerned if other
states implement this law those patients
who are waiting for hearts livers lungs
will certainly care and be concerned
because they must receive their
transplant care outside of New Hampshire
it is indeed a regional system here the
other thing I would mention is that
organ transplants of all types for New
Hampshire residents regardless of which
state it occurred because again all of
the transplants other than kidney are
occurring outside New Hampshire for New
Hampshire patients saw a 36 percent
increase this past year from 2021 when
there were 72 deceased organ transplants
for patients who reside in New Hampshire
to 98 in 2022 that is the National Data
that's publicly available and it is in
my testimony so I think just to sum it
up because I'd really like to take any
questions you have since we are the
entity responsible for doing the
coordination of this work I would say
that this bill is unnecessary because
tiebreaker based on proximity is already
built into the national policy that it
would disadvantage New Hampshire
patients particularly those needing
anything other than kidney I'd also
mentioned that
half of the New Hampshire residents who
received kidney transplants last year
did so outside of New Hampshire the
program in New Hampshire is quite small
and it's at Dartmouth so those who live
in the southern part of the state tend
to seek their transplant care elsewhere
with that I am I'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
thank you very much questions for the MS
Glazier
go ahead representative
microphone
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh do you have any data to
um to extend what we heard before that
the waiting line in New Hampshire uh in
some hospitals increased from three to
five to eight years and also like the
number of deaths on waiting lists
increased significantly
that I do not believe that it's accurate
to say patients are waiting eight years
for kidney transplant and that is not
what the National Data show and that is
been carefully monitored at the federal
level because the entire intent of this
change in allocation policy is to
equalize the transplant weight and the
modeling that was done and so so far the
data that we see with that first full
year after the policy was implemented is
that the wait times have not gone up
substantially and that the transplant
numbers have increased across the board
as for deaths on the waitlist I have not
looked at that data in particular for
New Hampshire but again I would say that
this is being monitored nationally and
the entire purpose of the policy is to
ensure that there's an increase in
transplant which has occurred year over
year in the U.S and that those most in
need most urgently in need are being
transplanted first based on a number of
factors including proximity to the donor
organ which as I mentioned is a key part
of the current policy and is used in in
tiebreaker and actually let me give an
example of that if a patient is waiting
at Dartmouth for for a kidney and a
patient that is similarly situated in
terms of Acuity sickness and is a
biological match is waiting at Yale New
Haven Hospital in Connecticut if a
kidney becomes available in New
Hampshire it's the equivalent of that
patient would receive the kidney two
years ahead of the patient at Yale
that's the way the scoring system works
in terms of using proximity to ensure
that kidneys are are allocated first to
those in need and in a tiebreaker
situation closest to where the donor
becomes available
can I have a follow-up sure follow-up uh
would you be able to look for that data
specifically for New Hampshire and if
you find it to send it to us of course
and just so I make sure I provide what
you're looking for New Hampshire
waitlist deaths
or New Hampshire patients waiting
anywhere
um
if you can find it okay
yeah be happy to do that thank you thank
you representative thank you any other
questions other representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman and also thank you
Miss Glazier for taking my question
it appears to be the only place that we
have sort of a say you know so much to
say but in New Hampshire anyways because
Dartmouth only does at this point in
time kidney transplants
help me understand if I am a living
donor
I get to say where I want that kidney to
go I have control over it is that
correct
yes that's a correct however once I
deceased
I lose that Authority
yes and so uh the Uniform Anatomical
Gift Act is a state law that has been
enacted in every state in the country
that governs the
um the donation of organs after your
death and what the Uniform Anatomical
Gift Act has said for over 40 years here
in New Hampshire and in every state in
the country is that upon your death you
can make a gift specifically to an
individual just as you can when you're
living what you can't do
is make it to a category of individuals
and that is in fact what this bill would
be attempting to do and that's also true
as a living donor you cannot say I wish
to give my kidney but but only to a
child or or only just someone of a
certain race or religion so you can name
an individual and it's intended to
ensure there is some autonomy rights
built into the system such that if you
have a personal relationship a family
member who could benefit from that gift
that that is permitted otherwise the
system is really designed to maximize
the saving of lives and the way to do
that is to prioritize the sickest
Patients First within a biological match
and within a geographic distance that
will ensure the usability of the organ
for its intended purpose transplant
thank you for that clarification thank
you yes representative did you have a
question
I asked this question before and I'd
like to hear the answer from you I mean
we can do whatever we want here but is
it enforceable that this bill passed
would that be enforceable
I I believe that National allocation
which is done at HHS through regulations
through statute federal statute preempts
any state law that would alter organ
allocation as to whether or not you
could put a check box you know on the
license itself you know obviously that's
up to you and your Authority but as the
organization that's held responsible to
follow Federal Regulation we would have
a conflict in law and that would also be
true for any transplant program like
Dartmouth who is responsible and
obligated to follow federal law
representative Leon
um thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for being here to answer these
questions
um I I looked over the criteria and the
laws the Federal Regulations around
allocation and it only said that you
cannot specify it based on state or
geography unless it's included in items
one through five some of those were
talking about equity and when you are
presenting your data you said that there
were issues around pediatric racial
ethnic and Geographic discrimination my
question is if there's I recognize that
your data from 2020 2021 and 2022 show
that there wasn't a problem then which
is fantastic but that's also been the
covid years I'd be interested in a
longer look at historically what our
rates are to try and figure out and make
sure that there are not inequities for
our patients whether they're here or
sitting at Mass General where you'd have
the same distance factor and there could
be a tiebreaker just I'd like to
understand how their human Geographic
discrimination and how we can address
that if that's in fact in here yeah
that's a great question and the
statutory site you found is exactly what
was relied upon to ensure that this
allocation reform was actually
accomplished and that's because as I
mentioned we want to make sure that
proximity is part of the allocation
system for two reasons one to make sure
organs remain viable so this is why
we're not shipping Hearts from Boston to
California yet someday we might have
Innovation so we'll allow us to do that
but that proximity is a really important
part to ensuring organ viability and
also that proximity is an important part
to making sure that there's not
Geographic disparities and so for what
we saw in the previous policy is relying
on service areas which are highly
variable so ours was the six New England
states but for example there were three
opio service areas in Ohio in one state
and when you look across the country and
there's 56 opos there are service areas
were highly variable and so what that
resulted in was Geographic disparities
because it was the service area of the
of the opio being used as a proximity
measure instead what the system did was
make it uniform I said we're going to
use 250 miles rather than service areas
so it's the same all the way across the
country and what we've seen is that the
geographic disparities have actually
already significantly reduced as to
whether the system was working well for
our region beforehand I can tell you
that patients in New England waited much
longer than other areas of the country
especially for livers especially for
livers but for other organs as well and
what this reform did because it was done
across the board for every organ was
start to reduce that disparity and that
was the primary goal of that reform and
it is being monitored so we certainly
can provide additional data you
mentioned for example you know what did
it look like before well I can tell you
before covet in 2017 there there was a
single deceased kidney donation
transplant in New Hampshire one and in
2022 there were 11. in 2018 there were
five in 2019 big jump up there were 13.
and then the years that you mentioned 12
9 and 11. so we really you know have not
seen a negative impact of this organ
allocation policy for either transplants
performed in New Hampshire which would
be kidney transplants at Dartmouth or
most importantly I would think for New
Hampshire residents in need of any
transplant and those transplants
occurring in multiple different states
thank you
another question Jeff yes sir
I have one more question thank you Mr
chairman
um what I want to understand 250 miles
what states do you represent
so our organization covers all six New
England states although Vermont is split
down the middle so we service the
Eastern portion of Vermont Maine New
Hampshire Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut
but the the system and the allocation
policies are done at the national level
through Department of Health and Human
Services which oversees the organ
procurement and Transplant Network the
optn which as mentioned before is run
through contract with eunos which runs
the wait list
thank you yes sir go ahead thank you Mr
chairman
um I have a quick question about
priorities or discrimination is it under
current law is it possible for
um well for example
um citizenship or legal status is it
possible right now that an illegal
immigrant could have priority or get an
organ over a U.S citizen so citizen
Citizenship status is not part of the
allocation policy by federal statute
allocation policy is to be based on
medical criteria
and geography to the extent required for
the same reasons we were speaking about
before
to ensure organs aren't wasted and that
they remain viable and to ensure that
there's equity in the system so
citizenship is not currently considered
keep in mind too that deceased donors
come from any individual who happens to
be here when they die and one other
point I might make about that and
follow-up to one that was made earlier
we are we benefit from a region that has
great donor registration rates and also
authorization rates by the family but
that's actually true in many other parts
of the country as well and while
historically New York had lower rates
they've had significant increases over
the past three years which coincide with
this policy change as well in fact last
year alone I think that their growth
surpassed the national average by either
two or three-fold
okay thank you thank you other questions
do you know hands so so okay thank you
very much thank you
okay next up to testify is John marasco
from the New Hampshire Division of Motor
Vehicles
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh thank you for the the
opportunity to speak before you this
morning my name is John marasco I'm the
director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles here in New Hampshire you've
already heard testimony we do oppose
this bill I won't take a a few moments
to offer some thoughts
um one of the one of the areas I wanted
to address as far as if this bill were
to pass from a a financial standpoint it
would be an update to our form and and
that's something that we could we could
certainly handle there were a few
technical defects in this bill when you
review the current statute one of which
is the current statute 263.41 does
identify exactly what is
relayed from the New Hampshire DMV to
New England donor services
and if uh if there was a change to the
form that information as far as New
Hampshire only
um is not uh is not actually in this
bill and that would um that would have
to be something that would have to be
added because the criteria are very
specific
um the other piece that would have to be
reviewed is um what the symbol on the
license what it would not look like if
there was going to be a change if it was
New Hampshire based only
um we uh we did testify on this bill
when it previously came up we opposed it
then
um you know obviously you've heard the
testimony here and many of those items
are things that we have discussed with
New England donor Services I can tell
you that the New Hampshire DMV has a a
very strong relationship we have 54
percent of New Hampshire residents that
do donate when they come into the DMVs
and and that's a very positive number
but um
um that's what I have for you this
morning so I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I just needed the
statutory reference again that you that
you stated yes uh 263.41 donor registry
for anatomical gifts
thank you I was nowhere near close so I
appreciate that thank you
other questions for the director
we're all set thank you very much thank
you
the next stop to testify is Kelly George
is George
microphone please thank you Mr chairman
and good morning everyone my name is
Kelly George I live in Enfield New
Hampshire I am a heart transplant
recipient and I oppose this bill
on December 3rd 2009 I received the gift
of con continued life from an anonymous
donor
prior to my transplant I struggled each
day with end-stage heart failure
once listed each day brought anxiety and
worry wondering if that call saying our
heart had been found would come to save
my life
because New Hampshire's only Transplant
Center Dartmouth health does not perform
heart transplants I was referred to
Tufts Medical Center in Boston
together the two medical centers care
for me until the long awaiting call came
on December 2nd 2009 I made my way to
Massachusetts received my transplant and
have enjoyed a full life since
hearing the words you have two years
maybe less before you need a transplant
to survive was devastating
if our surrounding states were to adopt
a bill similar to HB 587 the heart I
received could have been limited to a
resident of one of those States one who
was not as sick as me one who had more
time to wait than me
if that had happened I would not be
sitting here with you today
there is a cost to implement this bill
if we use those funds to educate the
public about organ donation and the need
to become registered donors
perhaps we could help to increase the
number of organs available to the
residents of our great state of New
Hampshire
I urge you to honor the edu the ethical
and responsible policy of sick is first
which has been demonstrated to save more
lives including my own and soundly
reject the Alternatives that needlessly
put transplant patients at risk
thank you are you taking questions or
any questions from Ms George
representative King
I see you have a written testimony and
there will only have one copy so when
you're done can I have it you certainly
may thank you I have two you can have
mine okay representative clerk so he's
our Record Keeper okay
okay other questions
okay thank you very much thank you
next up is uh Paul Birch
foreign
good morning
good morning Mr chairman and good to see
you all and
it's strange being here on the side of
the microphone
um
I have some prepare remarks but there's
a few things I just want to say first
one be careful the statistics you hear
for for example we heard statistics
about
um
the number of transplants at Dartmouth
staying about the same but there's no
distinction between live uh donations
and deceased donations
and it's my information that the number
of deceased donations has gone down but
the number of live donations has not
secondly you heard a testimony about the
transportation committee last year I was
fortunate to be assigned as a fill-in to
the executive session on the
transportation committee last year when
it uh considered the bill and I can tell
you it was not a matter of you know
could they put the sticker on the
um driver's license or not the
transportation committee considered the
entire range of issues having to do with
the bill in front of it there are other
things I could comment on but first of
all I want to say I'm 100 in favor of
this legislation either the Standalone
or the amendment and I would have caused
sponsored it had I remained in the house
I am a year out myself from a live
kidney transplant so I'm not directly
affected by this bill except to the
extent that if the ability of Dartmouth
Hitchcock to take to continue its
program is significantly affected I
would have a small impact because I go
back at this point
um it's just got changed you just said
my first anniversary so it's every six
months now and other than that I'm not
affected by this bill
and
um I do want to comment about the wait
time
I was considerably older than most
people who get a kidney transplant most
places cut that off at 70. I was 75. uh
Dartmouth was willing to do it there's
many hospitals in our surrounding area
that do not if I had to wait extra time
I had a live donation for my sister in
New York City if I had to wait
eight years
instead of two or three I would not have
gotten a kidney
and I would have not survived
so the issue of the increased wait time
which is a fact
is of crucial importance to people like
me
um
nothing I hear say here should be looked
at as legal advice okay first
you have about 10 seconds representative
what you're up about 10 seconds left
well I'm going to I may land up as
others taking a little bit longer I'll
skip to the important thing as far best
I can tell HB 587 does not violate any
federal law this bill does not mandate
any deceased stone or donor organs be
available in New Hampshire only any
granted stator can leave their organ to
the General Pool
in fact the Unos distribution scheme
is completely voluntary you hear federal
laws being broken Federal Regulations
bring broken you can't break it by not
following a voluntary law it's a bit
like getting auto insurance in New
Hampshire you're not breaking any law if
you don't get auto insurance though if
you do get it there's rules and
regulations and I'll give you a quote
from the federal 11th Circuit Court of
Appeals none of the optns adopted
policies are in and of themselves
legally enforceable against members of
the transplant Community rather
compliance is strictly voluntary and for
those who want to look it up that's the
Callahan case
um there's a significant issue of
resources
across the board in rural areas in the
medical world
Dartmouth hitch Cheshire hospital had to
close his psychiatric
adolescent unit a couple years ago
because they couldn't get a doctor we
all know the difficulty in getting
nurses at our County nursing homes we
just can't get them they're not there
we have one transplant unit
in New Hampshire
I'm from I heard people in Southern New
Hampshire don't go to Dartmouth I live
virtually On the Border
outside of Keene and I went to Dartmouth
and after my transplant I had to go up
there three times a week
can you imagine having to go to Boston
three times a week
especially when you can't drive
and then it was reduced to two times a
week and then once a week Etc
it's it would have been I would have had
to rent an apartment in Boston if I had
to have my transplant in Boston and
representative you could start wrapping
up please all right
in that case I will wrap up two thoughts
one
if I can leave my Mustang to anybody I
want
and if I can leave
money to a church or a synagogue if I
wish
I should be able to leave my organ
to a granted stator
and that's just part of my freedom as an
individual
and the final thing I want to say is
this is a relatively young group here
if any of you are of an age
and of sufficient help
let me plead with you
be a Kidney donor there's a hundred and
six thousand people in this country
waiting for a kidney
people die every day waiting for kidney
and other organs you can save a life
it's amazing thing to do you can save a
life thank you thank you open to
questions I have an article Vermont
Man's Search for a kidney Complicated by
new rules for organ donations I just
happen to come across it and my written
remarks okay great if you could give us
if you're getting me marks that'd be
great but questions yes sir
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question
um and appreciate that you're here to
talk to us
um my world is driven by lies damn lies
and statistics so I do appreciate the
first thing you said and I also
appreciate the distinction that you made
between live and deceased because we're
really only talking about deceased
donors here but
um Ms Glacier provided us some
statistics here that actually I guess it
contradicts what you said here this is
kidney transplants performed in New
Hampshire where they found that there
was actually an increased incidence of
kidneys from deceased donors over the
last six years the first two years there
was small numbers kidneys from living
donors have pretty much flatlined the
entire that's a bad term to use um
stayed stable over that period of time
but the numbers are actually fairly
equal do you have any comment on that
well I'm not an expert on those
statistics but my sense is that there's
a waiting list of transplants to be done
and I would say wait two years wait
three years and see if the number of
donated kidneys my understanding is the
number of
donated kidneys is going a live kidneys
is going up and the number of deceased
kidney donations is going down now that
may initially not affect the number of
actual transplants done but we'll have
to see over time what a diminished
number of donations do if that occurs
follow up
um if any data that you could provide
would be wonderful well so I'm just
looking at numbers right here I'll see
what I can do thank you can't guarantee
it other questions
seeing none
thank you very much thank you all
right yes okay next up is Jeffrey Salo
who I understand is if I'm a member of
this committee
solid way I'm sorry apologize
I should be good at reading bad
handwriting thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee it is an
honor and a pleasure to be here uh for
the record my name is Jeffrey salloway I
am an Emeritus member of uh this
committee having served three terms
um I am also professor emeritus at the
University of New Hampshire
um prior to that I was at Rush Medical
Center in Chicago where one of my main
responsibilities was organ procurement
research at the time there were three
National famous names in organ
procurement research one was a team from
Brandeis the other was Roberta Simmons
from Minnesota and you can guess who the
third one was that was me in case it was
an obvious representative Leon if you'll
be gentle with me as we go through this
um there um as you have been told the
demand for organs runs to six figures
the supply of organs is relatively
modest for figures the biggest problem
is Oregon procurement organ procurement
is done by transplant surgeons we have
one transplant team here in New
Hampshire under the old rules of eunos
the United Network for organ sharing
the first priority for harvested organs
for procured organs was to the patients
of the transplant surgeon who procured
the organs and made perfectly good sense
and this was a major incentive for a
transplant surgeon to run an active
procurement program get me organs for my
patients because frankly my friends
organ procurement for a trained
transplant surgeon is really not the fun
part of the job the fun part of the job
is transplanting that organ into a
patient and if you've got a patient
who's waiting for an organ you want to
go out there and you want to procure
organs and get them okay first priority
patient of the procuring surgeon second
prior priority
a colleague within the organ procure
within the transplant program at the
medical center where that surgeon
practices this meant that if a medical
center put together a team for a
transplant
all the colleagues on that team wanted
their fellows to go out and procure
organs and that provided a supply of
organs for those colleagues as well
third priority local region so I was in
Chicago we had five transplant services
in Chicago everybody in Chicago worked
together as colleagues to procure organs
we were doing the best we could to
enhance the supply of organs great going
okay
under and after that after Regional
distribution we went to a national
system and that's where eunos came in
okay now we go to the new rules and
under the new rules if you were a
bureaucrat in Washington I thank
goodness that you are not if you were a
bureaucrat in Washington you would look
at the epidemiological demand for organs
and you would say in New York City in
New Haven in Hartford we've got a huge
demand okay and we have a huge demand
because we have a minority population a
poor population where the epidemiologic
need is substantially higher than a
place like New Hampshire so as a result
organs will tend to gravitate to where
the demand is under the new rules driven
by the epidemiology
what that means is
our transplant surgeons will have less
access locally to the organs that they
want to transplant take a look at the
disincentive here this means that our
transplant surgeons
don't have the organs to transplant and
folks that's the fun part of their job
okay if and you may know it was
mentioned because you're not wrapping up
sir yes the only
program we have here in New Hampshire is
kidney we don't have heart we don't have
liver the reason why we we recruited to
Dartmouth Jacques McCullough a heart
transplant surgeon from New Jersey and
he has never gotten the program of heart
transplant that he was promised and the
reason why is that those organs the
hearts are disappearing they're not
there he doesn't know the fellow
fellowship program doesn't have the
program my friends we take care of one
another we are New Hampshire we're
different we don't root for the Yankees
we don't root for the Giants we don't
root for the Knickerbockers okay we are
New Hampshire we take care of one
another you've now lived through several
days of miserable snow and one of the
things that you saw was the messages on
your phone and on your email that said I
have a spare bedroom if you need a place
to stay come because we are in New
Hampshire we're different we're not New
York we're not new Connecticut we take
care of one another first this bill is a
nice step in that direction thank you
very much questions if you have them
thank you very much questions from
Professor soloway
thank you very much
representative Freight is how lovely to
see you
representative Freitas go ahead
together
on the committee
did you have a question or oh okay okay
uh yes representative kofault
so am I to understand
um
representative saloway thank you Mr
chairman thank you for for coming to
testify representative
am I to understand then that that
in New Hampshire we are not able to
develop organ transplant programs to the
extent that we other might otherwise
might be
if we if we had a bill like this in
place as usual representative you are
incisive and correct
okay that was quick any other questions
thank you so much ladies and gentlemen
it's been an honor
uh thank you Mr chairman is
um isn't one other reason we don't have
them in New Hampshire because
we really don't have the the volumes to
justify a system even if the organs
were available there is there is a
demand but it goes out of town so we
heard from a witness who had a heart
transplant at Tufts which has a major
transplant program we've got a number of
them in Boston and we dare I say leak uh
patients in need down to Boston
okay other questions
okay
thank you thank you very much
and uh what appears to be the last card
I have is
Aaron Kutcher
I'm reading the reading it correctly
by the way um as I've mentioned as I've
mentioned uh representative Leon I've
got to get some cataract surgery later
on in February so if I miss you or
misread your name that's why it's not on
purpose so welcome
all right is this on
all right I'm Erin Contino sorry for the
messy handwriting
um and I oppose the spell
when I was six months old I had a virus
attack my heart which caused me to go
into heart failure and for a year of my
life I went through medical trials
eventually my heart was functioning at
one percent and I was placed on the
waitlist for a heart transplant I had a
mirror 24 hours to get a heart or else I
would die
my case was unique where I was so sick
they were able to go outside of the
normal range and match me with heart in
Missouri
as it stands today organs are given to
the sickest person and in November of
1996 that person was me
the spell aims to allow organs based on
state borders and in doing so it would
deprive the neediest person of a
life-saving transplant and I feel this
bill is short-sighted
as you've heard in New Hampshire there's
one transplant center in the state and
it only focuses on limited organs this
automatically excludes a large
population of recipients and those in
waiting
as a small state with already limited
medical resources this will drive people
to receive care elsewhere and I count my
blessings every day that this limitation
did not exist in 1996 or else I wouldn't
be here today
I wouldn't have gotten married welcomed
my nieces and nephews and most recently
become a mother myself
the concept of organ hoarding undermines
the primary premise of organ donation
which is altruism as a final Act of a
person's life
thank you for your consideration
thank you very much uh are you taking
questions or sure any questions for the
uh
lady here
yeah well thank you very much for coming
in today
I have no other pink cards anyone else
here want to testify in this legislation
okay see ignorant I am going to close
the public hearing on HB 587 and open
the public hearing on HB 47 and once
again recognize the prime sponsor who is
representative Jose cambrells
thank you Mr chairman again for the
record I am representative Jose
Campbell's Merrimack County District 4
serving the towns of Canterbury and
Loudoun
I want to thank the committee for
allowing us the time to present this
bill today
in the interest of efficiency I will be
yielding my time as the main sponsor to
the expert on the issues that
necessitated this bill
I would like to introduce Linda Jordan
she is a registered nurse that has a
long and storied professional career
she is well known in the Health Care
Health Care circles and fondly called LK
by the many people that know her in the
Concord region
currently and for the last 18 years she
has been the proprietor of medical
analysis and Research Services a
Consulting integrative nurse practice
located in Bow New Hampshire
she approached me with the very
disturbing details of why this bill was
necessary back in the spring of 2021 and
with that I will turn it over to Ms
Jordan
okay thank you good morning nice to be
here
the seeds for the creation of this bill
were planted more than two decades ago
unfortunately the circumstances that
allowed and promoted the breakdown of
care that caused this death remain today
in 2001 Michael Burley a resident of New
Hampshire age 26 was to become the
youngest ever chief engineer for Global
for the global Oil Corporation in their
history
in early February 2001 Michael's
accident occurred it took less than 10
minutes for the ambulance to arrive and
the hospital was only five minutes away
he sported a shaved head worn earring
was on a motorcycle was from out of
state
and had organ donor designation on his
New Hampshire driver's license
there were many substandard missteps by
multiple Health Care Professionals that
met the legal criteria for malpractice
there were also unseen motivating
incentives the ins in the institution's
business structure that allowed greed to
become crime
had this bill been in place in 2001 the
additional layer of accountability it
provides would have altered Michael's
Hospital course of care and blocked the
tragic outcome
I'm sure that this summation has left
you with more questions than answers and
I'm sorry for that I have little doubt
that the whole story will be told on
film if not in print fairly soon it must
be told
the purpose of hb47 is to save lives the
enactment of this measure would assure
that victims of traumatic injury injury
would assure victims of traumatic injury
that they will receive the best possible
possible care as attempts are made to
save their life
this will increase the number of
citizens willing to be registered as
organ donors
the greatest number of viable organ
donors and tissues are harvested from
victims of trauma
every minute counts in trauma this is
why Advanced Trauma Life Support
protocols
were developed and instituted they
provide a method that is immediate for
the immediate management of
traumatically injured patients the
approach is systematic and concise as
well as safe reliable and and the
accepted standard of practice
for more than more than a hundred
thousand people are waiting for an organ
as you've heard many times today more
than a hundred thousand people are
waiting for an organ transplant in the
United States the majority of these
people will die on the waiting list
95 percent of Americans are in favor of
organ donation yet only 58 are actually
registered
we can increase the number of citizens
willing to register as an organ donor
by diminishing the fear that underpins
the hesitancy
if I have if I have organ donor on my
driver's license
and I receive the BET am I going to
receive the best care
to save my life when I need it
if I'm out of town and I get injured and
there's someone somebody on the organ
donor list that everybody knows are they
going to do everything to save my life
this bill when enacted will give
assurances
to the public that the expectation of
Best Care is reasonable and that those
responsible for making the decisions in
critical moments will be held
accountable
this will be done through legislation to
add a signature page to the medical
record in order for the remains to be
deemed eligible for organ or tissue
transplant
through a mandated one-page document
added to the permanent medical records
of all donors the objectives of this
bill will be accomplished
this new Doc document must be hand
signed not computer signed by the most
direct treating member of the trauma
team prior to death
they will legally attest that all
appropriate atls protocols were fully
implemented in their attempts to save
the life
this document will be signed by no less
than three licensed professionals who
are active participants in the trauma
team
at least one must be a physician those
who sign must be lead team members based
on the level of trauma care designated
to the facility this is for trauma the
we have level one level two level three
level four and five Trauma Centers this
is according to their criteria
the past Saturday this past Saturday
morning
it was put in really hard to shed some
light into the darkness
and I really appreciate the efforts that
went in
to move this bill forward
but with this testimony I'm respectfully
asking
that this committee recommend interim
study for this bill
let me tell you why
I've served in many and and varied roles
in over 50 years
in nursing I and my colleagues have been
really overwhelmed with grief and
despair at what we are seeing
the health care delivery system of our
local hospitals and committees and
communities
have collapsed
the community's nursing support
structures visiting nurses hospice have
burst at the seams
the global pandemic has indeed pushed
all of the stressed pre-pran pandemic
infrastructures of Health Care over the
edge
we don't have enough trained doctors and
nurses to answer the needs of our
population
this is a global crisis Nationwide
nursing schools lack educators in excess
of 80 000 potential nursing students
have been rejected because there are no
teachers to instruct them
in the news we have only seen
smatterings of how just how serious this
is
recently I have witnessed this breakdown
firsthand in our emergency rooms in
hospitals in doctors offices in the
homes of the unwell
it is tragic and screaming for attention
and resolution
in light of this crisis situation I have
come to believe that as important as HB
47 is to saving lives it is not Timely
our current system cannot implement or
sustain the very minimal tasks that the
passage of this bill would require one
additional page on the medical record
and three additional signatures would be
too much
emergency rooms are overrun people are
in dire need and waiting an average of 6
to 12 hours to be seen
then they are placed in packed hallways
waiting for beds for another 6 to 12
hours when admitted to the hospitals
patient did not receive the basics of
good care
help to the bathroom washing setups bed
changes consistent Vital sign monitoring
necessary medical testing and
interventions appropriate discharge
appropriate discharge planning and
coordination with either VNA or hospice
primary care physicians are not even
notified that their patients have been
admitted to the hospital
Hospital medical records no longer
automatically find their way to the
Primary Care Physician's office
it is almost impossible to get a
specialist appointment regardless of the
severity of need most are unavailable
for three to six months
or more
to many in many instances the delay
takes lives
please may our coming together on this
organ donor issue also serve as a
catalyst to get us thinking about the
important questions to be asked and a
call to action for practical change
where are we how did we get here where
do we need to go and how do we get there
how do we change Healthcare education to
meet the needs of the current and future
population
what is com what is continuity of care
why is it essential how do we restore it
how do we heal we must begin to
integrate our Collective advances in
knowledge science and technology in new
ways I asked this body and all of you
present to have the eyes to see and the
ears to hear the crying of our world at
this most critical moment
I ask each of you with your positions of
influence to open your hearts and
dedicate your awareness to these issues
none among you will avoid the suffering
rooted in this dilemma
we must join together we must Foster and
promote Innovation integrated with
time-tested experience and wisdom
we have no choice but to develop a new
paradigm of Health Care delivery
we need not pull the covers up over our
heads and hide there is hope there are
many who have been working to fix much
of this isolated in small corners and
large places in private practices
institutions organizations corporations
and universities many of these possess
essential pieces of the puzzle it's time
to bring them together our very lives
depend on it I respectfully and humbly
thank you for your time your attention
and consideration
hey thank you
uh and if you could give a copy of that
written testimony to our Clark
representation I have 20 copies here oh
okay thank you feel free to go ahead and
distribute them
um
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question I know you
um
you pivoted away from your initial
discussion about this bill to a larger
concern about our health care System but
if we can go back to the initial
discussion about the bill
um
you know in my short time in the house
I've become wary of passing laws because
of an anecdote or a series of anecdotes
so
um the implication that um
people will not get the proper Medical
Care
um because it's an incentive to harvest
their organs is a pretty um yes that's
quite a charge and I wonder if other
than the anecdote that you referenced
without detail if there is any data that
you're aware of or any kind of um
longitudinal information that would lead
us to know whether this is really a
problem or not okay but
I mean incentives
that were built into the business
structures of some facilities and it
exists in many others as well
where there is
there's a kickback
that goes to the heads and particularly
at Community Hospitals there's a
kickback that goes to the com to the
heads of specific departments
um for the monies that are brought into
Community Hospitals because they don't
show a profit they just expand as they
grow let's let's try to keep it as
focused on the bill as possible I'm
trying I know it's a huge issue and a
huge topic okay there are structures
within the system that do
um incentivize people not necessarily
getting the care so that their organs
can be utilized
other questions
yes representative Merchant and this
would fix that
it would just wipe it right out it's a
follow-up thank you Mr chairman for
and also thank you for taking the
question
I like representative Shapiro I'm
struggling here
um
what I'm hearing is troublesome and it's
looking at and saying
our health care professional particular
Physicians
are putting their oath to the patient
aside for a business reason
in saying that
is the place of this to be
resolved in a court of law from a
liability point of view and not
regulating Medical Practice I just we
have so many things please let me finish
we have so many things going on if you
will
within the Health Care system to as you
said before to Overlay this onto them I
struggle with it so would it not be more
appropriate for this to be dealt with in
a court of law from a liability point of
view if somebody's not living up their
oath if you will thank you
okay
um
yes and no actually what I'm saying this
is not it's not a legal issue what it is
is just bringing attention
to the reality that if someone
if anyone on the Trump team knows hey I
gotta sign a paper that says I've done
everything I can do to support the ALS
protocols that's going to bring more
attention and they will put more
attention on it this wouldn't have
fallen through the cracks if that was
there it's not that the health care
practitioners are doing anything and
that are they are Sinister it's just
that this would put a line of defense
that would have blocked that from
occurring
other questions
did you help me go ahead
hi um I've been a doctor for 35 years
now
um if I could count the number of times
somebody told me that I just needed to
sign one more form I can't hear you I'm
sorry I've been a physician for 35 years
now and I I if I could count the number
of times somebody's asked me to say it's
just one more form I need to sign which
then creates the problem that you just
said that now my swivel chair is not
facing the patient it's facing the other
direction my my priorities are in the
wrong place and I'm really concerned
that having trauma peoples sign just
another form
is number one it's not going to
accomplish much because we are held
liable to ethical standards already
I have to document everything I do
everything is written down in the
medical record that I've done for this
patient and that the medical board has
access to that if need be so what I'm
struggling is why this would change
anything and secondly
why would that affect organ procurement
okay which is why we're here why would
that would that change anything number
one we changed all the medical records
predominantly throughout the country to
the computer generated medical record in
2001. and when we made that change it
shifted a lot of
attention in a lot of ways and I can say
that as a nurse it became let me just
fill in this box let me just do this and
it altered Medical Care
and I'm not so sure it's a good thing
um
but that's another Point what I'm what
I'm saying here is because we have
now have this automated record the fact
that this would have a signature on it
rather than a checked box is something
that says wait maybe I need to make a
little bit more sure of this in the rush
of what we're doing that we're meeting
the protocols in this particular case
there were at least seven people who
just got lost in the process
and had this been at the end it would
just bring awareness to it and how would
it increase the organ procurement there
are a lot of people that won't put organ
donor on their license because they have
just these fears that I stated earlier
that say hey am I going to get the best
treatment
this took place at one of the top organ
doning facilities in the country that's
not the case everywhere else but the
bottom line is there are still people
that are afraid to get organ donor on
their license because they're not sure
if they're going to get the best care so
let's give them additional
accountability and say you know what
we're doing this this this piece of
paper is there trauma teams are are made
aware of this and Trauma data and
they're thinking more about it to just
make them feel comfortable okay I took
it off my license after I worked on this
thank you any other questions yes go
ahead
thank you Mr chairman is it current law
that um a physician has to legally
um
legally obey Advanced Trauma Life
Support protocols right now is it
current law that they have to legally do
these things
it is for trauma teams they are trauma
it's their they're required it's their
standard of care it's not a law
it's not a law okay
care or not law s other questions for
these folks
I see none okay thank you thank you
okay next up to testify
uh
um once again Alexander Raja
I probably still didn't pronounce that
correctly from the New England donor
Services New England donut Services yes
yes Alexandra Glazier president CEO of
New England donor Services thank you for
having me back I did submit some written
testimony and again rather than repeat
that I want to hit on a couple of key
points here as you know New England
donor Services is the charitable
nonprofit responsible for coordinating
organ donation and the last bill we were
talking about organ allocation this bill
is the first part of the process which
is identifying that there are potential
donors uh just to put some perspective
on this every hospital in the U.S is
required to refer a death that occurs in
the hospital to their opo for New
England this equates to about 50 000
death referrals a year
however only about two percent of those
referrals have any medical opportunity
for organ donation there's a very strict
medical criteria and clinical screen to
make sure that it's a suitable donor for
transplant that will result in medical
benefit for the transplant recipient
rather than any harm for example active
cancer would be a rule out and and other
conditions that might make it not
possible for organ donation to go
forward therefore think about a bill
like this and just to put some numbers
on it last year alone New Hampshire
hospitals referred nearly 5 000 deaths
to New England donor services that was
in 2022 again only about two percent
were ultimately found to be medically
suitable for possible organ donation
this would require this bill would
require almost fifteen thousand
signatures from emergency department
staff if it had been implemented at that
time one really important point for the
committee to know is that the donor
registry can only be accessed by the
opio and that only occurs after we've
received the referral which as I
mentioned happens after the patient has
died this is a really important
protection that's put in place
Nationwide and certainly here in our
region so that emergency department
staff do not know and do not have access
to the registry at the time that they
are caring for a patient
aggressive care of patients in the
emergency department is not only
compatible with organ donation it's
actually necessary if aggressive care
and appropriate trauma care is not
implemented then the patient dies in a
manner unsuitable for organ donation
because the patient must be resuscitated
and on a ventilator before they pass
away for organ donation to be a medical
opportunity so just from a clinical
perspective important to understand that
aggressive trauma care in accordance
with best practices and medical
standards is completely compatible with
how we coordinate organ donation there
are no Financial incentives for organ
donor hospitals to coordinate organ
donation because again it's the opo and
not the hospital that coordinates the
organ donation and with that I think I'm
I'm happy to take any questions
any questions that you may have thank
you very much any questions for the MS
Glazier
yes sir
thank you Mr chair based on the
testimony of the last witness it sounds
like
please correct her or me if if we're
wrong here ATS atls Protocols are not
required by law and
um if this bill were to become enacted
that in order to get an organ into the
donation system if if there were a
doctor or nurses that didn't follow all
of those atls protocols and then still
signed this they would be committing
perjury right is that is that my
understanding is that if they didn't and
then and then they still turned around
and signed it they'd be committing
perjury whereas right now they don't
have to sign anything it's possible that
they're not legally
they're not legally forced to provide
etls protocols and and an organ could
get into the system is that correct
um it's not exactly how I would approach
it as an attorney what I would say is
that standards of care are enforced by
law through medical malpractice and
liability standards So when you say that
the ALS protocol is not law by itself
it's not law but physician missions and
other health care providers are held
accountable by law to meet medical
standards and that's done through
malpractice and liability Provisions I'm
not here on behalf of providers or on
behalf of hospitals but as an attorney I
would say that this adds a whole new
level of liability what I'm concerned
about is that this will slow down organ
donation and could very likely result in
the loss of life-saving organ
transplants
by adding a bureaucratic step those
involved in the trauma care of the
patients are not involved in the organ
donation component they'd have to be
tracked down found they may no longer be
on shift and to get a physical signature
at that time means donation will likely
not happen
thank you other questions
saying none thank you thank you
next up is Lisa Patterson
from Concord Hospital
in College of surgeries
microphone please sorry about that good
morning morning
um I would thank you for the privilege
of speaking to you all just as an
introduction my name is Dr Lisa
Patterson I'm the trauma medical
director at Concord Hospital and I've
been a trauma surgeon my entire career
and my whole passion is saving lives so
the bill proposed and the explanation I
find offensive personally I am also atls
instructor for 30 plus years I also
teach rural trauma development course in
New Hampshire so I have a lot of
experience in this I think that the bill
proposed is misguided
and I think that it would accomplish the
actual opposite of what was mentioned in
terms of atls we teach this it's the
ABCs and permit me to just go over that
a little bit a stands for Airway and
somebody who's not breathing well gets a
tube down their throat to help them with
controlling secretions and not and to
help them breathing b stands for
breathing so anybody who's going to be
an organ donor is not breathing well on
their own so they are automatically on a
ventilator
C stands for circulation and you have to
support their circulation by giving them
fluids by giving them blood if needed
and possibly medications to support
their blood pressure so that's the ABCs
and that's the principle and as
mentioned this is standard of care this
is what's done in all Trauma Centers it
is standard practice so we don't
document atls principles because we all
do it so
this bill is going to accomplish just
the opposite of decreasing the
um the donors that I see because of what
you mentioned is it's it's an extra step
in documentation the people that were
involved in the initial resuscitation
May no longer be present maybe on
vacation off shift and so to actually
require this is ridiculous nurses do not
take atls that is a course for
Physicians and more recently for
Advanced Care Providers and physician
assistants
and I think on a more personal note my
driver's license says I'm an organ donor
and I have been saving lives my entire
life if I have a traumatic injury the
most common being a devastating brain
injury I want all my organs to be used
to save lives and this bill would
possibly cause a bureaucratic hiccup in
this that my organs would go to waste
because because one of three signatures
was not on there and I just think that's
wrong
and why is this bill only targeting
trauma patients because there are other
medical conditions that lead to organ
donation the biggest is massive Strokes
where somebody has no chance of survival
and they're brain dead and their organs
are also harvested so why Target
patients who have a devastating
traumatic injuries that they cannot
survive or they are brain dead and not
Target others so thank you very much
thank you you've taken questions
absolutely any questions for this uh
individual
yes Dr Nagel representative Nagel sorry
thank you Mr chair
thank you I just have a question that
just occurred to me that maybe for
anybody but I'll ask good of you
um
a lot of the donor organs are not coming
from trauma what do you have any idea
what percentage of donated organs
actually come from trauma situations as
a trauma surgeon I cannot answer that
I'm sure that the the opio system can
answer how many come from medical
conditions there are a huge number of
types people who drown that are then
brain dead massive stroke where they
will never recover so ideal in my field
we deal with it's predominantly those
patients who are have a devastating uh
non-survivable brain injury or they have
severed their spinal cord up at the
point where they can't breathe and
already at the scene they've sustained
what we call a hypoxic brain injury they
can't breathe there's no Oxygen to their
brain and they're brain dead so those
are the types of patients that we deal
with
thank you
other questions
okay thank you very much
okay next up to testify is Gina wurtzer
from trauma programs
hi thank you for having me my name is
Gina wurtzer I am a 26-year RN I am I've
been an ed Trauma Nurse for the last 24
years I defected from New York state to
come live in New Hampshire five years
ago and I do work at Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center I am the adult trauma
program manager I've been involved in
the trauma care of our my new neighbors
my new community and I would like to
clarify a few points that were made
today
when I first learned of this legislation
five days ago my initial questions were
was the Genesis of this amendment which
I just learned 10 minutes ago who is
sponsoring this and why before
advocating for or opposing anything I
try to understand the concerns of those
I'm supporting or in this case opposing
I reviewed the personal biography
biographies of the four gentlemen
sponsoring this bill and found not one
trauma surgeon any surgeon or emergency
medicine provider much less anybody with
a medical background nor could I find it
anywhere the background information that
triggered a need for a met for this
amendment to house bill 47.
so as I was unable to come prepared with
a counter-argument to an unknown
quantity I will present a few facts and
considerations
while it is offered during an emergency
Medicine Residency in a general surgery
residency Advanced Trauma Life Support
is not a current is not a required
certification to remain currency
and there is no requirement to maintain
I'm sorry to maintain current
certification for emergency medicine or
surgeons
the exceptions to this would be for
American College of Surgeons verified
Trauma Centers reviewed by the committee
on trauma who have received a
verification in an entire trauma program
there are only two individuals who are
required is a condition of verification
to maintain atls currency
um individuals who are not currently
atls certified cannot possibly attest
that all appropriate hls protocols were
followed and it would be fraudulent for
them to do so these guidelines not
protocols I will verify their guidelines
are revised every few years so unless
you are current you don't know
fact nurses do not take atls and cannot
possibly be certified in atls I am a
16-year instructor of advanced trauma
course for nurse taught by the Society
of trauma nurses it's a completely
separate corollary course nurses cannot
take atls
it would be legally fraudulent for any
nurse to document an attestation that
atls protocols incorrect word were
followed
the verbiage used in this amendment that
atls protocols in quote are being
followed as incorrect Protocols are
rigid statements they're standardized
rules to which one must adhere
atls is an amalgam of practice
guidelines not protocols guidelines
create a framework and provide General
recommendations for decision making
depending on any number of variables
being presented in a particular
situation
and for those cases of traumatic injury
quote unquote to which this amendment
refers I must emphasize that atls may
never have been clinically indicated in
many of these cases
can anyone sponsoring this bill or
anyone voting for it for that matter
explain to me
when atls might have been clinically
indicated for an injured patient
who makes that clinical determination
during these critical hours and if you
cannot tell me I suggest you rethink
what you are proposing today
my last consideration with all due
respect is a medical professional I
would expect any medical related
legislation to be sponsored by a subject
matter expert and where that might not
be possible that a reasonable amount of
research diligence and collaboration
with a subject matter expert be
demonstrated by those sponsoring a bill
I guess I need to pay better attention
to goings on here in Concord as a
private citizen of New Hampshire I'm
disappointed that legislation of this
magnitude that actually Advocates are
you wrapping up yes for medical legal
fraudulence albeit unintentional could
be pushed through with so little regard
for facts as well as the downstream
consequences of denying the citizens of
the state the gift of life through organ
donation thank you for your time
any you have written testimony ma'am I
have notes that I wrote down on the way
here if you want written testimony I'd
prefer to make it a little more
professional looking fine that's fine
you could email it sure I'd be happy to
any questions for this lady
seeing none thank you very much
uh next here to testify is Paula minahan
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good morning good morning is it still
morning yes it is um I will be quick um
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Paula minihan
Senior vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all 26 acute
care hospitals as well as our specialty
hospitals we are opposed to House Bill
and I will not repeat what has already
been stated but we do believe this bill
is not necessary and would add
complexities and time delays to the
current organ donation program the
current system is already complex and is
which is necessary to ensure the highest
quality
in best performing system for organ
donations we are concerned that this
bill could have a negative impact on
transplant patients preventing some
transplants from occurring I am going to
wrap up because I know you're well
behind and there are experts here today
some that have already spoken including
the trauma surgeon from Concord Hospital
as well as the trauma nurse from
Dartmouth they are the experts they I
please listen to them these
um this bill we are very concerned about
and again as has been stated our
hospitals are under a tremendous amount
of Burden right now and this adds more
burden and again unwarranted and we ask
that you not support this bill and I um
I thank you for your time thank you
questions from MS minahan
thank you thank you
next up to testify is Eric Martin New
Hampshire cot
good morning good morning
thank you for this opportunity to speak
out against House Bill 47. uh it's hard
not to be redundant because Dr Patterson
who we did not speak with before this
meeting had a lot of the same thoughts
but for background I'm almost 12-year
trauma surgeon I do work at Dartmouth
I'm a trauma medical director there for
the past several years in addition to
that my roles include the New Hampshire
chair of the tmrc the Toronto medical
Review Committee as well as the New
Hampshire chair of the committee on
trauma committee on trauma is a section
of the American College of Surgeons who
developed this course in the 1970s with
the first course being taught in 1980
it's a course that's probably more
intended to be focused on providers who
have to deal with these emergencies in
small Urban or rural environments in
developing countries that sought across
the across the world so it's basic
principles their guidelines has been
said they are not protocols it's not a
regulatory service it's an educational
platform so I'm here speaking in much of
my own itself as well as the college
that this is not really the intent of
what atls is as you've heard it's not
taught to nurses and I like Dr Patterson
fear that as a donor on my license that
if I go in somewhere someone is probably
not going to take that legal risk of
documenting that they followed all the
hls protocols and I do find it offensive
quite honestly that I've dedicated 18
years of my life to save people and this
is the concern I think there are other
ways to overcome those concerns and
those fears and I think those of us in
the field
do everything we can and I've never once
looked at someone's wallet coming in the
door and I don't have the time to do
that because I'm trying to save their
life I don't care who they are what they
are where they come from it's all the
same to us we do everything we can and
I'm a huge advocate for for organ
donation but I do know that as Ms Glaser
said that it's about the aggressive
resuscitation in order to first and
foremost save a life if that's not
possible because of a devastating brain
injury then maybe some good can come
with it
thank you thank you now questions from
committee members representative Weber
this is simplistic
but understanding from what I'm hearing
that
the same measures that you take to save
a life
are the same measures that are necessary
to keep organs viable for donation
thank you
any other questions
yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Dr
Martin for taking my question and also
for your service which I know is
sometimes very very strenuous
um having spent 40 years as a trauma
surgeon in Orthopedics serving in the
same trauma Bays that you currently
serve in my question is this have you
ever though I have never have you ever
at any point in time when a patient
comes through the door via the
helicopter or a trauma transport have
you ever asked anybody in the trauma
team which is fairly significant
have you ever has anybody ever come to
you and said change what we do alter our
our you know treatment protocols
regardless of ACLS or other means to
save the patient do you ever as you
mentioned you don't look in their wallet
have you ever asked anybody on the
trauma team to confirm whether or not
they are an organ donor and then
subsequently change the care that you
give the patient whatever thank you when
we know the patient's coming we have all
the right conversations about what we're
expecting what we're planning for we
don't talk about organ donation
Insurance backgrounds anything it's all
about saving that individual at that
time we used to call it a wallet biopsy
and we don't do that in medicine thank
you
any other questions
okay thank you very much thank you
and the final pink card I have Thomas
Lyden
and HMS Ena and NHA cep
good morning my name is Thomas Lyden I'm
an ER doctor here in New Hampshire I
practice in New Hampshire 18 years and
I'm here to speak on behalf of the
medical society as well as the chapter
of Emergency Physicians here in New
Hampshire and I've also spoken to the
emergency Nurses Association who
agreed that I could speak for them as
well and we all oppose this bill I
actually brought with me today the atls
guidelines uh it's 400 pages long it's
there if you look up the term protocol
it is not in here if you look at the
term organ donation it is not in here
managing trauma patients at a major
Trauma Center is very difficult managing
them at my hospital where I worked by
myself for 12 hours Monday night is
incredibly difficult so we have to have
some sort of guidance as to what we're
going to do and that is what has
motivated this and this is why it is so
useful for us in emergency medicine
uh I don't work at a Trauma Center so I
have to do all this by myself and this
allows me to develop a systemic approach
for treating trauma and every patient I
see in every circumstance is different I
will also note that in the military they
have a completely different system for
treating trauma this book is a 10th
edition they're working on the 11th
Edition there have been so many changes
over the years we need something to keep
us up to date but this is in no way a
strict protocol as to what to do for
treating trauma patients
uh we feel that the bill is written is
unnecessary and is nonsensical uh
certainly I would never sign something
saying that I did everything according
to atls guidelines I would certainly
sign something saying that I tried to do
everything I could with the limited
resources at my hospital with a very
difficult Health Care system and with my
lack of nurses but I think that goes
without saying every day when I come to
work and the nurses that I work with
they would not be willing to sign forms
such as this
with regards to the nuts and bolts of
what happens in the emergency department
for trauma I think you've heard a lot
about it but in my career in New
Hampshire I've encountered one case
where trauma patient was appropriate for
organ donation and that decision was not
mine to make there are other people who
make this decision for example in
Rollinsford a few months ago there were
four men who died in a horrific car
accident none of those patients are
eligible for organ donation their
injuries were horrible their organs were
not perfused they received blood
products those are not the type of
patients
those are the type of Agents we see in
trauma but they are not appropriate for
any sort of organ donation the few cases
that we see are people with isolated
head injuries and those are very rare
when those folks come in we resuscitate
them just like anybody else but if
they're appropriate for organ donation
that is not my decision I do not
approach the family about organ donation
I do not look at anyone's license to see
if they have listed as an organ donor
and there is nothing in my electronic
medical record that signifies anybody as
an organ donor having this on your
license is something for you to think
about think about what you want to do
and it really helps with people to make
these decisions but when someone comes
into the emergency department we do not
look at any of these things it does not
influence our decision I have no idea
who's on the organ transplant list I
don't want to know who is on the organ
transplant list I do not get any
Kickback from the hospital or from
anybody else if someone donates their
organs I am paid you know by the hour
unfortunately okay
thank you Doctor a good wrap up
um you have anything else or any
questions any questions yes please
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking the time to be here
um so your job is to save the life
um whose job is it to know whether or
not that patient is uh on the organ
donation list and what happens if you've
done your best the patient Dies who then
is the who then is the doctor or surgeon
that's going to perform the surgery is
it not you or is it somebody else
completely thank you it is certainly not
me and it's certainly not someone at my
hospital
so when someone dies in the emergency
department I have to make two phone
calls I have to speak to the medical
examiner to see if they want to get
involved in the case if the case was in
any way suspicious and by definition for
most traumas those deaths are suspicious
and the medical examiner wants to get
involved I also call the Oregon bank and
I tell them that someone has died in the
emergency department they ask a variety
of questions about the details of what
happened and they have a checklist which
they go through to see if most people
are eligible for donation most people
aren't they testified earlier two
percent I think that's would be my
experience one to two percent and most
people are appropriate for donations of
skin or corneas not their organs I do
not approach the family about this the
folks from the New England donors
actually call the family and speak to
them I am not involved in this in any
way
follow-up
who who then is involved in the the
transplant transplant procedure is it
another surgeon altogether and how long
can bodies remain viable for transplant
when all this backdoor paperwork is
going on thank you yes these are
fantastic questions but not uh quickly
answer unfortunately so for the ideal
case as I said uh
to be quite blunt a gunshot wound to the
Head uh whether it's intentional or
accidental those people if they haven't
injured the parts of the brain the most
basic parts that Keep Us Alive like keep
our heart beating those patients are
alive in the sense they are perfusing
their organs their organs are kidney
liver have no idea what has happened up
at the head and they continue in their
normal function you could put those
people on a ventilator and they are in a
sense still living their organs are not
dying so you have a lot of time to
gather a team notify the organ bank but
people from my Hospital don't do it as a
medical student as part of a transplant
team in Philadelphia and we would go all
over the East Coast there's a system for
calling people in and it's a very large
team that comes in there's actually a
team for each organ which comes in to do
the heart to do the lungs to do the
kidneys in patients who die of trauma in
the emergency department once they are
dead those organs are done lying and as
I said most of those people are not
appropriate the heart once it doesn't
get perfused it's it's not much good
same with the lungs as well
if someone is appropriate
I stay out of this the organ Bank
notifies the appropriate team but in my
18 years here in New Hampshire the only
cases we have actually obtained organs
are from these isolated head injuries
okay thank you
other question so Dr Nagel
representative Nagel sorry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
as a point
um we're really focused on following
protocols guidelines whatever term you
want to use the um sorry the definition
of evidence-based medicine is the use of
the medical literature is applied to the
individual circumstances of the
individual and I'm just really curious
in your experience
my world is totally flying by the seat
of my pants there's no protocols for
what I do
in your experience and Trauma how often
do you have to deviate from best
practice guidelines whatever you want to
call them it really depends on the
circumstances unfortunately I most of
the reason we have these guidelines is
because trauma patients are complicated
there are a number of things you'd like
to do all at once but if you're the only
doctor there you can only do one thing
at a time so you start with like we
heard earlier from the person who
actually did my last atls certification
you start with the A's you move on to
the B's and then you go to the C's in
the military protocols for this they do
something completely different
someday we'll perhaps reconcile them but
their first step begins with an M it's
massive Hemorrhage so in the battlefield
you try to stop all bleeding you know
that's part of what we do in the
emergence department but
these are the guidelines
so I wish there was a simple answer the
philosophy of what we do to treat trauma
patients changes all the time I could
give you a couple example of things
we've had in the last several years that
have changed how we treat trauma
patients but these are our guidelines
they're probably a couple of years
behind the research and they're a couple
years behind the results getting out to
Providers like myself so we view them as
a way to help us out but it's not really
a straight jacket and it's not in any
way medically or legally binding as to
what we do
follow-up follow-up so I'm I'm just
going to answer the question for you I
guess so you would and you can you can
say yes or no
um so you would feel constrained by such
a policy that basically forced you to
follow a guideline or a protocol well I
wouldn't sign it
that's then answered any other questions
hey thank you very much
I know of no one else here to testify is
that correct
okay I am closing the public hearing on
HB 47 then and I am opening the public
hearing on HB 223
at this time I'd like to recognize
representative Dan McGuire who's been
waiting here very very patiently for a
while and uh welcome representative
McGuire
thank you very much Mr chairman the
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire I'm from Epsom
um this bill is
extremely minor maybe the most minor
ability that you're going to hear in
this committee I don't know
um especially you know compared to what
I just heard so what this bill does is
it tries to save a little money and some
amount of annoyance
um for some number of patients I
estimate roughly 1500 but you know
that's my back of the envelope kind of
calculation and also some sort of make
work for for pharmacists so the bill
um
is uh relates to this particular
medication this is um testosterone gel
so for people that like myself have low
testosterone and generally our seniors
um the
endocrinologists might might prescribe
this and it's something that that boosts
your testosterone somewhat and and
testosterone is something that for best
health should be in some sort of a range
and and so if you're a little below that
range this is a medication that can
improve it and because this is in a
chemical category for a much uh heavier
Duty sort of version of this medication
something that's injectable
um it's it's in what's called class
three which means that patients are only
allowed to order a month's worth of
Supply at a time
so for me for example I have to put in a
order my prescription 12 times a year
whereas most kind of Maintenance
medication like this that the standard
is you do it once per quarter so so I
end up
um with with you know eight extra
co-pays and eight extra trips to the
pharmacist or in my case by mail extra
orders and like I said I I estimate that
that there's roughly somewhere between
one and two thousand uh men in New
Hampshire that are in a similar
situation so this bill just puts an
exception so that it allows this to
medication to be ordered uh on a normal
90-day schedule rather than the the 34
days I guess it is thank you very much
thank you representative any questions
for representative McGuire
yes go ahead
representative Cannon
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
so the product as you show there is a
30-day Supply
it depends slightly this bottle for me
is good for 20 days but but the bottle
has certain it's a pump you you pump and
you get maybe a tablespoon of stuff and
your prescription is between one and
four pumps per day so there's I think 60
pumps in this bottle my particular
prescription is three pumps so this is a
20-day supply for me so when I order it
that's what I get
follow up go ahead thank you Mr chair
um
so it if that is only uh or or it's 20
day or whatever
um what's the difference between that
product and an inhaler that I take every
30 days and have to fill every 30 days
um should we do this for other
medications as well
so thank you for the question so I I
think that
um the general principle here is whether
is how
um sort of how abusable is the is the
medication right so so if you were
taking I don't know fentanyl as a
prescribed medication
um there's a there's a reason for
limiting it to to a very small
prescription right but but
um something like this is as I
understand it is not really abusable
it's it there's no real street value or
something like that to this particular
medication I have no idea what the the
one that you take
you know what category it is in but I
would assume that there's probably
others besides this that ought to have
similar exceptions yes and there's
already in the law by the way uh an
exception if you look on line nine of
the bill that's existing law so there's
already an exception for this uh
amphetamines and
methophenidate
hydrochloride whatever that is so you
know there are things in this category
thank you Dr uh representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman I don't know if
this is the better question to ask you
or follow-ups but um can you explain to
us why that is a schedule three drug
oh thank you so
um
as I understand it so this is in the
same category as steroids right so so
the kind of steroids that help people
hit baseballs farther and that kind of
stuff and can be abused by bodybuilders
and that kind of thing it's it's in the
same chemical category but according to
my endocrinologist when I asked about
this in order to abuse this particu so
this is uh that's not the kinds that are
abused those are injectables right this
is something that you rub on your skin
and so it's absorbed very very slowly
it's not very powerful and I asked my
doctor uh how could you abuse this and
they said well maybe if you filled a
bathtub with it you know
and so you know this bottle is like a
hundred dollars right so so you know
nobody's gonna fill the bathtub with
this
the questions for representative McGuire
okay thank you representative thank you
next step to testify is uh
representative Gary Merchant who is a
member of that committee representative
welcome representative and from a
different day thank you Mr chairman
yeah
I have some handouts I'll distribute
as well
and I'll try not to read my testimony
verbatim but I think it's important what
I testify about it
and again we're trying to limit it to
three minutes representative you know
half this goes in that side
this half goes over there
I'll try to answer the questions that
were raised the reason why
this is in schedule three
it's the federal law and what it came
down to was back in the 1990s there was
a problem to what president McGuire
talked about abuse of Androids
um androgens if you will
so the federal law was the basically
clamped down on that whole issue and
lots of it a lot of that came down to
his bodybuilders and people are abusing
it
so I did
sign on to this with representative
McGuire but I want to talk about two
things with you folks and representative
Candace sort of erase it as well
from a regulatory point of view there's
two issues here one is abuse illicit use
of the drug I think president McGuire
talked about that pretty clearly
it's hard to abuse a topical product
because it's just difficult to abuse
number two
the reason why I wanted to insert the
phrase
that it's used for
chronic testosterone inefficiency for a
medical condition
what many people don't realize is in the
world of Pharmacy the DEA holds the
pharmacist equally accountable
for the prescription for a control rug
and what I mean by that is that if you
are in suspicion of a prescription being
written for non-medical reasons or not
legitimate reasons you're held
accountable
so in order to slow down the process a
lot of times if you get a prescription
you think is dubious or you think you're
questionable you have to call the
prescriber to verify the medical Reason
by adding the phrase that we're talking
about in the bill
that it's for low chronic testosterone
inefficiency for a medical condition it
tells the pharmacist at that point in
time you can in fact understand what the
position of the prescriber is coming
from you don't need to make the phone
call number two when you have which also
talks about from the DEA manual
there's no limitations on the day supply
of a prescription
so there's limitations on the refills on
schedule three you can do it five times
but if you're a pharmacist quite frankly
if you've got a prescription for more
than 180 days at one time most likely
you're going to question it or if you
get subsequently refills including the
original Beyond 180 days you're probably
going to be suspicious about what's
going on
so given the fact is by changing this
bill
to include that phrase I think would
help to alleviate some of the concern
that pharmacists will have also
communicate from the prescriber back to
the dispenser we had something
comparable to this in our committee in
2021 Dr Woods representative Woods
brought it to our attention with a
attention deficit disorder at the same
time there was limitation of 34 days we
were able to make a change as long as
the practitioner wrote on it the reason
why they're asking for a 90-day Supply
there's four attention deficit disorder
then the pharmacist and everybody else
understood what was going on
so fundamentally it's a simple bill it's
just allowing for people that are in a
situation where they have to get a
prescription for topical testosterone to
logically and reasonably get it filled
four times a year versus 12 times
[Music]
thank you representative yes
representative Shapiro state
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
this seems to me to be while this seems
to be
you know totally reasonable thing to do
I'm wondering if
um from your with your background
representative Merchant if there are
other medications within schedule three
that this would also apply to and would
it not make sense to
either through a study committee or
other means
um
survey all the medications that are in
the in that classification and create
um
create the same kind of alternative
prescribing for those while we're doing
this
I think it's wise to
talk about studying the issue I would
not want to hold this bill up for that
but I think one of the things we could
do in this committee or somewhere along
the way is to have an ad hoc group talk
about it because there are other drugs
that fall in the same
category if you will where because of
the federal law the state law is what's
controlling and not the federal law is
that we could change and modify the
state law to allow for greater
flexibility I think one of the key
things I would say is that where becomes
a problem is the communication between
the prescriber and the dispenser and it
goes back to the DEA corresponding
responsibility so I do agree what you're
saying representative sombero that we
should probably broaden it but I would
not want to slow this bill down because
of it
thank you
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for my
question take my question I'm going to
be up front and say I really like bills
like this because they increase access
to care and that's like really important
they decrease cost and improve
convenience for the patient however
when the um the DEA looks at their
scheduling one of the issues isn't just
and we know this from opioids and other
things isn't just who's got the
prescription only 10 percent of opioid
deaths were related to a legitimate
prescription 90 were related to
illegitimate use such as a child getting
the whatever from somebody's medicine
shelf or whatever
for the record one of the companies
Bellco in San Francisco was using
topical testosterone preparations and
and and and juicing players that way so
topicals are used what makes this
product different than that and I'm just
curious what your thoughts are about
that I think I don't know exactly which
topical product was being utilized if it
was actually testosterone another
chemical deviation of it for the most
part the ability to abuse testosterone
topically is a challenge the amount that
you're required to use it doesn't mean
it couldn't be done but that goes back
to the onus on the prescriber if the
prescriber is basically saying to the
dispenser I'm giving this to the patient
for chronic
low testosterone based upon a medical
condition
to me that sort of helps
deal with some of the questions you're
talking about for abuse
it puts the onus back on the prescriber
to justify why they're doing it and also
puts them on record that they're
doing it because of that reason so from
a liability point of view the prescriber
owns a lot of the liability because
that's there
I'm sorry
um so with opioids we have stringent
requirements that we have to follow to
inform the patient about what the risk
benefit ratios are how to handle that
product things like that
it I think you're I don't disagree with
you about the the risk of performance
enhancement with this but
it it does make me think that we should
probably be providing similar
information for patients so this is
something that they need to
deal with responsibly
is that yes
oh I'm sorry I'm really sorry
and my apologies
I've demonstrated the problem uh the use
of microphones closer is not only for us
but also for the people watching at home
so thank you if we could all work harder
at it I will try should I repeat or uh
well what was your question I I heard a
little bit of the lead up but I don't
show what the question was when we when
we deal with scheduled drugs we're
talking about an increasing amount of
responsibility for the person receiving
it to not just for the provider should
we be providing
I think I'm getting a little off track
but I'm I'm concerned because we we have
recommendations for one class of drugs
and not for another should we be giving
these patients included in this somehow
that we need to inform them about your
responsibilities that what the risks are
how to guard this how to take care of it
that kind of thing
thank you for that question I would say
there's two steps in that process one is
the prescribers themselves informing the
patient so they have informed consent at
that point in time to what's being
prescribed for them number two when you
get to the pharmacy if you look at what
representative McGuire had the pharmacy
is also required to give you a patient
handout a leaflet if you will which also
goes over a lot of the risk and things
of that nature with the drug so I think
in that scenario dealing with a topical
testosterone that is covered by the
prescriber informing the patient it's
also being dealt with by the dispenser
by providing to the patient a handout
that clearly just finds what the risks
are
thank you
representative Palmer
I'm sorry representative
great thank you Mr chairman uh just a
quick question uh representative
Merchant
um
representative McGuire said they would
take a bathtub of this chemical or this
product to cause abuse I guess so my
question is why do why do we have to put
and I think you may have answered this
why do we have to put for the treatment
of chronic low testosterone replacement
therapy versus just eliminating that and
just say we can prescribe this drug
because I'm not really aware of are
there other indications for this drug
and if so would they have the potential
for abuse or why do we have to be
specific I guess is for this diagnosis
only
it's a good question I would say the
reason I'm adding that is to eliminate
the phone call coming from the pharmacy
or the pharmacist to the prescriber is
it's a way of communicating between the
two parties
to allow them to understand that would
be giving a 90-day Supply
that it's for a chronic condition linked
to a medical condition
however I'd be not opposed to taking it
out but I think it would open up more
phone calls between the dispenser and
the prescriber and I'm trying to
eliminate that I understood thank you
other questions
and if you also will notice inside of
the way I in my testimony
um I did change the language in there
and I will bring back an amendment to
the Committees to look at so they can
review it I changed it to including a
medical condition in there and that way
there it's linked back to a reason why
you're prescribing for it in the first
place
we're not trying to get into which
medical conditions just that in your
professional opinion is linked to a
medical reason which goes back to the
corresponding responsibility of the
pharmacist's faces you have to take this
seriously because
as you all know Walmart Walgreens and so
forth settled with the DEA for several
millions of dollars
because then their opinion people
weren't taking it seriously so when the
DEA comes knocking on your door and it's
happened to me not because they're
looking at me from a broad point of view
but they wanted to talk to me about
something else we're doing as a model
um it sends chills down your spine when
they take out that badge and it's coming
from the de office
um you take it very seriously
thank you representative
Christian so again thank you
Representatives
Merchant and McGuire for your testimony
and for this bill
uh is there anyone else here to testify
on HB 223
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 223 and open the
public hearing on HB 397.
I'd recognize the prime sponsor
representative Phillips
good morning representative Phillips
this is my first bill so let's see how
this goes
um this legislation is basically to
decriminalize children who are helping
parents who need a um who have a
prescription for hypodermic needles or
pen needles those sort of things I'm a
type 1 diabetic and have been since I
was a child so I carry roughly
six or seven hypodermic needles or
products with me on a regular basis I
have three children two of which are
responsible enough to help deliver my
medication to me if I need it or pick up
after me or handle my purse or what have
you and I'm trying to remove the
criminality in that we're adding
language that would allow an authorized
agent of somebody who has a prescription
for these supplies
uh who is a minor to be protected an
authorized agent I have the description
for that
shall mean any person including but not
limited to family member or caregiver
who has the intent to deliver the
prescription drug to the person to whom
prescription drugs are lawfully
prescribed
another example would be a teenage
babysitter who had to administer an
EpiPen or insulin to a child they were
watching that would be breaking the law
right now
um
[Music]
another example I could think of was a
parent going through IVF and needing to
take a trigger shot in their gluteus
they need help with that so sometimes
they'll ask a teenager to help them with
that just by touching these supplies
they're breaking the law right now so I
think that we need to recognize an
authorized agent who might be a minor
who's helping someone who's lawfully
prescribed hypodermic products the
second part of this legislation is to
protect minors who might be
participating in the needle exchange
program right now that's an anonymous
program so I'm not sure how many people
that would even affect because we're not
asking for ages or names as far as I
understand so I don't want to
criminalize people who are seeking
assistance of these programs to get help
for their substance abuse I don't think
we want to put more people through
um legal problems when they're reaching
out for substance abuse assistance
and I think that I had one more one more
reference point is um there's a product
prescribed to all type 1 diabetics
called a glucagon glucagon kit and if I
were to go unconscious
um in a situation I would need to be
administered a glucagon shot in my thigh
and I obviously can't administer myself
so whoever's around which might be my
minor children would need to draw up
this medication into a hypodermic needle
and inject it into my thigh to save my
life minutes matter so I obviously train
my kids on how to use this currently
just by touching it and looking at it
they're breaking the law so
I'll yield any questions people might
have I think it's pretty simple
okay questions for representative
Phillips
representative yes go ahead thank you so
besides um children with allergies that
might carry epipens
um and type one or type 2 diabetics is
there another condition you can think of
offhand that someone under 18 might need
to carry
I I don't know of any but um you know
type 1 diabetics is a very common
autoimmune condition in children right
now so
um and epipens as I know there's a large
allergy population as well and it's not
just for
um
no I I don't I don't know of any
specific uh conditions I mean I I felt
this in my heart that doesn't connected
with this that my kids were breaking the
loss I was like well we have to do
something about this so absolutely yeah
maybe you're familiar with other
conditions no okay anyway thank you
thank you
other questions for representative
Phillips
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question
um
seems to make common sense but I wonder
I wonder how someone gets designated as
an authorized agent agent
that doesn't seem to be at least I
didn't find text to explain that but
how
who would oversee that if anybody
and what are the what's the criteria for
being an authorized agent
that's a great question
say I would give permission as a
prescribe as a person prescribed because
the intent was to deliver the
prescription drug to the person whom the
prescription drugs are lawfully
prescribed so this is all relative to
minors so my children in that moment
would be an authorized agent authorized
by me because I'm the one authorized to
have the prescription
I guess I I I'm not really sure but I
wonder if we should look into that a
little bit more to have a you know a
specific
way of describing an authorized agent
and um figuring out who that person is
you know I wonder when you authorize
someone to use your vehicle
it's just a simple I gave them
permission
I mean there's no statue about that
thank you you're welcome thank you for
the question other questions for
representative Phillips representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
so I'm clear about this as I read it
went back to look at the statute itself
and the uh 318
which is kind of weird
I live most of my life
there's nothing to prevent a child from
having that device as long as it has a
prescription attached to it yeah this
has nothing to do it with children who
are prescribed it yes
so
how we understand if they're not
prescribed it why would they have it
what I mean is that the a child touch so
if their family members say a sibling of
theirs a younger sibling has a need for
has a prescription and the older sibling
is helping to administer the medication
right now any child under 18 who does
not have a prescription for cannot pick
up my insulin pen
because I I have a prescription
what's authorization because I think at
that point in time who's author writing
is a whom
um it's going to be critical here
um
I hear what you're saying as far as the
other person in the family or somebody
else if you're gonna say it at a
football game and you have somebody has
a bee sting and you have an EpiPen and
you want to have somebody else give it
the person who's been strong may not be
able to give the EpiPen but somebody
near them was underage could so I
understand where you're coming from I
just don't know how this is to be
written that's all thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I think this um the part about
the designated agent that might be
something to have our committee
researcher look into and provide
information to the committee
representative Weber
but isn't it true that as a parent
um
there are many things that you authorize
your child to do that are not in writing
not
written down in a particular format or
anything else but you as a parent can
make it very clear to your child what
they are authorized to do and what they
are not authorized to do and what the
consequences are if those trusts are
breached
I would agree yes
other questions for uh representative
Phillips
see none so thank you representative
next up to uh speak and testify is
representative Joshua Chicago who is a
co-sponsor of the bill welcome
representative yakella
thank you uh for the record my name is
representative Josh yokella from
Rockingham 32 Fremont Danville and
Brentwood
um
I just wanted to uh kind of follow up
and not repeat the the language
because obviously I agree with
everything representative Phillips said
um I wanted to clarify that uh under our
current law
uh authorized agents are allowed for a
wide range of things as far as
prescription drugs if
um
if you have
um if an adult
has a prescription and asks another
adult to help administer that
prescription they are an authorized
agent currently under the law and so I
would just direct like the um
uh RSA 31842 is dealing with per
possession of prescription drugs and
that's where it defines
um what authorized agent is and so you
you're not allowed to possess position
prescription drugs that you're not
prescribed unless you're an authorized
agent which is currently in statute and
currently allowed and so all that we're
proposing in this bill is to essentially
use that same logic for these these uh
hypodermic needles that someone else has
a legitimate use for using them and
you're just facilitating that and you
um so I just wanted to be I I'm not sure
that we need to you know redefine the
entire authorized agent
um thing because it has been working
this whole time like no one has has
brought that up as an issue this bill is
only with the issue of over regulating
these children and people that provided
the um the needles to the children and
saying
um that there are certain circumstances
that it's appropriate and shouldn't be
unlawful
and so that's all we're trying to
clarify in the law so thank you
representative questions for
representative representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
clarifying that um that's very helpful
could you just repeat the statute that
where authorized agent is defined yes
it's RSA 318 42 and it's Roman 1.
thank you
yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for
speaking today
um
under current law if
If the parents are gone for example and
they have needles at the house and the
children are at home alone is that
considered possession or if a child
borrows the mother's car for example and
she always keeps needles in her car are
they considered to be in possession are
they are they can can they be held
criminally liable for borrowing mom's
car
thank you for the question I definitely
so I proposed a version of this bill uh
brought this issue back in a prior
session and I had a number of of
situations that I thought that this
could be potentially an issue as far as
what is possession of of the needle like
if you grab your mom's purse
if she didn't give you permission to
grab the purse does that is that allowed
because the needle is in the purse
um
it I think that
um at that point you're you know maybe
if you had the car if the parent left
the left the needles in the car and the
parent left gave you permission to use
the car then maybe you could make an
argument but you're probably if you're
getting
you know you get pulled over and the
cops do a search and they say Hey you
have this needle and and did you get
permission
you probably would have to go to court
to say like hey this is I actually did
get permission to use the car but not
specifically the needle or you know uh
that's
it's it's probably going to come down to
a legal thing if they if the if the
courts wanted to
um
to uh prosecute you in that case and you
would have to try and get the person
that was authorized to kind of speak in
your on your behalf I think
okay
other questions
representative Merchant
I think the intent of the law when it
was written was to
limit the access of miners to these
devices
for a lot of different reasons
I commend you what you're saying is
trying to open this up but are we
opening up a can of worms where all of a
sudden we're giving miners permission to
have hypogenic needles and other things
in their possession which is not the
intent of what you're trying to get to
but it does open up that window does it
not
thank you for the question if they're
possessing it for a legitimate use then
I don't think that there there should be
a law against it yes
thank you Mr chairman um
how do you how do you throw that needle
thank you for the question I think that
an authorized agent is pretty clear
about whether or not you're
um you're authorized or not that would
that is a legitimate use
other questions uh representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you this is
an issue I've dealt with since I was 11
years old my brother was a juvenile
diabetic but the way we dealt with it is
he had the glucagon on him if he needed
it we took it off of him and
administered it to him we weren't
carrying it around ourselves
and same thing with epipens the person
who is affected by the illness has the
EpiPen not the person you know who might
administer it
um so I think my question is that that's
how I would deal with this am I wrong
about that thank you for the question
um under current law if you gave it to
your sibling for them to administer it
you and your sibling would all both be
committing a crime under current law and
it doesn't matter that you're normally
carrying it as soon as you allow another
person that it doesn't have a
prescription to possess it you and your
the person possessing it both committed
a crime
so that's what we're trying to address I
don't think that you would normally
maybe in the example of um you know a
parent giving the EpiPen to a babysitter
for the entire duration of the time that
they're watching their kid might be a
situation where the person is actually
holding the EpiPen for the you know
two-year-old or whatever like you're not
giving it to the two-year-old and having
them give it back to the to the
babysitter later right so
thank you for the question other
questions representative Merchant and
looking at a couple attorneys on our
committee would that be would that not
be covered under Good Samaritan law
thank you for the question
um
if
it was an emergency and and
um you didn't have permission so if the
kid was like the two-year-old the
babysitter was watching them
um the the two-year-old had an emergency
they didn't get permission they went
into the drawer and found the EpiPen and
and administered it that would be
covered under the
um the Good Samaritan law however the
parents just giving it to them without
an emergency ever happening like Prima
before an emergency happening that is
not an emergent situation and so
therefore I don't believe that in that
case that would be covered under the
emergency emergent law any other
questions
saying none thank you representative
yukala thank you
next here to speak is Abby Rogers
good morning chairman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is Abby
Rogers I'm the legislative liaison for
the division of Public Health Services
I'm in and I'm here today with Rachel
Kush we came today to learn more about
the intent of the sponsors Bill we had a
conversation in the hall and realized
that the intend the bill really is in
section one related to The Possession or
the assistance with a family member that
has a medical condition which would
require a child a reminder to maybe
assist the parent or caregiver with
using that device so we were prepared to
talk a little bit about the work that we
do with prevention with syringe service
programs and I have Rachel here that
could provide information to the
committee on the second part of the bill
if you're interested in hearing about
that today or if you're more focused on
the first part of the bill we can skip
that we are trying to limit testimony
the same minutes per per individuals so
great okay if you can cover it sure sure
would you like
hi I'm Ray real Kush k-u-s-c-h and I
just wanted to give a little background
information about
the second part of the Bell
which allows
um
allows the possession of syringes if
they have been obtained legitimately
through a syringe service program so
syringe service programs in New
Hampshire
are programs that
um are kind of Statewide and they allow
people the ability to get sterile
syringes to inject drugs if they are
actively injecting drug injection drug
users
and they help people get linked to
substance use treatment disorder they
help people learn more about overdose
prevention
and get linked into care for
testing for different infectious
diseases so
um so are there any questions
specifically about this bill related to
that representative Weber
I had a couple of questions so my first
question is
um does the department have an uh an
actual opinion on this bill are you just
here to answer questions we we are not
taking a position on the go where here's
a resource today thank you may I have
one other question with the specific
uh with respect specifically to the
needle exchange portion but possibly
other portions as well
do you know of situations where the
provisions of this bill
might be used in a way that I would deem
inappropriate where you have per EX for
example
a family where the misuse of needles is
fairly prevalent
and somebody says oh are you
are you parent allowing your child to
use this
instrument and the parent just says yeah
whatever
is it possible that by enacting this we
may be
enabling
misuse in a situation where we would
prefer not to have misuse in addition to
the uses that people have testified that
might be very useful and and appropriate
so I think
I'm not sure what uh what you mean by
misuse related to how it says authorized
agent in the bill so
um
so I think the bill is written such that
it would it would make it so that uh
any any syringes that were supplied
through a syringe service program
legitimately
would not be characterized as misuse
thank you other questions representative
Merchant
first of all a statement and a question
but as a
I think you're right
I'm looking at the second part of this
from line 11 down
it sort of conflicts with lines above it
and I'm trying to understand
if the first part of it is you have to
have a prescription to begin with
in order to obtain it you have therefore
need a prescription
so if you look at the second section it
says that you don't have to have a
prescription
but the first one says you do
so I'm looking at the language and
saying it really is not in
sync with each other because in order
for somebody to have it you have to have
a prescription
basically yes
thank you
yeah I don't know I can speak to that
one
didn't you I think so I could speak that
I would I thank you for the question
representative merchandise as you know
the intent of the the sponsor spoke of
the intent of to bring the bill forward
to to assist with heart with parents
caregivers medical needs I can see how
you could say that there would be some
concerns about the second part
um you know we're here today to really
talk about the fact that
um as a department when we look at uh
into the subject of subject substance
misuse we use the youth risk behavior
survey and have found that substance use
identified by data we collect from that
survey starts as young as 12. and we
support the concept of minors can get
substance use treatment at the age of
12. we don't have a position in this
bill but would like to you know just to
talk about the fact that you know there
should be resources available for for
minors in that situation so any
technicalities on the bill perhaps
should be better addressed with the
sponsor and maybe on a subcommittee
level
and perhaps an amendment needs to be
offered or something
uh yes representative the Weber
thank you just as you read the bill
isn't the purpose for two different
sections that have two different kinds
of Provisions because they're addressing
two different parts of the existing Bill
one being
syringes that are part of a prescription
and therefore there is a prescription
and the second part being part of the
existing bill that deals with syringes
that were never a part of a prescription
but part of a needle exchange and that's
why you knew the two different sections
and one has a prescription and one
doesn't yes thank you
hey other questions
I see none thank you very much thank you
thank you
thank you both
and the final pink card I have this
morning uh is from
Lauren McGinley
New Hampshire harm reduction company
is Miss McGinley here
okay does anyone else wish to testify on
this bill
okay saying no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 397.
at this point
um
oh no it hurts
hers doesn't do we want to continue with
this
um it's uh it's 12 10 by my watch do we
want to continue I'll ask the
committee's Indulgence or failing you
want to continue or do you want to um
break for lunch
we have six
I'd like a break that no two before
lunch one of which should be incredibly
short
any preferences in light of the weather
I would certainly appreciate continuing
on and if somebody needs to step out and
get nourishment these are hearings we
don't need a quorum for a hearing
okay so anybody who is suffering can can
Rush away and get notes from somebody
else when they come back any objection
to continuing then
seeing none all right let's proceed to
uh let me I will then proceed to open
the hearing on House Bill 338.
and accordingly I will recognize
representative adjutant to uh
to uh introduce the bill was the Prime
sponsor good morning good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh my name is
representative Josh Adrian from the town
of Enfield and I bring to you today HB
338 a bill that would do several things
before I forget to before I get to those
I figured I would talk about where the
bill came from in 2020 the state of New
Hampshire adopted a co-pay cap for
insulin and while I was happy to support
that at the time I had a lingering
concern in the back of my mind a co-pay
necessitates commercial insurance or
government-backed Insurance like
Medicaid Medicare
at the time I voted for that bill I was
an uninsured American and I knew there
were many more like me people who made
too much for Medicaid but not nearly
enough to afford Commercial Insurance
in 2021 in 2022 Congress took action
again within the same co-pay parameters
I still held those concerns
so in September I submitted an LSR that
would expand to Medicaid to further
cover those individuals and qualify for
the cap
OLS and I ran into an issue with the
Medicaid rules and so through a work
around the language was placed in nhrsa
161-l Colon 2 the New Hampshire
prescription drug Advantage program a
program that I did not know existed in
the rsas prior to November I read it
over and I thought well isn't this
fantastic we have a mechanism to reduce
the cost of prescriptions and deal with
big Pharma right in our statute
why have I not heard of this before I
began calling around and sure enough
nobody else had either it turns out this
was a program that got hit with the one
dollar budget fix shortly after passing
in 2008 and has not been active since
so now that we've arrived to today the
bill does one smaller thing and its
other committee referral would do a
bigger thing
the small thing it would do would be to
add language to the RSA that
specifically caps the cost of insulin
copay for the four percent of New
Hampshire residents that are reported to
not have insurance per the insurance
department and there are two things
about that figure that I think may make
that four percent figure a little low
the reporting mechanism on that I'm
really hard-pressed to believe that only
four percent of the state particularly
low-wage workers fall into the
parameters of not having employer
Insurance on making too much to qualify
for State assistance
um and making too little to qualify
commercial insurance but also the
existence of the public health emergency
and how once that's over uh or once we
move on from that as far as Medicaid is
concerned there'll be a lot more
residents of New Hampshire who are
uninsured
um but that language doesn't do a whole
lot unless the bigger thing this build
does goes into effect the bigger issue
here would be to re-establish and refund
the program and we can do that by
agreeing that the program has Merit that
prescriptions of all kinds in the United
States are far too expensive these days
and that grandstaters especially the
elderly and those unfixed incomes need
price relief and we can deliver that in
the form of Cheaper prescriptions
through the refunding of the New
Hampshire RX Advantage Program
I'm hard-pressed to think you'd find
anybody who relies on prescription
medication who holds the opinion that
the cost of these Goods is reasonable in
fact many Americans either do not fill
prescriptions because they can't afford
them or they cut medication in half
because they can't afford to take what
their doctor tells them and they need to
take every day to get better and live
happy healthy lives with that I would
ask the committee to consider two
pictures here a smaller picture and a
bigger picture
small pictures that we have to a way to
universally lock in the price of a
life-saving drug like insulin for
uninsured Granite sitters the bigger
pictures that we already on the books
have the means to reduce prescription
costs for constituents all the guesswork
has been taken out of that and it can be
sent somewhere else where hopefully they
can find the means to pay for this
important program and I would like to
raise one point with the committee as
far as the methodology of the bill
if you look at that under the fiscal
note
presumably individuals who receive
coverage through Medicaid will not
utilize this benefit given that Medicaid
insulin coverage is a one dollar copay
for up to a 90-day Supply I think that's
an important thing to note because as I
was just speaking to Mr very from HHS
the Medicaid threshold as far as income
is concerned cuts off at around sixteen
thousand dollars for an individual
whereas this bill uses the figure of the
300 percent
um or within 300 of the poverty uh
guidelines parameter so that gets that
closer to forty one thousand and there
is a considerable income difference
between somebody making 16 000 a year uh
and forty two thousand a year it
captures a lot more people
um using the 300 of the property
guidelines so
um I wanted to just clarify that before
somebody said well you already have a
lot of people on Medicaid they're
already paying the dollar I understand
that my goal here really is to close the
gap like I said several times in the
testimony between people who do not
qualify qualify for Medicaid because
they make just barely too much uh and
those who do not have insurance through
their work or affording it commercially
so I understand we're behind I'll wrap
up with that and I can take any
questions
thank you representative way on um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representatives for sticking with us and
being here to testify my question is
regarding which types of insulin you
intend to cover with this
um and and what limits you would have on
this
types of insulin we would cover
um I guess I'll ask my question better
um so there's not really generic insulin
on the market because that's been
replaced by new novel ones they do sell
some as sort of branded generics
um the way it's written is insulin I
don't know if you're intending to
include insulin pumps or other very
costly Innovative medical devices which
while they improve people's lives are
very very expensive I was wondering what
what limits you were planning to put on
this sure I will happily cop to the fact
that I'm very grateful to not have to
have used that medication before so I
was not aware that there were broader
parameters on that
um so
um I would like to on that issue defer
to the wisdom of the committee if that's
something that you guys want to clarify
but I did not know necessarily that that
was a distinction thank you
the questions representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question so if I understand
correctly this is talking about this is
um capping the insulin cost at 30 per
month for people who
um
already
not for people who have Medicaid but for
people who do not qualify for Medicaid
are
um under 300 percent of the federal
poverty level and don't have other
insurance
or even if they do have insurance it
still caps the co-payment correct
there's not necessarily limiting
language in here that would um kick in
if they have
um Commercial Insurance
um but essentially trying to catch that
vicious metal uh so my question really
is
um I know pricing for pharmaceuticals is
incredibly
bizarre and and subjective and but
assuming that there's a cost to someone
that goes beyond thirty dollars who's
paying that cost
is it that is it the state is that the
pharmacies will not be able to charge
more than thirty dollars
so where's the cost go right I mean I
think that bleeds broaderly uh more
broadly into
um 161.
um I can grab that really quick
um this has to do largely with the
rebate program that pharmacies go into
um so I I would ask that that question
be deferred
um to Mr Berry from HHS
um just because
um I was not as familiar with the rebate
as I would like to be
um like I said I found out in November
that this program existed uh which is
really unfortunate because it looks like
a really good program
um and it would be really good to be
able to deliver those savings for folks
[Music]
thank you other questions
oh representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman I just have a real
quick question it says in the bill
language qualified individuals and I'm
trying and I think I understand based on
what you said
but I don't see what that's referring to
within the text that's another thing
um I spoke with Mr Berry
um I goofed and I think there may need
to be some harmonizing between qualified
individual and qualified resident
um I did not catch that during the OLS
process but just to make sure that those
two things sync up
um I think that'd be valuable is that
the tone of the question
other questions
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak as a co-sponsor
of the Bill of Representative shewitt
representative short here
okay
sure understandable
senator al-sheller
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you honorable members
former colleagues
the cost I'm here to speak to you about
House Bill 338 my name is Senator
Deborah alchillar I represent the
Seacoast District 24 the towns of Exeter
Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton rye and stratum the cost of
life-saving prescription drugs is one
that can put many Granite Staters who
are chronically ill in danger of having
to make unimaginable choices to maintain
their health care and afford it as well
in the last 20 years the cost of
diabetes drugs has doubled
during that time
the price of insulin has increased more
than now I have put in my testimony 500
percent and in fact checking just two
minutes ago have been corrected and it
is actually 600 percent
according to the American Diabetes
Association people with type 1 diabetes
need on average two to three vials per
month
for the uninsured and those with poor
coverage A month's worth of insulin can
cost on average one thousand dollars or
more
this poses a significant financial
burden for patients and their families
who need insulin to stay alive for those
who may not be intimately acquainted
with Diabetes Type 1 is not curable it
is a chronic disease managed by daily
dosing of insulin people who have the
disease
are wholly dependent upon prescription
drugs to remain alive those prescription
drugs are a required purchase for these
people even as costs Skyrocket currently
there is no alternative to insulin
meaning that the drug companies have
diabetic patients trapped
Diabetes Type 2 often referred to as
adult onset diabetes can in some cases
be managed with diet and exercise but
often patients with type 2 also rely on
insulin
a person
I'm going to let you read the rest of
that testimony but I wanted to take the
last bit of my time to make a couple of
clarifications on some questions that
were posed by the committee a moment ago
for
insulin pumps
um are considered durable medical
equipment they are not what we are
talking about in this bill we are
talking about the actual insulin itself
and insulin
the markup on insulin is over 500
percent so the
um the questions of oh how will we pay
for it insulin is actually a very very
inexpensive product to produce the
markup is on is coming out of the
manufacturers and now that we have
fortunately
now have bargaining power with the
pharmaceutical companies we are hoping
that the the prices for some of these
incredibly marked up and life-saving
pharmaceuticals will be more affordable
for states to be purchasing
thank you Senator thank you
any questions for Senator walsheller
representative Nagle
just a quick question oh thank you Mr
chairman thank a quick question so
you're going to cover the insulin that
goes into the pump but not the pump
right now not everybody uses a pump some
people use hypodermic needles um pumps
are
pumps and patches are fairly new to the
market and they're not suitable or
appropriate for all patients so that is
that is not the intent of the bill the
intent of the bill is to get the
expensive insulin into the hands of the
patients who need it
um
and we aren't we're not discussing the
method of of delivery just getting that
insulin to the patients thank you thank
you for your question other questions
for Senator alsheller
foreign
thank you very much
hey next sign up to testify is Robert
Berry from the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'll be very brief
because I know that there's weather
concerns and people are hungry
um so
um essentially what uh representative
imagine stated was of the Crux of my
testimony I just want to go over a brief
test a brief history of the New
Hampshire prescription uh drug Advantage
Program
um it was enacted in 2007 due to funding
issues we had never been able to
operationalize this program in 2019
through HB 458 the
um the funding mechanism was repealed
and that brings us here today
essentially as representative agent
alluded to the department cannot
manage this bill without some funding
mechanism so that's the one thing we
wanted to point out to the committee
other than that I'm happy to take
questions and bring them back
questions from Mr Berry representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question you might have just
answered it but I didn't fully
understand it so the the difference
between thirty dollars a month and a
thousand dollars a month is substantial
um and whether
whether these drugs are ferociously
marked up or not the numbers are still
substantial so
are you saying that the mechanics of
pain for this would be that
um
the previous statute
would be revived somehow so that money
would come from the state to make up the
difference it would have to be revived
in yes funding from the legislature
would need to follow that yes so would
an appropriation have to be in this bill
or how would that how would that what
would be the mechanics of that be well I
think it's up for the to the legislature
to cyber the appropriation uh would go
but
um I I don't have a number to throw out
as to what the appropriation would look
like we don't really have a point of
reference at the department I am working
on trying to obtain a number for what it
would take to run such a program but
just have not been able to do that at
this at this juncture thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
for questions my question goes back to
the different types of insulin if the
department would if they were
implementing this would look for
injectable insulins continuous insulin
pumps or where they would set that bar
of where it's important to have state
funds make up the difference for people
or if it's a matter matter of providing
something that is adequate so that's a
thank you for the question that's
something I had not personally
considered I'm also not familiar with
the different various types of insulin
so what I would do and I'm going to do
is I'm going to take that back to our
Pharmacy experts at the department to
get a sense as to what that might look
like
and as a follow-up I'll offer what
services I can my job used to be trying
to get governments to pay for insulin
pumps awesome I will uh take note of
that thank you
any other questions for Mr Berry
okay I see none thank you very much
in the last pink card I have this
morning or this afternoon uh on this
particular bill is Brittany O'Donnell
oh
microphone please
sorry I have testimony to send around I
also have
uh a little thing for each of you if you
want to take whichever one out of the
bag you'd like
um I'll explain it in a minute
we haven't had lunch is it something we
can eat or
that's okay we've been doing good
so first and foremost I would love to
answer that question I've been chomping
at the bit in terms of insulin and what
you would cover
um
first of all I hope my testimony will
give a little bit of something different
to think about during this bill but also
in my experience these bills only cover
insulin uh typically on a vial or a pen
form and that's just because it's
durable medical is going to go to a
different piece of insurance altogether
so durable medical equipment and
prescription benefits are usually two
separate things anyways
um
and also we don't want to be greedy
um really I'm just we're just looking
for affordable insulin I would love to
have the conversation of how to get cgms
and Insulin pumps covered but I would
settle for just the medication I need to
live
um
with that being said I did write a
testimony
I know you're short on time I will try
to be quick on it but it helps me stick
to my point
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Brittany O'Donnell I am the
New Hampshire chapter leader for T1
International which is a global
non-profit organization that works
towards affordability and accessibility
of insulin today I am here to offer my
support of HB 338 as well as ideas for
how to ensure it truly helps the most
New Hampshire rights affected by the
insulin price crisis I'm sure that you
may be able to think of someone you know
or love who is living with diabetes
there are 26.8 million diagnosed
diabetics in the U.S making your odds
one in ten
if you can't think of anyone allow me to
introduce myself I have been living with
type 1 diabetes since 1990 when I was
diagnosed at 13 months old I lived
through my mom pureeing meals from
Weight Watchers
that was the only diabetic diet that
they had for conversion at the time
blood sugar monitors that took over a
minute to produce results assuming that
you put just the perfect amount of Blood
on the test strip and most notably I
survived off insulins that were derived
from Pig and Cattle
when Humalog insulin was released in
1996 there was a seismic shift in the
way diabetes was treated as it was
finally offered and it finally had
offered enough predictability to also
provide hope for the diabetic community
and their caretakers that is until it
became a medication so expensive that it
is now unobtainable without great
insurance or a healthy disposable income
since the 1990s the cost of insulin has
increased over 1200 percent yet the cost
of production for a vial of most analog
insulin which is NovoLog Humalog the
fast acting insulin you need to cover
anything that you eat or a high blood
sugar
it costs only between 3.69 and six
dollars and sixteen cents to make
for those unfamiliar insulin is an
absolute necessity especially with those
with type 1 diabetes where your pancreas
no longer produces it insulin helps
blood sugar enter the body cells to
create energy using insulin is
meticulous with some training you are
expected to be a mathematician a
dietitian and make life or death
decisions daily somehow diabetics around
the world not only manage this but do so
while holding down full-time jobs and
supporting families
quite simply without insulin we die
there is no grease in it and oftentimes
it's slow and painful it's a condition
known as diabetic ketoacidosis or DKI
when you hear about diabetics who have
died due to rationing there is no
justice done for what they actually went
through
with dka your body slowly deteriorates
your liver eats away at fat for fuel you
have a general feeling of weakness and
illness and though it can occur within
24 hours it can take days for untreated
Decay to claim the life
described by those who have experienced
it as burning or your blood feeling like
it's on fire it is actually the blood in
your body turning to acid
those who go to the hospital can expect
to accumulate an average bill of about
thirty thousand dollars to treat it and
be released
I would also expect those numbers to
have changed that came from a 2001 study
I had read in a medical journal
over the last year with difficulties in
hospital Staffing and challenges faced
by patients and being able to find
hospitals equipped to care for them
so what can HB 338 do if properly funded
the bill has an incredible opportunity
to help people who even with the copay
cap in place can't afford insulin it has
the ability to help people who are too
ashamed to ask for help because for a
lot of people who ration their insulin
it feels embarrassing to ask for help to
afford a medication that is as vital to
living as air itself
it can help people who are in between
jobs relationships or whatever other
transitional period life tends to throw
at us when we are least expecting it
has the potential to help people who are
in the position I was in when I ration
my insulin the only reason I'm here
today to talk to you is because there
were only three months between my 26th
birthday and the day I got married
I had a high deductible on the plan I
went on after aging off of my dad's
insurance and even with the coupon I was
graciously told about by the pharmacist
I was only able to pick up one vial of
insulin at a time I stretched it for as
long as I could I found old vials with
expired insulin around the house I opted
for lower carb meals so I wouldn't have
to use too much insulin and I let my
blood sugars run higher than I normally
would to avoid running out
I never told anyone what I was doing but
I did sleep easier when I was able to go
on my husband's insurance
in researching what this bill has the
potential to do I would be remiss if I
didn't acknowledge my concerns about
what would happen if it's not properly
funded the New Hampshire prep
prescription card on which this bill
relies was never given the
Appropriations following its
establishment in 2007. it's also not
very user friendly from what I found on
the website and some of the programs
only cover medications for type 2
diabetes
which is a whole different conversation
but if we're talking about type 2
diabetes as a preventative medication we
should be talking about type 1
medications as preventative medication
for things like dka and all of those
other things amputations that go with it
um
for it to be successful funding for New
Hampshire prescription card would have
to be included and Insulin would have to
be guaranteed coverage by the program
with a bill that offers so much promise
I also wanted to share a different
approach to the same problem I could ask
you to start wrapping up yep sure I have
one more paragraph
in 2020 Utah passed HB 207 and created
the Utah insulin Savings Program
recognizing the dangers of rationing
Republican representative Norm Thurston
negotiated a set price with Express
Scripts where the state could buy
insulin in bulk at one set price
which they would then pass along to the
people who signed up for the program at
that same price given that Express
Scripts has a relationship here in New
Hampshire with its state employees
as they are currently working with the
New Hampshire's prescription drug
affordability board they may be
interested in setting up a similar
program as Utah's the Utah Savings
Program is open to all residents of the
state with the only exception being if
you are an employee of the state I did
give you the website in my testimony
the Savings Program had bipartisan
support and passed both the House and
Senate with ease before it was signed
into law less than two months after its
introduction it was created to do
exactly what this is looking to do which
has helped those with no insurance or a
large deductible with 8.3 Americans
uninsured and 47 percent having high
deductible plans there are many who need
this help
I'm here today because I survived
insulin rationing and I owe it to those
who did not to do better one important
diabetics in the United States will
ration their insulin so statistically
speaking you know someone who is
rationing or has rash in their insulin
as much as I take my response my
survival as a responsibility I hope you
take this opportunity to help save lives
this is not a partisan issue it's a
human issue and I hope to have your
support
thank you
questions
anyone have questions
apparently not thank you thank you
I have no other cards of indicating of
anyone else interested to testify is
there anyone here who does want to
testify on HB 338
saying not I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 338 and open the
public hearing on HB 43 413.
and
I'd like to represent uh yeah represent
recognize representative Lucas the prime
sponsor welcome
thank you for the record representative
Alicia leckis Hillsboro 38 which is the
photorial between Hudson and Litchfield
um whenever I meet new constituents I
always say so I'm one of your reps do
you have any concerns questions
complaints and if it's a business person
I say I ask are there things that are in
law which interfere with you're doing
your business or conducting your job or
whatever so when I got my new primary
care physician who is a nurse
practitioner I ask her that question she
said let me get back to you in
um at my next physical she said actually
I have a few things for you and this was
one of them and basically she said I can
prescribe drugs that can kill you but I
can't prescribe diabetic shoes
so I I went to research and you know try
to figure that out and this bill came
out of that somebody just recently said
to me what if instead of diabetic shoes
it said medical devices if you want to
do that that's certainly fine with me as
long as there isn't an exception in law
already for diabetic shoes
I'm I'm in education
so I don't know I'm just trying to help
my nurse practitioner and anybody else
and her comment was there are plenty of
offices where there are just nurse
practitioners not
um medical doctors and if a patient
comes to her and needs this she that
they would then have to set up an
appointment with a doctor they'd never
met as a first
you know as a as
brain failure uh you know when you first
see a doctor whatever that is and and go
over all of that stuff and pay all that
extra money to a doctor they don't even
have never seen so they can get their
prescription for diabetic shoes rather
than just having their primary care
physician who deals with their diabetes
and prescribes their medicine to be able
to prescribe that and that's all I have
to say but I will try to answer
questions if you have them thank you
representative yes
thank you Mr chairman
so these
um physician assistants and nurse
practitioners they already have the
legal authority to prescribe medication
um but they supposedly don't have the
ability to prescribe diabetic shoes why
there must be some law already written
or something that prohibits that why
don't we instead of adding new words to
the code why don't we just scratch out
the old words that are somehow
preventing the you know prescription of
diabetic shoes and other ridiculous
things that should be legal
I like removing code not settings I
agree with you and that's entirely I'd
be thrilled with that this is the law
that came the bill that came out when I
went to research and then research
talked to Ola you know this is what they
came up with when I went and said this
is a problem how do we fix it so
and as I said I'm education I don't
understand what all the Health and Human
Services laws are but if you do please
fix it
thank you representative Weber
isn't the answer to the previous
question that this is not governed by
law but governed by the scope of
practice of an individual practice and
therefore it's not a law subject to
being repealed what we need to do if we
choose to do this is to add this to the
scope of practice for this particular
practitioner
if that's actually what's stopping it
yes that will be what we need to do it
may be Medicaid or Medicare
that is saying that in order to do this
so like I said I don't know but yes
whatever needs to be done amend it
however you have to and if there are
other silly things out there get rid of
them too please
representative
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question or I think one of
the problems that this does have to do
with Medicare it it you bring the thing
that you bring up has been a
sewerpoint for years because a lot of
the durable medical equipment and other
things physician assistance and nurse
practitioners aren't haven't been
allowed to prescribe but that's by
Medicare regulation and I think there's
been some loosening up with that so my
question for is I For Me Maybe is to go
and look and see if that would allow
because we can make a law here but if
Medicare isn't going to allow it it's
not going to matter so I think that's
what we need to find out thank you for
doing that
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative I
definitely understand the constraints
around Medicare but do you think it
would be important to offer it up to
patients on Commercial Insurance or cash
pay if they wanted to shoe better suited
to reduce amputations absolutely
anything that's going to help and
anything you guys know how to do and I
really appreciate you looking at this
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman
um this bill really surprised me because
did you actually look through the scope
of practice for nurse practitioners I
went to research OLS research and I
asked them and they gave me some things
but there was it just said
MDS only
so I don't know
but at any rate they said they did a lot
of research which they only sent me part
of they said so when I put in the bill
with OLS
they will be happy to work with OLS so
they did that and this is what came out
to me so I don't know what all the ins
and outs are because they communicated
follow-up yeah I was going to try to
look drag up the nurse practitioner
rules to see that because my that
surprised me that they can't write them
now and just so we acknowledge who's the
hero in this um I as a doctor they as an
nurse practitioner write a prescription
the pedorthist actually makes the device
they're the ones who really know what
they're doing and and um for them to
write a prescription for it's not a big
deal
which I'm shocked it's not allowed well
my my PCP was shocked that it was not
allowed
other questions for representative
yeah representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh would you believe that the
language here is being inserted into the
um the nurse Practice Act in the um
Physicians assistance scope of practice
so it is in the in the place that we're
we're talking about but because I would
you be agreeable to like amending it to
broaden it to other devices I would be
amenable to anything that's going to get
patients the care they need thank you
thank you
other questions
the point of order representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman as a point of
order I think we all slip back into the
sort of discussing through questions and
what I know I was guilty of that as well
um hopefully we'll try and keep things
more focused in the future even though
this was beneficial right now
any other questions
see none representatively because thank
you thank you all of you
he also signed up to testify is a
representative Jess Edwards
foreign
thank you Mr chair I I didn't really
intend to testify on this I was waiting
for my own bill later but as I was
listening to this
um the the one thing that I thought
might be useful to the committee that uh
maybe this is their first term is that
we have a trend of multiple terms trying
to open up access to care to make it
more easy for patients to get access
like for example last term we passed one
saying that a person can go order their
own
diagnostic pathology test without an
order uh and and and so so the to the
extent that this is consistent with that
Trend I think it's fully supportable or
I hope we can support it and then the
other part is that I have uh I got
another little Bill that I'm coming to
you with that I had overlooked one of
the practitioners of a health care in
New Hampshire in in my bill and so they
asked me to come back and think and get
them at it so so my point there is
these two types of care providers may be
necessary but not sufficient and since
this is in an early bill you know maybe
maybe there's time to do a little bit
more research and an amendment to make
sure that you're comfortable with it I'd
be happy to work with any representative
on that even though I'm not a co-sponsor
here thank you representative
any questions or comments or primary
questions represent Dr Nagel
representative Nagel
there's other doctors here no I know
um the only problem that I see with this
bill at all because I think it's it's
sad that it's not
doable now
the number of durable medical supply
devices that we're talking about is
immense so are we going to just add them
one by one by one by one by one and
right now most of the health care
Primary Care are substantial percentage
of it is increasingly be done by nurse
practitioners and Physicians assistants
and it's important that they have the
skills or the abilities to be able to
provide these services so I'm
I'm I I would like to think that there's
a way to work this in more broadly than
just that and not have to come back here
every year to add another one
representative Edwards okay so there's a
I think a question in there and I I and
and my answer the answer to the question
I heard
is is is is is I agree this feels to me
like it's a very small shot at what
could probably be handled in a more
broad sense and as somebody who needs an
orthotic for my ankle I I I know that
the Specialty Care resides in the people
who make the brace and not and that's
not the magic isn't in the prescription
the magic is in the person who fits you
so
representative Weber point of procedure
Mr Mr chairman
while I'm very much in sympathy with the
idea of broadening
areas of practice
I just wanted to make the point that if
we take this particular Bill and start
adding a lot of different things on it
we're either going to need to have a
whole other public hearing so that the
public gets notice of what we're doing
or we could use it to set up some kind
of study
or without having a bill at all either
you as chair you as chairman of this
committee could appoint some people to
study the issue so there's lots of ways
of doing that I just wanted to caution
people about putting 18 more devices or
categories of devices onto a bill
without the appropriate public hearing
on it
uh because I I don't want people to
waste all that good work for something
that then is going to be run across a
procedural there's an amendment we're
offer though would not have to have a
public hearing by itself or we don't
normally have public hearings on
amendments we offer amendments all the
time without public hearings thank you
it it the question is how far it Strays
from the original intent of the bill and
how much members of the public who might
have something to tell us about it get
notice of what we're doing it's more
honored I'm afraid in the breach than in
the observance
thank you
anything else any other questions for
representative Edwards
Mr chairman are we representative on
Bill 413 yes one of the things if I
could
make a recommendation to the
representative there I went back and
looked at the physician assistance
chapter they can according to the RSA
318d3b
prescribed for devices
this is clearly the device number two
is that if you simply add a language
under the current statute which is 326 B
11 which have copies of four people here
is simply where it says they have the
authority
to prescribe control and uncontrolled
drugs is at that point in time just add
a simple thing and devices like you do
with a PA
versus trying to get into a Litany of
what they can and cannot do
another procedural thing is this not a
matter for either a work session or a
subcommittee or an executive session I
would say or discussion among any number
of members of this committee less than a
quorum who could just go off and talk
about it and bring back an amendment
quite well taken thank you
all right no other questions or comments
thank you representative Edwards thank
you Mr chair I've been getting mentored
by representative Weber now for five
years so it's good to continue the
education a lot of experience thank you
okay good to see my old seat mate
our next bill is um
for one o'clock by not having lunch
we're actually a little ahead of
schedule
and as I understood
exactly exactly so if somebody wants to
people want to get up and stretch a
little bit close the hearing foreign yes
uh and with no one else had to testify
in 413 I will
I'm sorry did somebody have a question
I'm going to close the public hearing
representative Shapiro
if you need to go and get something to
eat that's fine but we're not family
breaking for lunch now so I'm going to
close the public hearing on HP 413 and
we'll reconvene in a few minutes for at
one o'clock for HB 329.
or in recess
thank you
I'd like to reconvene please
I
as as as things often happen in
government you say you're going to take
five minutes you take 15 but that's good
but that's okay we had a long morning
and a busy morning and I appreciate
everybody's Indulgence
with that I am going to open the public
hearing for HB 329
and I'd like I would recognize the prime
sponsor representative Jim Murphy
great good afternoon now everybody uh
and good afternoon and thank you Mr
chairman in um honorable committee
members for HHS and Ena
for allowing me the opportunity to
present this bill which has been
presented before as you all may know uh
to introduce House Bill 329 with a
fiscal note attached establishing an a
myotrophic lateral sclerosis registry in
the state of New Hampshire
for the record my name is Jim Murphy I
represent Grafton 12 which is lime in
Hanover uh in in my second term where I
worked previously in ways and means so
I'm very happy to be in a place where
I'm most comfortable having been in
medicine for 40 years up in Dartmouth
and through the New London area
as you all know ALS is also known as Lou
Gehrig's Disease it's a really a fatal
devastating neurodegenerative disease
which patients suffer deeply I have
given you a written testimony hopefully
I'll have it as well as Dr stormel's
It generally strikes people in our age
group 50 to 75 it is thought to be a
disease which is genetically susceptible
and likely even triggered by
environmental you know stimuli
the average survival time from the time
of diagnosis is about 3.3 to 5 years
currently there's absolutely no cure and
there's really no understanding of its
true etiology
establishing an ALS registry in New
Hampshire would help those caring for
these patients better understand the
disease and help treating its rather
rapidly Progressive symptoms
present with me is Dr Elijah stomal Dr
Elijah stoma is a board of neurologist
at Dartmouth Hitchcock who I've worked
with for many years and out in works in
the care of many of these ALS patients
in New Hampshire with his laboratory and
his team
so you might ask why a registry
how many people have ALS
is there a genetic predict
these are straightforward questions we
know this from most diseases we take
care of but we don't know it with ALS
without Registries and research these
questions just go unanswered
it the Registries will help us
understand both the prevalence which is
the total burden in the state or region
in the incidence how many cases per year
are actually discovered
they the Registries help us with um uh
the Natural History genetic
predispositions environmental influences
the benefit of clinical tries and More
in New Hampshire alone we have
approximately 30 to 40 new patients of
ALS every year
but that also is is recognizing that in
the northern part of New England about
20 percent of these patients or patients
with ALS go on undiagnosed and
unrecognized
the Registries help providers give more
accurate advice to patients and families
for clinical pathways which can lead to
improved care and life expectancies
even in the absence of a cure which we
don't have right now
Registries can also help get patients
connected with ALS support systems
and help them navigate really as we
would all recognize a very scary
and sometimes very complicated Health
Care system
we have many Registries in medicine we
have them in cancer and infectious
disease many of you may have been
involved or have family members who have
been involved in actually benefited from
a registry
with the registry
um we get better treatment of diseases
at once were considered basically death
sentences but with research Registries
and identification of the problem a
living long and productive lives
the other the other part of this like
many other
um diseases that we discover and that we
treat and understand the etiology the
derivative basic help here with would
help us with other neurodegenerative
diseases think Alzheimer's disease and
Parkinson's disease
Massachusetts is really the only state
in the country right now with a
reportable mandated uh registry which is
up and running curiously Vermont and
Maine our neighbors now we're surrounded
have just passed legislation to set up
ALS ALS registries
together with our neighboring states we
will better able understand the regional
burden of this disease and work
collaboratively and working the best
possible care for our patients with ALS
Regional integration supported by a
registry helps us get a much broader
data set
diseases that we don't understand are
benefited by getting large data sets the
more data points the better able we are
able to understand demographics risk
factors exposures prevalence and that's
how we lead ourselves to identify causes
and treatment
Dutch stomal already has a very well
established
um I should say he also has a very well
established Department which he runs
it's a very strong laboratory which
takes care of virtually all of the ALS
patients in the state he has a team of
nurses mid-level providers residents
fellows interns all who help them along
with grants that he uses to support his
ALS work
with a registry they will be able to
provide even better care and even you
know understand our regional burden and
then ultimately connect with the
National Registry
if we can then partner in some way or
another with the state
collaborating then with the National
Registry we can which can then provide
us with a you know which is oftentimes
considered a very um potential
consequence of established Registries uh
the National Registry now in the in the
United States uses a system called
redcap which we will have access to the
the physician in charge of the National
Registry has worked with Dr stomel and
has basically stated that we will have
access to the Red Cap system uh which is
a safe electronic storage base
Mr chairman and committee members I
honestly believe that my focus is on the
patient only that's what I've done for
40 years I know that we can work
together in some way or another to
establish an ALS registry which will
only improve the care of our patients
help family and friends who suffer with
this debilitating disease and fatal
disease
it is only with this research and
Registries that we will actually be able
to improve the model of care and
therefore I encourage you to support
this bill
um
I'm more than willing to take any
questions that you may have I am really
not the subject matter expert I did take
care of many patients with ALS only when
they slipped fell and broke a bone or a
hip but I really don't understand ALS
much beyond that
um but I'm willing to answer any
questions you may have of me but also I
have here Dr stomal Who is prepared to
give a statement and answer any
questions which you may have as well
okay thank you any questions for
this gentleman
yes Dr Nagel I mean representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman I'll get it done
eventually
thank you Mr representative Dr Murphy
I just I have two questions if I made
the first one is um
how does this replace what does this
offer us at the National Registry does
not and maybe you're not the right
person to answer I probably am not the
right person I think Dr stomach how do
we know about Dr stomo then and have his
testimony well why would you like to
speak to that because he will be able to
speak more um uh cogently about that do
you want me to answer it now sure go
ahead good so uh the National Registry
is not a reportable mandatory registry
and they probably only get somewhere
like 60 percent of cases in the in the
entire U.S
um and one of the major goals here is to
try to assert in all the cases and even
go through the data to make sure there
aren't false positives
um and in big States like Michigan or
California or Texas if you were able to
get all the cases in a state like that
in one year you'd have an incredible
database and if you could share it with
the National Registry which they would
like to do then uh
it's a win-win situation because they
don't have the the reportable registry
it's a voluntary process
and eventually I could see where the
National Registry might become a
reportable mandatory registry but it
isn't at this time
let me ask a follow-up no go ahead you
kind of asked my second question
um I diagnosed probably one patient a
year with ALS and it's you said the word
mandate what happens to me if I neglect
full in my duty what happens to you if
I'm neglectful in my duty to to I failed
don't even know this registry exists
whatever what happens to me I
just of most Physicians including
yourself would be
um to report I don't think they're
they're going to take you to jail
um I don't think uh you would be find
some huge amount of money
it brings
it to everybody who's in the clinical
world to their attention that it's
something that they need to report the
same thing with Lyme disease or
infectious diseases certain cancers
is sort of on your on your filing system
that you need to report it and
um
if I may also I think that you know as
you well know I think most Physicians
you know when they see that you're
mandated to report something whether
it's Lyme disease or other communicable
diseases we tend to do that in that in
our business so to speak
um uh one of the potential you know
consequences of not reporting which is
when mandated by Statute is even
potentially reporting to Board of
Medicine to say there has been some
egregious Behavior here and you know
maybe a reprimand or at least some
knowledge that they need to do it and
why they need to do it
okay representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair
and also thank you Doug Stonewall taking
my question if we have if I understand
this correctly
redcap currently exists
but the challenge is we're not using it
to its fullest extent
could we simply just mandate
that they reported to Red Cap and not
have to set up our own registry
uh
important to have
some experts who can a certain cases and
review records and make sure that there
is a misdiagnosis you don't want to have
a lot of false positives in a database
follow
-up thank you Mr chair
in saying that
once it goes into the Red Cap
could there be another step which I see
you have been kind enough to volunteer
at least just now
to review a lot of the documents could
at that point your staff or somebody
from the medical center review the
documentation to invalidate the
diagnosis my concern is that
this is kind of frankly State of New
Hampshire being frugally who we are to
get authorization for half a million
dollars is going to be an uphill
challenge so I'm trying to find a way to
allow for
the reporting to occur in an existing
database and if we could do that and
still have your staff review it it may
take care of some of the fiscal note
attached to it with that that's what I'm
trying to get to Okay so okay so our lab
does have red cap and there probably is
a way to funnel the information directly
into my lab
um but we need some kind of legislation
uh stating that it's a mandatory process
but that's you know it's only going to
be about 30 patients a year 30 plus and
I'm reviewing records on 30 patients
every other day sometimes
so representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you doctor for being
here would changing would amending this
to Simply require reporting to Dartmouth
and to allow Dartmouth to maintain this
information be sufficient in order to
achieve these goals
it would be sufficient to me
thank you
representative Weber
good peripheral vision Mr chairman thank
you
um
is
would would rep man would specifying a
is there a concern
other than mine because I don't know
these systems well if we specify either
something like redcap or a particular
program
aren't we creating a real mess for
ourselves if if the program for example
moves from Dartmouth to another
institution or if uh one registry is
found to be less user friendly and
another one is created
I guess I'm asking you the question
about are you more comfortable with a
generic or with a specific
when we're drafting the statute
I don't see where their there would be
another Center in New Hampshire with
such a small number of patients
um
I I don't know where that would be
and the vast majority of ALS patients
in New Hampshire either come to
Dartmouth or end up at Mass General
Hospital especially the ones on the
border
um
and
so I I don't foresee things changing any
kind of drastic way
follow-up representative Weber
so that just raises a follow-up for me
is what happens uh with New Hampshire
patients who are treated in
Massachusetts do they go in our registry
they're the way that those patients
would be captured is through their
primary care physicians who are still in
New Hampshire
yeah
doctor we kind of I kind of preempted
you before you could give a statement do
you still want to give that statement or
well I think
Murphy did a great job but um I could
add a few things okay
um just to give you some examples
um I've been studying ALS for
probably 25 years now and had Fairly
good success with funding and we've had
a lot of epidemiology studies done and
we found clustering of ALS in Northern
New England in many areas one of our
sort of claim claims to fame is that we
were able to find clusters around water
bodies that had cyanobacterial blooms
and cyanotoxins are implicated nail s
and they're animal models that have
shown that and there are clinical trials
going on where you can sort of
arrest that exposure
um
we've seen conjugal couples many
conjugal couples in Northern New England
so people who live in the same house or
work in the same office who come down
with ALS at about the same time those
are fascinating
and we've been collecting
samples from patients saliva blood urine
Nails we found risk factors including
the cyanotoxins heavy metals like lead
and Mercury
eating fish that are high on the trophic
scale seems to be a risk factor for ALS
persistent organic pollutants like
pfases and other chemicals that come
from
electricity technology
I.T technology have persistent organic
pollutants in them that have been linked
to ALS head trauma athleticism
air pollution I work with a with a lady
in a physician
from Mexico City where there's terrible
air pollution and she's finding evidence
of ALS there and teenagers when she
looks at the neuropathology
um so there's probably these factors
including genetic factors and
environmental factors work together and
as an analogy not everybody who smokes
cigarettes gets lung cancer but if you
have the right exposures over the right
period of time it can have a devastating
effect
um
the
was it going to say the VA population
has about a two-fold higher rate of ALS
than the general public and that's been
demonstrated all the way back to World
War II and there's a lag period between
when they're deployed and when they come
down with ALS it's about 10 years and
then there are all these things that
that veterans are exposed to over their
their deployment
um including
dioxins pesticides
diesel exhaust jet exhaust
guns that produce a lot of lead
so there's a lot of unanswered questions
there and you can imagine if the big
States in this country were to have
Registries like like Vermont New
Hampshire not New Hampshire Vermont
Maine and Massachusetts then you really
can make a huge impact on understanding
the disease and one of the keys here is
is that if there's some precedence for
setting these these these
Registries up you might be able to get
the large states involved and then reach
a point where the National Registry can
can
take care of all the data and share it
with whoever needs it so I think
precedence here is is very important
um
I don't think that the cost of a of a
registry in New Hampshire is going to
amount to very much I know there's some
disagreement about that but if my lab
and my helpers were to do the brunt work
and and review records and make sure
they're safe and sound and in electronic
records and shared with the National
Registry
um I think the cost should be minimum
minimal and I have
Paul made his word who's one of the
directors of the National Registry that
he could probably find funds to help
um pay for the assimilation of data and
the storage of data
uh
so I think those are the important
things I wanted to say thank you
I'd like to take the bull by the horns
and and really try to help these ALS
patients it's horrible to see them dying
off and and can't do anything for them
thank you excellent point uh
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
um answering this question
um
you use the number 30 people is that is
that the number of new cases per year
correct yes so that's a pretty minimal
number I I imagine the cumulative
numbers quite a bit more but still low
the incidence is about one to two per
hundred thousand yep so you you said you
just finished saying um that you think
the cost would be minimal but there's a
fiscal note here that where the costs
seem to be
pretty significant especially given
pretty low numbers like
um
over two hundred thousand dollars a year
for two positions
and I don't I don't see that that would
be necessary and then it costs should we
ignore I guess well my question is
should we ignore this part of the bill
at this point when we first wrote up the
bill we were using some of the
neighboring states models going forward
we didn't Vermont and Maine don't have
an academic Medical Center like Dr
stomals that can be a repository for all
of the data so in order to do that we we
basically were using the model where
they were having that model having
spoken with Dr stormel in the robust
nature of his laboratory that the bottom
line is you know he will be the
repository for a lot of the data the
data collection the interpretation and
then ultimately
um sharing it nationally uh with other
states
um so I think that we can actually kind
of we will ultimately minimize any
potential costs with a significant
enhancement and the other derivative
benefit is oftentimes when you
understand a disease process like ALS
you also are understanding other
diseases like Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's disease they are and I'm not
a neurologist
Dr stomal is and he can tell you that
there are similarities in trying to
understand one has oftentimes a
derivative benefit of helping others
well beyond that diagnosis
um yes follow-up
yes thank you um so so it sounds like
the fiscal note is not accurate because
now the thinking is that this um
registry could actually be incorporated
into the the Dartmouth program
um it would seem to me I don't really
know how one does this but um that
the bill should be refined before we
vote on it so that um
so that people will be actually voting
on something that's accurate and also
maybe a little bit more um
yeah palatable after I was speaking with
Dr stormel and after the bill was
originally
um uh drafted uh we recognized that as
well that the fiscal note probably is
well beyond what is absolutely necessary
Dr stomal Labs is already very robust
um there is already mechanisms in place
for you know privacy there is also the
need to assimilate all of the data
combine it nationally and actually make
an impact on a disease that's fairly
devastating representative thank you
possibly an amendment uh I don't know if
you want to do that but that might be
something to consider representative
Weber
well I'm wondering if the mechanism
isn't already in the bill on would the
language on page 1 lines 23 to 30 be the
mechanism by which the commissioner
could simply say
I I'm going to have somebody else do it
and I'm not going to provide an awful
lot of funding for it yeah honestly
would that would that suffice at this
point or you know thank you for that
question I don't have the bill right in
front of me but I understand the intent
my understanding when we drafted the
bill was that much of this data would be
deposited into and I I don't know the
exact numbers but I don't want to put
words in dot just almost but I imagine
he has 99 of all the patients with ALS
in the state of New Hampshire and we
don't really need a very robust system
my intent and I will work with others
um in in our region right here with us
to figure out how we get the data to Dr
stormel's Laboratory
um and I think it will be at a minimal
cost basically because he already has a
system up and running and could I have
one follow-up Mr chair
follow-up and will you also be working
with the Department to satisfy the
department that the language is not
putting on them the onus of a large
structure that they're not prepared to
deal with in the absence of a
significant amount of funding and for
which it doesn't sound like there's any
need because there's already a structure
available right our conversations prior
to presenting today with the Department
was basically to have those
conversations
uh Dr representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman
um Dr stumble I've known of you for a
very long time I think the work you're
doing is absolutely wonderful and very
needed and I appreciate you doing that
um I've been involved with universities
a lot and I know people come and they go
continuity is extremely important with
the registry and I'm curious what the
plan would be for registry when you're
not there anymore and I don't know what
your time frame is what's that sorry
yeah so so um
I think you know people come and go as
you said and uh
I feel deeply that that I would turn
this over to somebody who is responsible
somebody's going to have to take care of
the ALS patients when I'm gone and uh
they're going to continue to come in
and uh it's if you have any interest in
research
everything will be set up for you and um
you know it's it's you're being held
handed a golden uh platter and I would
also from retirement I would also add
that you know I am no longer fixing
bones anymore but I know there are
adequate you know uh there are excellent
people at Dartmouth still taking care of
good taking care of Bones and that is
basically the legacy of the church here
Medical Center bringing on people that
can actually carry on the work that's
already starting thank you any other
questions yes representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Dr
stromo and Murphy
so given everything that has been shared
and the clarification that you would
house the registry
and this clarification that mandatory
reporting to you would be sufficient I
am wondering
would that then also mean you would be
reporting to the National Registry or
um you need that uh sort of clarified as
an expectation and could you be
designated as the
given the prior conversation could you
be designated as the the state
registry not naming Dartmouth but the
State academic ALS registry
I don't know exactly what you'd call it
but um
there's a ALS Center of Excellence at
Dartmouth which is part of the ALS
Association
so um we could come up with a title and
and contact people including myself
that could and you would do the
reporting as part of that or does that
need to be authorized to the FED to this
National Registry we would have a
easy system by which to transfer data
from
the registry at Dartmouth Hitchcock to
the National Registry
how's that representative thank you okay
other questions
representative Merchant
so
that I'm clear all right are you
supporting then that the commissioner
would be the one to hold the
responsibility but the commission would
therefore work with Dartmouth Health
disestablished registry and so forth so
if you look at where it says here in the
establishment the commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall established are you proposing then
the commission of the Department of
Health and Human Services shall work
with Dartmouth Health to establish and
create
is that the intent are you talking about
just Dr sumo
well I don't think that there would be
really a need for a commissioner to
review data I think it could go directly
to the ALS Center
yeah right
okay
other questions
I think we're good thank you very much
oh I'm sorry
sure go ahead
so rather than
establish could it be designate
as far as the language
because we have cancer Registries at
Dartmouth that are the official state
cancer registry so akin to that you
already have the registry it's just not
the official state one
that might be taken up in a work session
or during the amendment process
representative Weber you had a comment
okay
okay any other questions uh I'm seeing
none thank you very much gentlemen thank
you
next up is uh and let me take my glasses
off for this one
representative Stringham
sounds like I could use a handwriting
lesson though for you no it's just it's
my vision
thank you very much I'm Jerry Stringham
I'm the representative from Lincoln and
Woodstock I'm a member of Finance three
outside of of the state house I am a
consultant in the healthcare industry
mainly working on reimbursement for
medical technology which among other
things has me authoring studies using
longitudinal data from claims data or
registries
uh but I'm I'm here really I think we
heard most of what we had to hear about
the bill itself but I'm here uh to talk
about my personal experience with ALS my
brother-in-law Dane Ward was a wonderful
spouse to my sister uh Jenny he was an
intelligent healthy and kind soul he was
in his late 50s
and was a runner and in perfect shape
great health his whole life at his
eldest son's wedding it was the first
time we noticed that his leg wasn't
raising right and he uh he tripped a
couple of times three months later he
was a full boar diagnosed with ALS in
one year one and a half years later he
passed away having gone through the
incredible typical ALS devastating
decline
um
this bill is important and was asked for
by members of the ALS Community I know
because there are many research areas
still unstudied that could help these
people my brother-in-law Dean was a PhD
and he was selected to be part of an ALS
study group that kept a prioritized list
of over 500 different identified
projects that that they could
potentially benefit from and he after
reading through the list one day said
just for the heck of it he went to the
lowest priority project on there and he
thought it was actually pretty good
so there's a lot of unexplored
opportunity
and leveraging from the history of
others that can happen through registry
is really important
cures and better treatment can come from
these types of observational studies
that come out of these and um uh you
know um I
um
I think that this type of registry can
help people like Dane and uh I hope
there's a way we can we can establish it
here in New Hampshire
um and I do know this this group has
been incredibly uh effective at raising
money through things like the ice Buck
bucket challenge uh and um
so I'm I'm sure there'll be it'll be
leveraged to the fullest if it exists
and I'm also very grateful for Dr Steve
oh for all he did there was a Dr Stegall
supporting my brother-in-law that uh uh
we were grateful for every day so thank
you thank you any are you taking
questions are there any questions
apparently not thank you
in the last pink card certainly not last
but not least we um have our friend
Attorney John Williams from Health and
Human Services welcome back and Lisa
servoice am I pronouncing that correctly
you did
um good afternoon uh members of the
committee and and chairman McDonald my
name is John Williams I'm the director
of legislative affairs for the
Department of Health and services and
with me today is
good afternoon I'm Lisa cerice the new
bureau chief for population health and
Community Services over on public health
and HB 329 represents a really good
model of problem solving and I have to
thank represent Jim Murphy James Murphy
for taking the time to hear the
Department's concerns I would um want to
make one clarification the fiscal
analysis that was done by the
Legislative budget Assistance Office
based upon information thoughtful
information supplied by the department
is accurately reflected based upon the
four corners of the document and the
bill that's in front of you the bill
that's in front of you does mandate that
the department set up a registry I
registry that you've heard now
testifying that the academic medical
folks are able to do and this is a
really good example because this bill
actually came before this committee and
for those of you who were here in 2019
there was HB 644 a very thoughtful Bill
pretty much similar testimony Dr stomal
came and testified to the committee as
well but it didn't go forward because it
didn't have a funding mechanism for the
Department to move forward with the bill
we do think and I have to say that very
insightful questions I would say at
least four or five great questions from
this side of the room not to ignore
folks over here but but Bill's sponsor
Bill sponsor is over here and he was
testifying but also from the front of
the room with your leadership you
actually came up with a solution that we
were talking with out in the hallway
with with Doctor uh excuse me
sorry representative Robert
um representative Murphy
um on this bill and so we think we can
work out a solution to this um key to
this bill is the mandated reporting
requirement that can be taken out of the
department statutes and rather put in
the physician surgeon statutes so that
it would show that those individuals
would have a reporting requirement we
don't want to see people go to the jail
or anything like that we want it to be a
positive collaborative environment but
it doesn't require the Department's
oversight hhs's oversight or involvement
I would also suggest and this is one of
those rare occasions because I think
that representative Weber is one of the
finest drafters of legislation but this
is one of those rare occasions where
identifying a specific entity is really
critically important because they're the
one entity that could do that here in
New Hampshire that could be accomplished
through a chapter law versus putting it
into an RSA so with those changes we are
here as a resource to represent Murphy
the committee and we think we can come
up with a solution that we didn't come
up with back in 2019 I know
representative shame on well at least
one person testifying right now but I do
think we have a solution to eliminating
the fiscal impact of the bill by taking
the department completely out of the
conversation in terms of at least the
program now with that said we like
Dartmouth find that information to be
critically important critically valuable
and that's why I have the wonderful Miss
Royce next to me who's going to tell you
about the merits of the importance of
that information anything else you'd
like to testify to and remaining one
minute 30 seconds that we have
I'm representative Murphy and Dr
stromwell did a really nice job of
giving an overview of ALS and you know
under the way this bill is written such
to what John just said in addition to
the registry if if that's being moved
out from under the department there is
other language in here around the
development and design of educational
materials and Outreach materials
so I would just share that that would
need to be something that is discussed
as well because currently in public
health there there is no program or
resources or funding or staff focused on
ALS right now so that would be something
new and then to also just share
um RSA 141b and 141c do not include ALS
as a reportable as a reportable disease
and currently we do not have the
authority under us to mandate something
like this to be reported
and that'll just quickly share as you
know we think about Als in the the
incidents and the prevalence
um those are estimates that were
provided and when we look at the
National Data we know that the
prevalence of this is around 5.5 per 100
000 people and then incidents so new
cases around 1.5 cases per hundred
thousand so every life is important you
know the fiscal impact here would be
pretty severe for the department and so
it's nice to see that there are some
options on the table
thank you any questions
no I'm sorry representative King
yeah I didn't catch the rsas that you
mentioned uh I heard 141 141b and 141c
I'm sorry can you repeat the last one
DNC
thank you very simple
I believe we also sent written testimony
to the committee as well and that is
those are in there as well
thank you representative Weber
so just as a drafting guideline we would
need to change those statutes as well to
include this as a mandated recording or
are you saying we
leave it out of there and just put it
somewhere else
I work with office of professional
licensure then that would be something
different to mandate Physicians to
report this so we would not need to
revise 141 B or C okay thank you
Department yes and the critical statute
to references under chapter 329
physician surgeon statute we think that
that at least preliminarily with a
needed conversation to our friends at
the office of professional licensure and
certification who we love and adore hi
uh to the viewing audience and so we do
need to make sure they're included in
that conversation under that chapter for
the reporting requirement
great other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
okay I know of no one else ahead of
testifier on this bill
so I'm going to is anyone else does
anyone else wish to do so
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 329 and open the
public hearing on HB 614.
I recognize the the prime sponsor again
another representative Murphy for this
purpose
good afternoon chairman McDonald Vice
chair Leon and honorable members of the
committee my name is Nancy Murphy and I
come before you from Hillsborough County
District 12 representing the town of
Merrimack a pfas impacted community
I'm the sponsor of HB 614 a bill that
when filed proposed creating a pfas
repository to collect adverse Health
outcome information and data relative to
areas impacted by per and
polyfluorinated alkyl substance pfas in
air emissions and drinking water
this initiative was one of those
recommended for legislation and included
within the most recent HB 737 pfas
commission report
on January 13th shortly after the filing
deadline for the final language on the
bill DHHS presented an updated cancer
report to the HB 737 commission related
to an increase of excess cases of
identified kidney cancer in Merrimack
through this reporting DHHS made a
recommendation that in response to the
increase in cases the next appropriate
steps would be to conduct a phase 3
feasibility study
this feasibility study was another of
the recommendations in the hb7 HB
737pfest commission annual report
as it is germane and with your
permission I would like to introduce a
replace all amendment to hb614 that
would include language and an
appropriation for the Department of
Health and Human Services to engage in
this next step it is important work that
has potential to benefit communities
Beyond Merrimack feasibility study
relative to kidney cancers in this pfas
contaminated Community as proposed in
this amendment is essentially
foundational work for the data
collection sought for our health
outcomes Repository
and can identify appropriate Cancers and
health outcomes for inclusion in a
potential epidemiological study
with your permission I have copies that
I could I could pass out sure thank you
this amendment has been brought forward
after a significant collaboration with
DHHS
um and I want to explain a little bit
about why I've come home with this
amendment
given the statistically significant
excess in the number of cases of kidney
cancer in Merrimack the known exposure
of this community to environmental
contaminants like pfas that have been
associated with kidney cancer
an increase in the number of those
cancer diagnoses over time
and the recommendation of New
Hampshire's DHHS that a feasibility
study as determined by the New Hampshire
cancer concern investigation protocol
phase three be conducted to further
investigate this very concerning
negative Health outcome
HB 614 is amended is meant to authorize
an appropriation to fund this cancer
investigation protocol as despite its
many wonderful employees DHHS does not
have the expertise in-house nor
resources to complete the study itself
this work would be done through a
contract with an academic or research
organization and would inform the next
steps in the investigation
feasibility study would identify
appropriate Cancers and health outcomes
to be included in a phase four
epidemiological study if that is
determined to be warranted as well as
any next steps
additionally hb614 would allow DHHS to
identify potential exposures that may
contribute to this excess of kidney
cancer incidents and Aid in
understanding
how those exposures May contribute to
the excess of kidney cancer incidents in
Merrimack
I'm sure you all know probably what a
feasibility study is I did not know
myself
and in terms of HB 614 it's part of the
cancer investigation protocol the
purpose of which is to gather more
information to see if it's likely that a
study will show whether or not the
cancer cases that we see here in
Merrimack
relate to a common cause for example the
long-term exposure Merrimack residents
have had to the pfest contamination of
our air water and soil
there are a number of steps in regards
to the study that um DC excuse me DHHS
could certainly elaborate on and they're
here and I know willing to to take
questions
um why we need this study you know it's
a full epidemiological study is is time
and resource intensive I mean it's an
important important to determine whether
or not that level of study is warranted
um the feasibility study would also
identify appropriate Cancers and health
outcomes for their inclusion in the
study I know when we looked at the
Cancer report that we received in 2018
there were a number of other cancers I
think at least three or four that were
just below that level where they um uh
they reached the sir number and so you
know we were talking kidney cancer is
certainly an excess but in the Merrimack
Community has concerns about a number of
other of cancers and health impacts as
well
this study will tell us
um it could help determine the
plausibility that cases and contaminants
have the potential to be Associated
and it would help us identify those
cancers I mean other health outcomes for
inclusion in that in a future study
the benefits to impacted citizens we
would finally have the data that we
believe exists but we just don't have it
collected anywhere that shows our cancer
cases may be related to a common cause
and that may impact things such as
medical monitoring and also the more we
know
our decision making is based on
information
so um this is you know it's a bit of
information that we don't have
um the this will provide us a better
understanding of the strengths and
limitations of existing Public Health
surveillance tools to support this work
I know we had originally talked about a
registry and then a repository of this
health information
but part of the the challenge is making
sure that we have the tools to to access
all that information so we have a place
it's a place to put it and then it will
drive decision making down the road
um uh as far as privacy concerns uh
around the um the study DHHS is a HIPAA
covered entity uh it safeguards and
secures any personally identified by
excuse me identifiable data and
information for federal regulations
um information would be self-reported by
by individuals identified as a case via
a survey and it would be securely stored
in a public health database all
summaries and ports would aggregate the
results uh to protect privacy and
confidentiality
um you know I know that there's a
there's a a um appropriation
um involved here and you know I want to
answer the question as to why is this
study worth the money that we're asking
be appropriated
uh this the feasibility study uh would
provide information that we don't have
now
um and around people that have diagnosed
with cancer while living in Merrimack
New Hampshire that could help inform the
development of a research proposal for
that epidemiological study that I I
referred to
um and help us understand the difference
in risk factors
knowledge drives decision making and for
example living in a highly impacted pfas
Community like Merrimack we must be able
to show that there's increased risk and
negative human impacts on New Hampshire
citizens associated with that exposure
if we're ever really going to be able to
truly impact our environment and the
human health from risk these negative
Health outcomes increase health care
costs to Citizens and government and
negatively impact the quality and lives
of our of our citizens
uh representatives from DHHS are here
are far better equipped to answer many
of the specific questions relative to
the study
um and I know they're they're here and
willing to do that
um on behalf of a community greatly and
disproportionately negative impacted by
a life-altering cancer diagnosis
one known to be associated with the pfas
contamination we have had long-term and
ongoing exposure to I ask that you
please vote OTP on HB 614 thank you for
your time and attention have you taken
questions representative or do you want
to defer those through HHS
um I I would imagine that probably many
of the questions would probably be more
specific to the study but I can answer
questions if any questions for
representative Murphy
okay and we will pick it up thank you so
much thank you very much
okay also a sign up to testify is
representative Rosemary Wang
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for the record my name is
Rosemarie wrong I'm a state
representative from Hillsboro 12 which
is the town of Merrimack I'm not going
to repeat uh the comments of
Representative Murphy but I do want to
say that for the past three years I've
been a member of the pfas commission
that resulted from the passage of HB 737
it's comprised of representatives from
the towns of Merrimack Bedford and
Litchfield last year we added the town
of Londonderry to be represented since
they have also been impacted by pvas
contamination from the Merrimack
operations of Saint Cobain the last two
years I've served as chair and one of
the observations I've held and I I'm
it's been shared by other members of the
commission and by people in the
communities is we don't have
comprehensive data to really understand
the impact and the extent of of the
health impacts from this contamination
and
um many times in the community people
just rely on anecdotal stories about
cancer oh this neighborhood's been
really impacted and that type of
speculation
um really damages The credibility of
decision making that we need to make and
an accountability for what's going on
the last point I want to make in support
of this bill is that I believe this
feasibility study will help DHHS and
I'll let them speak for themselves but
but my opinion is that it would help
them identify infrastructure processes
and procedures that can be applied to
much other situations or other diseases
or other ways that we can more
efficiently and effectively collect data
to be able to drive good decisions that
benefit New Hampshire
so with that I would be happy to take
any questions
any questions for representative rung
I see none thank you representative
thank you very much
and the last individual signed up to
testify today is Abby Rogers from the
Department of Health and Human Services
good afternoon good afternoon Mr chair
members of the committee my name is Abby
Rogers I'm the legislative liaison for
the division of Public Health Services I
thought I put Michelle roberge's name on
the card I apologize apologies if I did
not I'm joined by Michelle brobears who
is the bureau chief of the Bureau of
Health protection I wanted to clarify
that we are speaking on the amendment to
HB 614 that would be number 2023011
1H that representative Murphy uh just
described to the committee and I will
let Michelle speak to that
thank you representative McDonald and
members of the committee again my name
is Michelle Roberge I'm the bureau chief
for public health protection within the
division of Public Health Services I
apologize I have a bit of a cold so I'm
going to keep my mask on can everybody
hear me okay
good hopefully I can get through this
without coughing as well sure you just
move the microphone up closer to your
face is this better okay thank you
um as Abby said we're speaking on the
proposed replace all Amendment for HB
614 20
2023-0-111h the department is in support
of this proposed uh replace all
Amendment we are here as a resource for
the committee and we are happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have I have two additional colleagues
with me here today that I would like to
just introduce we have Whitney Hammond
Whitney is she is our um
chronic disease section administrator
within the division and I also have Dr
Kathleen bush
who is our environmental Public Health
tracking section administrator as well
that are are here as a resource and if
you have specific questions they may be
able to answer as well
on January 13th the department presented
the cancer incident report Merrimack New
Hampshire to the commission on the
environmental and public health impacts
of pfas substances commonly referred as
HB 737 Commission
the department has been serving on that
commission as a resource for potential
Health impacts from pfas exposure to the
communities represented by the
commission which includes Merrimack this
report is available on our website but
it we can also provide the report if if
you are interested in that please let us
know
it is the position of the department
that the proposed amendment language to
HB 614 presented today by representative
Murphy is more aligned with the
Department's recommendations regarding
next steps in exploring potential
exposures that could have contributed to
the excess number of kidney cancer cases
observed in Merrimack rather than
requesting the department to collect
data on reported adverse Health impacts
in a voluntary pfas repository which was
which was the language including
included as the in the bill as
introduced
the department has worked in
collaboration with representative Murphy
regarding the proposed language
modification we would which would
provide necessary funds to support the
Department's recommendation to conduct a
feasibility study that would be
completed through a contract with an
academic or research organization and
would inform next steps of the
investigation
sorry
the department recommends that this
investigation moved to phase three in
accordance with the Department's cancer
concern investigation protocol which
includes a feasibility study as noted
early this earlier the study would
require additional funding and
partnership with an academic or research
organization the phase three study would
determine if an epidemiological study or
phase four
in in as we refer to it in the cancer
concern investigation protocol whether
that epidemiological study would be
warranted and if it would identify
appropriate Cancers and health outcomes
for inclusion in the study the proposed
500 000 appropriation to be a provided
for the biennium ending June 30th 2023
to the department would help fund this
study
and we would be happy to answer any
questions that you may have on the
amendment or provide any more detail
around the reports to the commission
thank you questions
yes representative Weber
so you made reference in your testimony
to the study the doctor that
representative Murphy was talking about
and um I guess I'm just wondering is is
this the language that you prefer at
this point the language of the amendment
is presented or do you think that this
needs further work I'm not under I
wasn't unjust clear about that sorry
about that no we are supportive of the
current language okay the amendment the
amendment Amendment thank you I just
wanted to be sure I had that right yeah
it's consistent just it's consistent
with their recommendations in the report
other questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you thank you
I know of no one else signed up to
testify is there anyone here who wishes
to testify on HB 614
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on hb614 and open the
public hearing on HB 582
I would recognize a representative
Stapleton the prime sponsor to come
forward
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee
um
I am here to uh present
HB 582
FN
which is about the sixth attempt at uh
bringing this bill to completion
fruition
for a number of years
for the reporting of
induced pregnancy termination statistics
short form as abortion statistics
our past
um really brief history was the last
bill
the last session was 1654 that got
tabled along with an attempted Amendment
and before that was 158
and then
before that SP 111
and prior to that
[Music]
um
well I don't know what the numbers might
be but we've had a number of iterations
and a number of attempts
and we've learned from each one of those
attempts
to rectify shortcomings and address
concerns especially for privacy
and the collection use and
distribution of non-identifying
anonymous anonymous data so that no
persons are identified in any way either
by location or by person or any other
effects
the bill
why is it important
we're a population now of about 340
million people
according to the good marker Institute
the CDC the American Life league and
several other organizations
since 1973 when Roe v Wade was declared
in doe versus Bolton
we've had something like 63 million
abortions accounted for
probably more because many of them maybe
otherwise classified as miscarriages or
not reported or
somehow slipped through the cracks
and you know if you were to add the
effect of contraception which is not
part of this bill I'm just talking in
context here
you probably would be short of a hundred
million
births since 1973.
that's a large segment of population
and is it any Wonder these days that we
see
help wanted
now hiring
a shortage of employees in every venue
in every industry
Health Care too
so this is a huge impact
on American population and American
Health
now we report
all kinds of health statistics
in just about every way possible
and the Department of Health and Human
Services has a health wisdom site maybe
differently named now in
transition
that you can find just about every
Melody and ailment and condition
concerning human health on that except
for
most of the
induced pregnancy termination statistics
and I would submit to you many claim
that abortion is Health Care well if
that's true
shouldn't that also be a component of
the state's concern
the concern of the people to know what's
happening in that realm of Health
instead of tucking it away in the corner
and putting a dark cloth over the top of
it
so we worked
to find what would be best
practices for reporting from the
standpoint of privacy
keeping this keeping data discrete
collection very regimented
and final reporting by DHHS
under strict safety criteria and
guarding privacy
the
division of Vital Records and the
Secretary of State offices has the
Machinery to collect
all kinds of critical life data like
marriages births deaths
and are well suited to handle this task
also with an addition of a module
some years ago
several years I'm not sure when
that responsibility for data collection
was taken from the Department of Health
and Human Services and moved over to
division of Vital Records
so we were able to determine earlier on
in the last 1654 bill that that was the
proper continued proper venue for that
the department
New Hampshire research office of
legislative research helped
to discern
what the standard reporting requirements
would best be
on this particular subject
and in the bill
there is an itemization
that basically was taken off the form
and the best practices from
from the CDC
and and that basically
is on
page three starting at line 14.
all of those
um itemized
items there
are um taken from the CDC specification
and why do we use the CDC specification
because 47 other states use it
New Hampshire California and Maryland
are the only three that do not report
and that doesn't make sense if this is
an important statistic it should be
reportable by all states and we should
we should join the other 47
not only for National figures but also
so that we know what's going on in the
state
and can read understand and know the
extent of this practice within the state
but for the sake of reporting the CDC
specification does make sense
because they've been down this road
before and it's worked for 47 other
states
the big question was
how are we going to protect the data
so that individuals are not
disclosed
or make known and so
the system sets up a confidential
um
provider number
and
a confidential
patient number and that resides with the
provider
the data goes to
division of Vital Records
in aggregate
non-identifying form
and those figures are
tallied and aggregated
and then when complete for the period or
year then it turned over the Department
of Health and Human Services for their
inclusion along with other Health Data
in the health wisdom system
as I say we had
challenges of the concern of privacy and
rightly so
and we think we've addressed that
completely
and this is the fifth attempt and uh
I think we've we've covered all of the
concerns and patched all of the unknowns
with this bill
the only thing we're waiting for now is
a
Financial note from the Department of
Health and Human Services relative to
their cost
for publication
the discrete publication within their
system
I see that the financial note from
the
division of Vital Records
shows uh
expenditures of 25
000 to 50 thousand dollars for the
addition of the module onto their
existing system
I think that's a completely reasonable
amount
and even though we don't know the DHHS
figure yet
I can't imagine that it can be far
exceeding out of range of that
reasonable number
but they maybe can testify on that and
or produce the FN as requested here
before
so that's basically my summary and I'd
be happy to take questions on the
Stapleton before you leave today could
you make sure you've fill out a pink
card we don't have one from you I'm
sorry I will do that thank you sir our
records questions for representative
Stapleton representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Stapleton for taking my
question
could you help me explain why in the
bill
on page five
line six seven and eight are there
because we're talking about patient
confidentiality and you're saying
that would be kept completely sacred and
protected then why do we need to have
that inserted into the bill
um this page five line six seven and
eight
just so everybody knows that reads Roman
13 any data collected pursuant to RSA
126 colon 25
I may personally identify either the
health care provider who perform
an induced termination of pregnancy or
the patient on whom it was performed
this exemption shall not include
non-identifying information required to
be disclosed under
RSA 126 colon 25.
um
try to cover all the aspects of law
including RSA 91
and
um that is just I had help with this
with a number of people an attorney
that suggested that this is an important
component of this bill
follow-up follow-up so my concern is
that the reason why that would be here
in this bill
is the fact that that data that we're
talking about being so private in
reality may not be as private as we
think it's going to be so therefore we
have to be sure it's excluded from
Discovery
and so my concern goes back to the same
question about is privacy we had a
meeting this morning on another bill
about the issue of data integrity
yeah we're going to give the department
some very sensitive data
and we're not even sure they have the
ability to protect the data we have
today
and our concern
on this bill how that's what I'm trying
to understand from your point of view
how are we going to ensure that the data
that's being collected I don't think we
have to collect the number one but it's
going to be really protected because
everything I'm reading through this
there are concerns about its privacy and
security
from what I understand is that the
Department of Health and Human Services
and the division of Vital Records have
not had
outages relative to Health Data
and maybe they've had one or two blips
but from last testimonies I've heard
we've got a pretty good and secure
system in the state
if there's a violational law and there's
a court order
um for disclosure
that's not something that the Department
of Health and Human Services or the
division of Vital Records is going to
disclose they don't have the ability to
do so because of the aggregated nature
of the collected data
court order will have to go right to the
provider
for that particular information and
that's where it resides
okay any other questions
see any okay thank you representative
Stapleton thank you please don't forget
the pink card we'll do that
okay next uh next person who signed up
to testify is representative Daniel Papa
bovich right
Miller
I'm going to give you a lot of line on
those cards to write a long name thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
I really appreciate it I promised you on
the card that I'll keep it to one minute
I'll just steal a few seconds at the
beginning of this testimony to bring up
that I am a co-sponsor an hb397 that
came to the committee this morning and I
it was my intent to come testifying
support but I am the clerk for the
finance 2 committee and there was no way
for me to uh you know excuse myself from
that meeting so I just wanted to quickly
bring that up
and this is in my opinion a clear
necessity this bill and this data
because of the amazingly contentious
nature of those types of decisions that
we have to make as a legislature
there are a lot of passions and heated
you know positions on both sides of the
aisle and I think it would behoove all
of us to have a good understanding of
what is actually going on how many of
these procedures happen when do they
happen data is not designed to support
one stance or the other it's just meant
to inform us and help us understand
exactly what's going on so we can all
make more more informed decisions I
completely agree with the concern for
the privacy of the data I think it is
essential that this is just
non-identifiable aggregate data for
policy reasons it should not be used in
any way to you know disclose information
about an individual so those safeguards
in my opinion are already in the bill
and to me that additional layer of
security was just a catch-all in case
other parts of the law may not be fully
adhered to it's better to have more
layers of support than too few in the
hope that there are all they're not all
needed but again I strongly support this
bill and similar types of bills because
as policy makers we need to understand
the impact of the bills we pass that
includes understanding how many people
will be affected and how and you know to
me that's critical information and I
would urge all of you to consider
supporting it thank you very much for
the time
thank you questions uh representative
Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh does it make sense
to you that we involve
first one division in collecting this
data and then the transport of the data
to the Department of Health which is
actually what we're talking about
wouldn't it make more sense to collect
transmit the data just once thereby
uh lessening the possibility of a slip
and putting it immediately in the place
which is where it's destined to go
very honestly any method that the
committee finds the most desirable to
achieve this result I will
enthusiastically support you have more
information on all the you know details
involved and at the end of the day
regardless who the sponsor is on this
bill it becomes a committee's bill and
anything any method in which you can
achieve this objective I will be very
happy with I'm not really invested in
whether it's this department or their
Department whichever method does the job
of just providing this reporting and
this information I will be happy with
thank you representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
if the focus is on the what and not the
who
could we not eliminate The Who
eliminate the patient and provider just
collect aggregated data and therefore we
wouldn't have to risk any concerns with
privacy and security about privacy but
just collect the what and not the who
I believe that right now the patient
identity is not collected at all it is
the information you know it's just a
code number that is only known to the
provider
I believe that it is necessary in order
to verify the Integrity of the data if
it ever comes called into question if
you ever have to audit an a medical
provider for failing to comply with this
you know I mean at the end of the day
I'm not I don't see any enforcement
mechanisms in this law right now this is
a pure requirement but as a data person
I used to be a database developer I
wrote a lot of code your data is only
good if you can at some point spot check
it and verify I do not foresee this
being you know
a huge issue but you know as I said at
the end of the day
any step forward that the committee
comes up with will be welcomed even if
it is maybe less you know than what the
original uh intent of the bill was
thank you any other yes representative
physician by training I've delivered
babies taken care of uh prenatal women
and I'm also Health Services researcher
by training and I'm very hard-pressed to
understand the actual reason for having
this kind of a bill I wonder if we would
also track his um
um vasectomies and the number of
gallbladders that are removed and other
organs that are removed so I I really am
struggling I am new but I'm I'm not
understanding the reason for why this is
something that needs as someone who
teaches others about data and the
importance of its use in collection I
really am hard-pressed so I'd appreciate
um some some insight
thank you if I may address that
I completely respect your professional
opinion and obviously you know you have
chosen an amazingly rewarding career and
thank you for serving so many people
I hear you say that you know perhaps
clinically you don't need this
information to make those decisions but
when I ran for election it was my first
time running for the house this year
I didn't really open the topic much and
yet half of every discussion came to
these types of laws I think as
legislators we have the duty to again
understand the impact of the laws we
passed as a provider absolutely you are
focused on that one patient in front of
you the decision is clear you don't need
that for medical purposes but I believe
that as legislators we do need to
collect this type of information when we
write laws on the topic
okay representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair
a lot of you know hospitals and physical
therapists and stuff like that they they
love to boast their numbers about how
many people they helped throughout the
year it's usually pretty common I think
um are the abortion providers
intentionally not disclosing how many I
mean aren't they really proud of how
many abortions they've given and what I
mean isn't this information already
publicly available does it need to be
done through the government or are they
really keeping very tight-lipped about
how many they provide thank you thank
you I obviously cannot speak for the
intent of any medical provider in making
whatever decisions they make I you know
I'm not a mind reader I don't presume to
have that
I think there is a difference between
the numbers that people
sometimes publish voluntarily and uh you
know more accurate numbers will be
provided in order to um you know
to comply with a legal mandate and also
while a lot of them are talking about it
some of them aren't just the data that's
voluntarily reported of course a lot of
data is voluntarily reported but
definitely not all of it
okay yes representative
follow up on previous question uh would
you imagine that on like uh late terms
abortion we will have more data if it's
a practice that exists or how common it
is uh as opposed to General statistics
on how many abortions will be available
if this
take effect thank you I the bill is not
focused on one type of abortion on over
the other it's a bill that's focused on
the system as a whole and the you know
holistic you know complete data set of
course when we start analyzing date
complete data sets for policy reasons
every legislature legislator may look at
certain numbers or others but I think it
is critical for all of us to start from
the same total numbers when we make
those decisions and then whatever area
one legislator May Focus over another
that's up to the 400 people in the house
and 24 in the Senate and so on but
I think at the end of the day
we all look at it and have different
numbers from different people wouldn't
our decisions be better informed if we
had a common number set of numbers to
start our analysis from and just have
the confidence that they have been
verified by state agencies who are you
know trusted to report accurately who
are non-partisan who will just report
the data as is I think it's important to
start from that common set of numbers
when we look at the you know certain
aspects of this policy
other questions
okay well thank you thank you very much
I really appreciate your time
next signed up to testify is deputy
secretary of state Aaron Hennessey
good afternoon chamber and chairman and
members of the committee it's nice to
see everyone today I am here to offer
information about this bill and to ask
for a clarification on one point
as noted the division has noted the
um amount estimated amount to create
this new module the about fifty thousand
dollars we have a new vendor within our
division of Vital Records that's
um creating our new modules and um we
have a very good relationship with them
they're very responsive so we're hoping
that this fiscal note is accurate in in
order to do this
um the one question I do have for the
committee and hopefully you you can look
into this further and get back to us
because it could create more of a
difficult situation in trying to perform
what we are tasked to do with and that
is on page two
and it it surrounds the confidentiality
of the provider
um and I see it kind of like a a circle
um just keep going around in a circle
where we're not allowed to keep the
names of a provider
um any personal identifying information
but we have to give providers
confidential
numbers for their health care provider
or for for the individual or for the
provider the facility so I'm not quite
sure how that would be done
to give someone a confidential number
without knowing who we're given a
confidential number to so that's just
one question that we would have need
clarification on if this bill were to
pass I'm happy to take questions
uh representative Weber
for clarification could you tell me
where on page two you're subjecting to
the language sorry questioning the
language it's not an objection it's a
concern
um it's um on page two lines 12 through
16. and then also looking down
um lines 27 through 29.
thank you very much
other questions
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you
for taking the question
is that different on line 22 on page one
that someone's gonna
issue identification number to your
point
however if you turn over on page two on
line one there's also a patient
confidential number
who is going to issue that is that going
to be the same concern with the patient
we have with the provider
thank you for the question
representative I don't know that the the
patient confidential number would be
necessarily something the division would
issue it could be something the provider
issues or it would be a randomly
generated number within the module
itself
unless the policy were to try and track
the same confidential patient more than
once and that would that would need
clarification then as well
um but to your point about
um line 22 on page one that doesn't that
just I sets the definition for the
health care provider or facility
um and doesn't at that point doesn't
indicate that we wouldn't be able to
identify
within our division
other questions representative Weber
can you clarify or perhaps maybe just
Express a preference because you weren't
the drafter of the bill
um
if
if it is if if the
identified
data which is linked to a patient name
is held
at the provider's office
then how
this may be the same question in a
different form
how is the patient
the patient's individual code going to
uh be generated and indicate where
their residences by state city town or
County and and if if this is here's what
I was really trying to get at if this is
generated by the module that resides in
Vital Records how does that then not
stay linked and therefore not have the
confidential
confidentiality that this purported to
have
by keeping all of that information at
the provider level
thank you for the question
representative and I apologize I believe
I forgot to introduce myself I'm Erin
Hennessey I am the deputy secretary of
state and within the Secretary of
State's office is the division of Vital
Records and archives management so thank
you representative um
the way I read this bill and I I
probably need to spend a lot more time
to answer some of the more intricate
questions and get with the sponsor but
unless to the other Representatives
point the policy decision of the house
would be to track an individual multiple
times
a an individual's
confidential number would be much easier
to generate with
um keeping that patient
's name confidential it's not something
the division would even need to receive
um
with the other information that the
provider would Supply
but to provide a provider with a
confidential number we would have to
know who we were providing a
confidential information to
for the providers
number
or identifier not necessarily a number
thank you that encapsulates my confusion
well
representative
thank you Mr chair thanks for
answering my question hopefully so I
heard you mention concern over line 22
identification number for health care
providers so my question is currently
for any other procedures done here are
our health care providers linked with an
identification number for other
procedures
I would have to look into that and that
might be a question for the Department
of of Health and Human Services as well
but I would have to get back to you on
that question and so follow up follow up
um so with that question would be so if
if that is a thing that other procedures
are linked to that why wouldn't this be
that as well
thank you for the question so
um
our department deals with vital records
and not necessarily procedures
historically so I would have to find out
get with the Department of healthy human
services to find out the information for
your question
uh representative Weber I'm sorry I'll
go ahead
it's really a follow-up to the the prior
question would you be willing to provide
the committee with more uh information
about this proposed module and how it
works and what it generates and what it
keeps track of just because you would
have knowledge of the specific
parameters that this module deals with
so that we could take a look at what how
it actually works in practice thank you
thank you representative for the
question so we
um in doing a fiscal note for the bill
we we don't actually
perform any work to start something
before it's past policy wise so
um policy wise we would develop the
module based on the information that's
required for the provider to submit and
that would be on page three starting on
line 14.
Samantha so so my last follow-up is I I
was assuming that there was some kind of
module that you would purchase off the
shelf this would have to be built this
following thank you correct thank you
yeah sorry for the representative
okay
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um are you aware of the um the birth
worksheets that are completed with every
live birth in New Hampshire and they're
sent to the Department of Vital Records
yes
and are you aware that that worksheet
asks a lot about procedures and also
about birth outcomes live births and
other outcomes that could include three
possible outcomes which are spontaneous
abortion
um
you know termination or uh
ectopic pregnancy are you aware of that
that that
question is asked too
thank you for the question
representative I I am aware of the the
birth worksheet but I'm not familiar
with every single question on it but
um I if you're reading from the birth
worksheet then I would assume that
that's yes you're correct follow-up
um so knowing that would it is there I
assure you
um knowing that like would you would you
agree that this kind of does still does
kind of fall under that same sort of
data that that of Department of Vital
Records is already collecting
but it just it's not this specific but
it falls under that kind of umbrella
like it's not a random you know how many
toes are amputated in New Hampshire when
you're not collecting data on on
anything like that you know
that it is related to data that you're
already collecting currently
um
yes thank you for the question
um I I see this bill as a policy
decision for the legislature to tell us
what type of data we would be collecting
and not collecting so
another question yes representative Seth
King thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming today
I have a really basic question and that
is what is what generally does the
Department of Vital record what do they
do what does the vital records do
um and is it used strictly for
legislators to gather information to
make policy or is it for the general
historical record so our and you know
our descendants 100 years from now can
look back and see I mean what is the
point of all this and um to riff a
little bit on what representative tell
us act asked earlier and I don't think
she got really a terribly good answer is
um you know how much like do we take do
we take records of hysterectomies and
vasectomies and things like that and and
um you know just I just curious how
normal the idea of taking abortions and
putting that into Vital Records if
that's is that is that normal for all
the all the states in the union or is
this somewhat abnormal so it's a lot of
questions there sorry but the my first
one is the vital records what all do
they do and thank you
thank you representative for your simple
question
um so I think that the Department of
Health and Human Services will tell you
that the division of Vital Records is
would traditionally be in a Department
of Health and Human Services in other
states but for the mission of our
division of Vital Records in New
Hampshire it was a policy decision to
move it to within the department of
secretary the Secretary of State and the
Department of State
um and so we
um as a division and I apologize I'm not
an expert on Vital Records yet we
collect information on births deaths
marriages annulments adoptions and
process the vital records associated
with that so birth certificates death
certificates
um
marriage certificates and we have a very
close working relationship with
providers that
um process those types of documents so
Funeral Directors
um city and town clerks
um
other Physicians related to the the
death module that we that we have
I can get you a lot more information
though
and sorry what was your other simple
question
no I guess that's it I guess
other questions
yes representative Nagel
um I guess this is a simple question
um hopefully oh thank you Mr chairman
thank you
um do we offer
um certificates right now for still
births abortions miscarriages as a life
and death thing now
thank you for the question I would have
to get the details on that I know that
they're
I'll have to get you the details on the
types of death certificates that people
process for
um for your for your question so I will
get that for the committee
okay other questions
hey
I think we're all set thank you thank
you thank you Dan
representative Edward you submitted a
card was that for this bill or best for
this yes sir
you didn't put a bill number down that's
why we asked oh I'm sorry
it's hard to get good help these days Mr
chairman
so representative Jess Edwards just
Rockingham District 31. the reason I'm I
decided to say something is because I've
been kicking around in this field for
about six years and one and I've I've
been in this conversation many times and
one thing that I now know that I didn't
know that you may want to know is is
that once once the data gets into Vital
Records uh there is a vital records
privacy board that reviews uh very
detailed and very formal applications
for clinical research to be done on that
data and and so this board
goes ahead and reviews it all and
determines whether or not there's
clinical utility in the research and
whether or not that there's sufficient
privacy safeguards so that we can
protect our citizens anonymity and and I
know this now because as of one November
I was appointed by the Secretary of
State on that board and I've gone
through a few meetings I've reviewed
about 10 of these packages and we've
kicked them back if they're not if
they're not good enough we we refuse to
let the data go until we're convinced
that you know there's clinical utility
that's got good scope that there's
a safe the safeguards for privacy are
assured so the vital records privacy
board is critical to this and as as an
aside
um uh though there's going to be a bill
kicking around there there had been a a
committee that Senator Cindy Rosenwald
uh LED where we took a look and reviewed
the uh live birth worksheet and uh we
have recommended some changes to that to
segregate which data is mandatory and
subject to felony and which of it is
optional all of it had been subject to
felony charges for false information so
we we fixed that and that live birth
worksheet is for live births and and it
didn't it didn't necessarily come up in
the discussion but as I was thinking
through it listening to testimony I I
came to the conclusion of the Assumption
rather that that live birth statistic
worksheet would not be completed for an
abortion
so so right now there is none of that
data in the vital records database
there's no form to get it in there so
um that's that's what I think I know
questions for representative Edwards yes
would you believe as another person who
worked on the live birth worksheet that
the Bureau of Vital Statistics doesn't
fall under the purview of HIPAA
because we sat next to each other I I I
think I think I recall that uh but but
I'm also very confident that all of the
requirements of HIPAA from a
security perspective and from a privacy
perspective are are built into the whole
Vital Records database and the processes
around it so although it itself is not a
subject to HIPAA it is certainly subject
to intense scrutiny from a security and
privacy perspective I believe that's
fair from what we heard thank you I just
thought that was is good for the
committee to know because it certainly
came up
during our committee deliberations right
and I and I think I also heard that that
it needed to go to vital records and not
DHHS because somebody raised a
constitutional issue within the New
Hampshire Constitution I don't know if
that's true or not but but that that's
another
factoid representative that would be
good to know when we have the executive
session on this bill also thank you
thank you any other questions for
representative Edwards
okay thank you
I have copyrighted in the oven on sp91
thank you
okay next sign up to testify is Sarah
McNeil from the League of Women Voters
good afternoon
um Mr chairman and representatives
my name is Sarah McNeil and I am
speaking on behalf of myself and the
non-partisan League of Women Voters of
New Hampshire
I serve on the State Board there I'm
also a nurse I've also worked at a
clinic that has provided um women's
reproductive
um
birth control and abortions
I'm here to speak in opposition to House
Bill 582 requiring the New Hampshire
division of Vital Records to collect
statistics pertaining to induced
termination of pregnancy
just three days ago on January 22nd
we should have been celebrating the 50th
anniversary of Roe versus Wade a 7-2 U.S
Supreme Court decision protecting
women's Reproductive Rights
instead we are here once again facing
another bill that continues to chip away
at women's right to choose which she
believes is best for herself and her
family
under the statement of purpose as
written for HB 582
it states quote the general court also
finds that the collection of statistical
data regarding termination of pregnancy
is essential to the state's compelling
interest in the life and health of its
citizens including the pre-born
unquote
we asked this committee
exactly exactly how are these statistics
essential to the well-being of our
citizens
have any of the sponsors of this bill
researched other states to see how they
have utilized the data they collected
and if any of those statistics improve
the care
of women's reproductive health
the statement of purpose also includes
the word quote pre-born unquote
for those who don't know this word is
closely associated with organizations
who strongly oppose a woman's right to
choose
it should not be part of the purpose of
this bill
in addition HB 582 does not provide us
with the list of abortion statistics
that the state wishes to obtain
I wanted to reference
what was mentioned earlier on page three
of this it seemed to be a cut and paste
from the CDC data requirements
and it goes from one all the way down to
16 and then uh in that area
so these are these are things that my
understanding could be questions that
are asked
I also reviewed a number of CDC websites
over the years because as we all know by
now they have been collecting data and
other institutions have been collecting
data on this you can start wrapping up
ma'am here we have over here three
minutes well I'm sorry
[Music]
um
so including some very personal ones and
a woman on the day of the abortion would
likely be the time she would have to
answer these questions and I want to
just try for a moment to put yourself in
the place of that woman and ask
yourselves whether there is any
situation in which a man would be
required to answer such questions as are
you married have you had other abortions
were you using birth control measures
when you got pregnant how many children
do you already have what about your
financial situation and why are you
choosing an abortion today
after a health care worker has asked and
recorded the answer is that person will
now be responsible for ensuring the
confidential results are documented on
the proper form and sent to CDC or
whatever other organizations the state
chooses we all know that health care
workers in New Hampshire as else as
elsewhere are stretched to the Limit and
do not need to spend more time on this
type of paperwork okay ma'am please wrap
up okay I have one short paragraph
okay about the fiscal note of 25
000 to 50 000 and according to the
methodology paragraph because I believe
one of your representatives asked about
this it's in the methodology paragraph
that a new module have to be designed
built and tested in addition education
program from Health Care Providers would
need to be developed and then deploy to
an unknown number of providers in a
variety of Health Care settings periodic
analysis and annual reports of this data
would also be needed and needed to be
submitted once again to unknown
organizations furthermore the note does
not include as we mentioned earlier the
New Hampshire division of Vital Records
who already is keeping track of birth
marriages divorces adoptions and deaths
so in closing I go back to my original
questions about this bill
why is this bill needed and in what ways
could the findings be essential to the
well-being of our citizens I thank you
for your time and your consideration of
my comments thank you ma'am questions
representative Weber
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
have you in your own relationships with
your medical providers ever been asked
to provide your educational level before
a treatment or a procedure was done to
you
I have never had an abortion
I know that you're not asking that
directly and I know I don't have to say
that but I'm not uh but I have had other
uh procedures but I've never been asked
the questions that are on here about
personal relationships about how my
educational level about my financial
situation
that sort of thing I think these
extremely personal things that no person
should be asked to answer in addition
it the provider certainly can record
the date of birth the fact that an
abortion occurred and how many weeks
those are facts but many of these other
things how accurate is that data going
to be represented from a woman who is
very nervous to start with I just
questioned the accuracy of some of the
other data I think it might be asked uh
yes representative thank you thank you
for taking my question
um so I heard you mention and correct me
if I'm wrong that
this bill
um basically takes is a
ffecting a woman's right to choose
um but I'm wondering how collecting just
statistics of the numbers that we're
talking about not the who's the numbers
how that in itself would take away a
woman's right to choose how does that
affect that I don't have a problem with
the actual facts as I just mentioned
those very clear on the date of birth of
the person perhaps although I don't even
think that's necessary the number of
weeks along the type of procedure that
was performed but
it is it's this has just been one of
many many bills that have come up in the
last number of six eight years in New
Hampshire
some of them have really impounded upon
uh the women's right to choose it makes
it more and more difficult not
everybody's going to speak up
many of these women are you know are
very scared to start with and it's just
nibbling away chipping away at the
women's right that was 50 years ago
it's important we focus on this bill
though not the other groups follow up
please follow up yeah so I mentioned it
again that it's I hear what you're
saying but this bill we just want to
know the numbers that we're dealing with
so I know when I was canvassing for my
election this past time that one the
number one topic was this and so many
questions were asked of me about it and
I had no idea how to answer them so and
and they were throwing stats at me that
well this do you know how many people
um died during childbirth and this and
that but there was no other stats that I
could in turn so I'm I'm I get so again
it's I I hear your concern but I've got
a question yeah it's I I'm gonna go back
to because I don't think you really
answered it is how is this bill the way
it's written right now taking away a
woman's right to choose with all due
respect I go back to what is listed this
cotton paste area if I knew what the
questions were but right now it's a
whole potpourri of many many questions
many of them are personal that would
make a decision a woman would say I
don't want to put myself in that
position to have to answer all those
questions if there was a list of
specific questions in this bill I might
feel very differently about it but it's
not in here
why don't we move on then any other
questions
yes representative thank you for taking
my question
I'm sorry in your last paragraph you
enumerated a number of different
processes that need to happen for this
to actually be operationalized and so
were you suggesting that the estimate of
25 000 or whatever the number is is a
gross under count I
all I'm saying is from 25
000 to 50 000. there seems to be an
awful lot of data that awful lot of
things that need to be accomplished just
designing and implementing a new module
that's not just downloaded from the
computer that by itself is huge
educating all the providers these are
not just freestanding so-called abortion
clinics this would be every hospital
every doctor's office every Outpatient
Clinic
in the state of New Hampshire would have
to be tapped to see if the those
providers need to be educated in this
new module so it's quite far-reaching
and you know once again as it's
mentioned today what I've heard so far
is the numbers are still being um
um
they haven't been settled yet that's not
quite sure what they are
still being crunched other questions
yes representative Merchant thank you Mr
thank you for taking the question
it gets back into I think one of the
things we talked about earlier this
morning and it gets back into the
Privacy issue and I think what I
understand there's the issue of
what we want to protect and how we
protect it
and my concern is that once you start
aggregating data in any kind of a
database
do you have any concern about it being
breached and then at that point in time
once it's breached it all this I mean
there's so much personal information in
here do you concern yourself with this
I'm certainly concerned I think we all
are in today's world with credit cards
and every day we hear about somebody's
uh identity is being stolen for sure and
I do Echo what others had mentioned
about if you give a personal ID to the
provider and then another personal idea
to the patient
somebody's going to be keeping that data
and there's a turnover all the time and
you know it's going to be the data is
going to be kept at the at the
provider's offices or hospitals
there's such a turnover all the time
who's going to be the keeper of the key
so I am concerned with that confidential
data to start with I'm not really sure
why we need
the patient's name at all I can on the
other hand understand why we might want
to have a provider's name
other questions
okay I think we're all set thank you
well thank you I have uh copies of my
testimony okay I could bring them
forward and give them to the Clark
please
okay I also signed up to speak today on
this on this bill is Kurt welper from
Stratford New Hampshire
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Kurt
welper I am vice president of New
Hampshire right to life and I'm here
representing them as we represent all
the people in the state of New Hampshire
there are a lot of questions I
I've heard so many I want to answer some
questions and so that's what I'm going
to do
right we need this data why
the same reason
the same reason that department of idle
statistics
keeps track of death
because
the reason for this bill
Above All Else
is that we are not talking about a
health procedure
we are talking about a death procedure
every successful abortion
results in the death
of a living human being
a living human being with the
fundamental inalienable not separable
from their own physical being
inalienable right to life
that's why we need this data
because the best data that I've seen and
I've seen a lot in the years that I've
been working on this
there were roughly three to four
thousand abortions performed in our
state every year
everyone knows including guttmacher Who
provided that number
that isn't right
because all they get is what's
voluntarily reported to them
by abortion providers
would we allow any other
procedure to go forward in our state
that knowingly
killed three to four thousand people in
our state and maybe more
I don't think so
I think we will all know who did it
and where they were
we have a whole range of crimes and
other sections of our law
the pre-born
are treated as people with rights
so if you go to the homicide law
child killed before it gets born
it's treated just like a human being
just like everybody else
why aren't these particular class of
human beings
treated differently
that's why we need this bill it's in the
absolute right place the Department of
Vital Statistics because it's tracking
deaths
those just may not have names
but they're still people
and a lot of them do have names
the question of privacy has been
addressed in this bill several times in
the past couple years in the past five
years I know
and it's been beaten to death
as you've heard earlier testimony you
have to have some way
of tracking
where and these things occur
and who's doing them
you just have to because whatever you
get useless thank you Mr Wilber yes
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative welper
um the the ethical question aside of
some people say that it's not a life at
a certain point and some people say that
it is and there's that debate but
putting that aside would you agree that
knowing where the rates of abortion are
in our state can be an indicator of the
health of our population
and seeing how they're trending with
changes in the economy and you know as
we see demographic changes don't you
think that that would be a valuable
piece of data for us to have just to
understand how abortion numbers respond
to changes in the state
yes I'm going to just say yes because I
don't want to go longer
take your time
um yes representative thank you Mr
chairman
um so according
to your position
um an abortion is a death and therefore
it should be recorded
but is it not also true that all
miscarriages are also by your definition
of death and should they all be recorded
as well thank you no
yes and no so yes a miscarriage is also
a death
what it is not is intentional
and so it would not fall under the
criminal code word anybody else
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you representative for
being so forthcoming and direct and
honest
um an earlier representative who
testified said acknowledged that there
was no need to have these statistics for
clinical purposes
um
you know clinical medical purposes but
that they but having these statistics
would inform policy decisions that
Representatives have to make
so if you
had these statistics available to you it
seems sounds like you have some
estimates of what's going on already but
if you had more specific statistics
available to you
how would it inform your policy ideas
well let's just suppose for the sake of
argument that all of these things
occurred at one place
I think that it would be perfectly
because it would be it would be
desirable
for us
to enact House Bill 615 which is coming
up later
and to say no we're not going to provide
any money
to anybody that kills all those all
those people
that would just be one way
also representative
no I just I follow up okay follow up
it's really not a question I just want
to thank you for being so directed we
really should be confining our efforts
to questions not not debate
okay okay thank you
representative Merchant did you have a
question
okay maybe anyone else
any any other questions
okay thank you
okay next signed up is Patricia Tilley
Tory
wow okay
with Charlie
thank you so much thank you and again
for the record my name is Patricia
Tilley I am the director of the division
of Public Health Services at the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services and with me I have ciaoi Chala
who was our bureau chief of our Public
Health Bureau of informatics and health
statistics so thank you very much you've
heard a lot of testimony today on this
bill we are here to provide some
additional information and answer answer
any questions that you may have from the
public health side of this question
primarily we want to let you know right
away there is a fiscal note if you look
electronically it was submitted it is
live online right now so you can see the
DHHS fiscal note right there I'm sure
representative Stapleton did not have
the opportunity to see that yet but it
is currently there for those who haven't
had it take a look had a chance to take
a look at that we can just tell you that
we have suggested that it would cost
somewhere in the area of about 140
000 in order to do the requirements that
this bill is asking the Department of
Health and Human Services to do and that
is around developing reporting
structures and all not only the
epidemiology of those reporting
structures but also the data
visualization on our whiz wisdom
dashboard which is now called the New
Hampshire DHHS data portal it is always
going to be wisdom in some of our hearts
but it is now called the New Hampshire
DHHS data portal additionally we would
like to note that there are some
technical parts of this bill and that is
included in our testimony around the
citations around which laws need to be
adjusted that I think the sponsor may be
interested in as we move forward we are
happy to answer questions around the
public health side of this data we have
some concerns
considerable concerns around the Privacy
component simply the mechanisms of that
I think you all discussed this earlier
with the deputy from the Secretary of
State's office in particular around the
medical provider confidentiality number
we appreciate the need to protect
privacy but from a technical point of
view I think that probably needs to be
fleshed out a little bit more on how
that would be
done within the division of Vital
Records services so again not the
Department of Health and Human Services
that directs the division of Vital
Records to do that work we just wanted
to acknowledge that that seems to be
tricky is is the technical word that I
would do use for that of how you would
create those confidential numbers give
them to Providers and do the monthly
reporting that is asked of any provider
who may provide this service whether or
not a procedure was given so I'm going
to hand it over to Ms chawa and she will
fill in what I've left out it just
follow the record my name is Jaco chawla
I'm the bureau chief of Public Health
statistic informatics in the division of
Public Health Services just to emphasize
what Trisha has addressed So currently
there is no appropriation to support a
data collection review validation
preparation and also reporting in the
public health services sorry in the
physical note we did I suggest you have
a one full-time positions as well as a
10 full-time epic positions to perform
this work and secondly the department
acts as a vital record data through a
memorandum of understanding established
with division of Vital Records
Administration in accordance with the
RSA 12624 CC and this does not and the
department does not have the ownership
of Vital Records data and if this bill
will move forward this will require both
RSA 126 as well as RSA 5c to be amended
in order to provide the authority to
collect the data for on this matter
and also uh currently participating in
the CDC abortion surveillance system
reporting is voluntary so um and we
contact the CDC and the reporting data
elements will include the races
necessity week of a gas station
age in single year method of termination
residents of states and other
informations as well and also in
contacting with CDC we realized that the
CDC has contacted the division of Vital
Records to encourage them to report the
data to the CDC abortion surveillance
system
and we do have the uh the email that
reply back from CDC on this matter as
well
so so that that's what we have for today
and we are happy to take any question
from the committee members
none yeah oh representative benagel
I think you may have already answered oh
thank you for taking that question
um you may have already answered my
question but according to the pretext of
this bill it says that we are one of
only three states that don't report
um is there any knowledge of the data
because there's a question about all the
the questions that are being asked here
do we have any knowledge of of are all
these questions being asked in every
state or is this a unique document here
I'll take a swing at that thank you so
much for your for your questions so we
believe that many states are are
providing much of that data there may be
data elements that they don't provide of
those 47 states that provide abortion
data again to CDC of course that is
de-identified there is no identifiable
data going to CDC it should be noted and
we've and several of the speakers prior
to us have noted that there is voluntary
collection of this data already that
does not happen through the Department
of Health and Human Services there's an
entity called The goodmacher Institute
we've heard that reference today and
they voluntarily collect abortion data
not to this level
um my understanding is the latest 2017
numbers there were 2 200 abortions in
the state of New Hampshire in 2017 and
that represents about a 12 percent
decline between 2014 and 2017. I don't
have more up-to-date data than that
okay other questions
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you
thank you next signed up to testify
today is Jason Hennessey
thank you honorable members of house
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs my name is Jason Hennessey I'm
here today speaking
um more to the Privacy aspects so I did
my PhD in computational sciences and
statistics and I've been a researcher
for over a decade I've published on
computer security and privacy topics in
top venues I've also been the manager of
a large informatics database containing
lots and lots of Private health
information that was part of a federal
study and we had to meet Federal
requirements so I wanted to talk a
little bit about that in the interest of
full disclosure I'm also the president
of New Hampshire right to life but I
don't think you have to be pro-life to
be in favor of this there's there are 47
other states that that do this including
States like New York and Massachusetts
which would not be considered uh you
know pro-life extremist States so I
don't I guess I you don't you don't
really need to be pro-life so I don't
think that that's necessarily relevant
if you are concerned about privacy I
think you'll be much more concerned
about the nhchis which is the
comprehensive Healthcare information
system
in that database there's a my
understanding is that that database has
all of the insurance transactions and
has identifiable uh or has identifiers
in it that would let you track across
visits and across the entire database
across health insurance providers they
have an encrypted social security number
in there and if you're worried about
privacy you should really start there
and this in this Database The Proposal
that you have before you the the
identifier is a one-off pre provided by
the provider so my understanding from
reading the bill is that you wouldn't
even be able to identify somebody who
went across providers so it would be it
would be limited to just one
um
so
in terms of I've heard some questions
here about the research value
I I think there's a lot of things so I
guess the the number one thing that
comes to mind would be the CDC uh they
they publish data regularly using this
database uh you know you might be you
might be concerned are abortions safe
are there certain people are there
people at certain ages or certain
gestation levels or
um or in certain locations that are
having more complications you know this
is if the CDC is interested in this I
guess the question is uh why else would
you wonder about that
um you know there is a vital research
interest here and
um I would also point out that you know
for instance we had there was a question
about do we need this and uh in 2020 the
the legislature passed a bill requiring
health insurance New Hampshire health
insurance to cover abortion so I would
say for you legislators knowing how many
abortions there are that's a that's a
pretty important question
and with that I thank you Mr chairman
and honorable members of the committee
would love to take any questions okay
any questions
see none okay well thank you sir thank
you Mr chairman
and the last card I have for today on
this bill
is um Frank knock from the ACLU of New
Hampshire
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and I apologize in advance if
anything I say has already been repeated
I was unfortunately in another hearing
on another bill and just walked in
um you know I'd like to just start by
saying you know I think the one thing we
can agree you know regardless of your
political affiliation or your ideology
as Granite Staters is that we care about
our privacy we have some of the most
robust privacy Protections in our
constitution of any state
um in this legislation poses a grave
threat to the Privacy
um of of lots of granite Staters
under this a proposal
we've heard a lot about you know what
other states are doing under this
proposal there would be individualized
data that would then be at the state
level aggregate but at the initial
creation of the data individualized and
even just looking at what's happened
with the New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services and data
breaches back in 2016 there was a data
breach that affected up to 15 000 people
and so the notion that you know we are
creating these individualized um data
and that it's not at risk of getting out
it's just not how it works in modern
society with technology and with the
ability to hack and with data breaches
Etc and I think what makes that worse is
that there's really no need for this
legislation the Department of Vital
Records Administration collects data
about you know birth certificates
marriage civil unions divorce and death
certificates
abortion is a medical procedure they do
the department uh the Department of
Vital Records collects no other
information about any other medical
procedure so why are we singling out
abortion care a medical procedure for
collection by this agency it makes no
sense
and I'd also like to point out
um you know there are some questions
about you know 47 states do this well I
think you know the details matter and I
think message someone stated that
Massachusetts does this and
Massachusetts does this why can't we
so I think it's important to look at
what mass and what Vermont two of our
neighboring states actually require so
this is Massachusetts law right here
just this little paragraph it's
aggregate only there is no
individualized data collected at all
none of the numerous factors that this
bill collects and Vermont again Vermont
does not require any data collection
about the patient this is Vermont's law
there is no data collection about the
patient and so this notion that 47
states do this already is just not
backed up by the facts our neighbors in
Vermont and Massachusetts do not do it
this way I think as Granite status we
care about our privacy and the fact that
even Vermont Massachusetts aren't doing
this should send real signals to this
committee that this is not fit for the
granite state and happy to answer any
questions
uh questions
uh yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm not an attorney
but I want to point something out that I
read this morning on another bill and I
wanted you to help me understand how
this may impact that
according to what it says here New
Hampshire vote has passed the right to
privacy into the state constitution to
November 2018 with an 81 approval with
that vote state government culture and
behavior needed to shape be shaped by
the words an individuals right
individuals right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private
private personal information is natural
essential inherent in your opinion is
this going to conflict with our
constitution our ability as a citizen of
our state to keep the government out of
our data so we have not done a specific
analysis on this versus the
Constitutional protections but I'd be
happy to do that and get a memo back to
the committee
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you explain to me why the
ACLU objects to collecting this data
specifically and
um doesn't object to
the Department of Vital Statistics
asking if there were perennial
lacerations if there was an unplanned
hysterectomy
what was the last outcome of the
previous pregnancy there are very very
deep questions on the birth worksheet
and the Department of Vital Statistics
is our Vital Records and statistics is
already collecting that so can you speak
to that a little bit what's the
difference between a live birth a mother
of a live birth needing to divulge that
information herself and there be and
that being okay and it being not okay
for a physician to send a monthly report
of similar information yeah I appreciate
the question so um I I'm not sure the
specifics of the the scenario just
raised so I don't know what our position
was in the past on that issue I'd be
happy to look into that but in this case
you know this is a medical procedure and
the fact that the vital statistics folks
are not collecting data on any other
medical procedure especially one that is
like abortion that is you know
universally recognized as safe
is is troubling and in the fact that
um you know this the way that they would
collect this data unlike our neighbors
in Massachusetts unlike our neighbors in
Vermont puts people's individual privacy
and personal medical decisions at risk
unnecessarily we think is deeply
problematic
yes representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman
um would you be able to supply the
committee with the references to the
laws in Massachusetts and Vermont and
exactly what they
um do submit to the CDC uh absolutely I
can email those to the committee thank
you very much
representative Weber
okay
any other questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you all so much
I have no other pink cards here I know
of no one else here to testify on this
bill is there anyone else here to
testify
okay if that's the case then I am
closing the public hearing on House Bill
582 and what appears to be our last bill
of the day at least according to my
records is House Bill 615 I am going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
615 at this time and
recognize and invite back for sub for
the I don't know how many times today
representative Edwards
it was the Prime sponsor of this film
I think representative Edward you missed
being in the finance room that's why you
keep coming to see us today
actually I'm not allowed to leave this
room uh but uh okay so I'm
representative Jess Edwards Rockingham
District 31. I hail from Auburn
representing Auburn Candia Chester and
Deerfield I'm here today as the prime
sponsor of of HB
615 to introduce the bill I I think for
context uh it's kind of important for
folks who who don't know me
and are listening to what I'm about to
say to understand that I grew up in an
era of Roe v Wade and that despite Dobbs
that decision my mental framework is
still pretty much that the right to an
abortion is a constitutionally protected
medical procedure and so um so I'm not
here to attack a boy portion or access
to abortion I'm here as the chairman of
division three who went through the
budget process last year and saw how
little money the state had to put into
Family Planning Family Planning we fund
planning Family Planning that we had so
little money it's like eight hundred
thousand dollars a year that I just
wanted to protect our family planning
resources and as it turns out
a few of the vendors that go compete for
our family planning dollars
are among them
our abortion providers they prefer the
term reproductive Health Care Facilities
but if you go look at what the
definition of that is again this is for
the new people that's that's
intentionally obfuscated language
because the definition in the in the
statute is essentially an outpatient
abortion clinic and so so if we're going
to have a real discussion we just need
to know the difference between an
outpatient abortion clinic and a family
planning Clinic I think I think they are
materially different the Family Planning
Clinic I think has the mission of of
helping couples have a family and to
have a family when they choose to have a
family and so things like birth control
to include iuds and Lark which is uh I
forget the acronym but it's a long-term
um
anti-fertility I'm messing up my word
there but it's birth control
providing cancer screenings providing
STD testing and treatment providing
preventive care to so that the mom now
or in the future can remain healthy
those are all great Family Planning
clinical objectives completely support
them I want the eight hundred thousand
dollars we spent on it a year to to go
for those purposes and so what this is
uh is meant to do is to ensure that
there's a
firewall between Family Planning and
abortion services and by firewall
I have used the phrase
financial and physical separation
in hb2 last year the the term got
reduced to just Financial separation and
so I've had a couple years to walk
around that a bit and you know it didn't
I did I didn't like that we we struck it
and made it just Financial separation I
wanted physical separation as well but
it's something I can live with there
were concerns that we were being trying
to take away a woman's right to choose
an abortion I I don't think we did that
we you know if they're getting
counseling on their options they can
certainly be referred out or or have
somebody tell them to go where they
could go for an abortion uh so we're not
trying to stop that and as a matter of
fact the bill specifically says that the
state shall pay our minimum share to
participate in Medicaid so that minimum
share is to abortion providers
what we're really looking to have done
is to have an independent audit what we
had heard for years years and years
probably you know since I first paid
attention to this issue in the 70s is
that there's no commingling of money
between abortion providers and Family
Planning money we heard that we heard it
we heard it so in hb2 last year we said
okay you know kind of like a Missouri
person I'm not a Missourian but you know
show me so so we we in hb2 for the first
time ask that
DHHS conduct an inspection of the
financial records and to provide a
certification that's what hp2 did when
this certification
which I I think Planned Parenthood has
in their testimony from the Department
got to the executive Council
my executive counselor didn't think it
was adequate or sufficient and and I I
don't know what the exit how the
executive Council thinks But but so they
they essentially stopped
um
some of the contracts
that would have gone through Planned
Parenthood
to create Family Planning services and
so that executive counselor asked me to
support uh
submit this bill on her behalf so that
what we are now wanting to do is to have
an independent audit
and I think you'll you can read the
phrase online
13 and 14 of the first page of the
legislation we're asking for
an external independent audit by a CPA
and provide the results along with any
corrective action plan to the
commissioner of DHHS so that's an
independent audit now is that a
requirement for Planned Parenthood no
it's not it's a requirement no it's not
it's a requirement for every family
planning project that's on line 13.
so the obligation to get the audit is
associated with the decision
to compete for our family planning
contracts it's not targeted at any one
organization it's targeted to protect
our family planning money it may
certainly have a large impact on a
particular vendor of Family Planning
services but but it isn't it isn't
necessarily targeted
um there's I think a slip up in in the
language of the bill uh online nine
where it refers to a geographic
connection it says if a planning plot
plant Family Planning project has any
Financial or Geographic connection to an
abortion clinic that provides abortion
Services the state contract shall
specify the following well I don't know
where the phrase Geographic connection
came in that's that wasn't part of any
dialogue any testimony and it's a
drafting error that I'm accountable for
so so I'll just I'll just do a Mia culpa
on that
um I um
I
I want that to be stricken and just made
a a financial connection
to a reproductive Health Clinic
um because I think that's easier to
determine it's an easier test to
determine whether or not an audit is
required
uh co-location may still be appropriate
as well though because co-location
implies to sharing of facility sharing
of overhead sharing a Personnel just to
give you one example of the sharing of
personnel
there's a
executive director who who runs Planned
Parenthood of Northern New England the
medical director Dr Donna Burkett and I
I'm told she makes 286
000 and change a year in that when in
2019 she lobbied the Vermont legislature
to add abortion to the Vermont
Constitution the New Hampshire Family
Planning program was paying 20 percent
of her salary
so so that's the kind of thing that
stick your finger in somebody's eye that
that really has caused this show me
attitude to request a financial audit be
conducted
uh I'm I'm about to wrap up Mr chair I'm
just looking at my notes to make sure
um
okay so so the audit that we're
requesting the executive Council said
that they they would like the results of
it along with any corrective action plan
a week prior to considering any contract
to a family planning vendor with a uh
what I will say is with a um
a financial or physical co-location with
the family planning services and and the
reproductive Health Center so so I owe
you I think an amendment a tiny
amendment to fix that that line because
the geographic connection I think I
agree completely with uh planned
parenthood's upcoming testimony that
that's overly Broad and complicating and
just is dumb I don't know why I didn't
catch it so
um anything else
I I also want to point out I think that
in 2021
[Music]
Planned Parenthood of New Northern New
England was spending 2.3 million dollars
a year on lobbying and after hb2 came
out that increased 400 000 to 2.7
million so they had 400 000 extra to
throw into their lobbying efforts and in
a independent expenditure report
submitted to on behalf Planned
Parenthood New England action fund I'd
want to point out that they
contributed nearly 193 thousand dollars
to political campaigns none of which
went to help my campaign for what it's
worth so uh okay I am not expecting any
in the future right now but I would not
imagine representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and let me just say
nor my campaign
um
could you help me out with my chicken
and egg problem here
you can't get any state funds unless you
have an audit to show that you're not
spending the state funds that you
haven't received yet inappropriately
so I'm not sure I understand how you do
the audit because you haven't got the
state funds yet because you can't get
the state funds until you have the audit
which presumably isn't auditing the
state funds you haven't gotten
great question thank you uh I'm glad you
didn't ask while I was hungry
um but uh for the the the chicken and
egg on this is that remember these are
Family Planning uh contracts and that we
do have uh Family Planning vendors that
that's all they do so those contracts
have gone out to established Family
Planning providers
the the hang up has been on on the the
ones that are affiliated with abortion
Services they've they've had difficulty
convincing the executive Council that
they've done the due diligence to to
ensure Financial separation and and the
determination of that is the executive
Council it's not mine
um but uh so there isn't an expectation
that anyone who isn't currently in
business is going to apply for one of
these contracts so there will be ongoing
business operations for whoever bids on
these contracts and so it's it's an
audit of their ongoing Financial
concerns
does that help
the egg has been laid
okay well can I have One phone
but my understanding was that the
funding was denied so it doesn't exist
anymore so how do you start over again I
mean how do you audit it when you've
already ended that particular
contract and haven't started it up again
and can't start it up because you can't
have an audit so okay so that's a great
question and I'd I'd be happy to work
with you on some some
tailoring language around this I I can
tell you when hb2 language got inserted
I was I was as much bystander and and
witness as I was author
and what it always meant to me was that
we could request that audit you know
during the term of the contract
and and and and and my interpretation
that it was something that could be
triggered during the term of the
contract got morphed by the executive
Council to be interpreted as a condition
to have a contract let which is a
totally different thing and and so so if
if this was a question of
um uh should we
require the audit after a year of
operation or something like that so
there's something to audit uh I I would
be in agreement with that either that
would make sense
um
and as I said you know the executive
council is our own entity and they
interpreted the law Beyond differently
than I think I would have but
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman um
I'm curious about the term external
independent audit by a certified public
accountant who decides
which certified public accountant who
who approves of that who who decides
because we've seen that the
DHHS was doing these audits but by some
people's standards that wasn't good
enough so how do we make it so that this
audit will be acceptable who gets to
decide who that auditor is so if you
pass this law word for word I think I
think to get the ball through the goal
posts all it would need to do is to meet
the words in the statute it it we
wouldn't be telling them a determinative
way and to select the external CPA to do
an independent audit we would just
receive an audit
and we would verify that it met the
conditions and and and and if you would
feel more comfortable adding some
language in order to uh pick this who
selects I you know I I don't have a
problem with that I I actually think
it's a little bit more flexible uh and
perhaps more acceptable I mean to the
extent that there anyone wants to accept
this if if if we leave it a little
flexible there but I leave it to the
committee so the so the way it's written
now your understanding is that the
agency who's being audited would would
find an auditor and I assume would pay
for it as well
uh we don't talk about pay uh who pays
for it but I think that's rational that
they would end up paying for it and then
they would select it and and there would
be you know some some concern on their
part that the executive Council would
view it as independent
you know external and
um
the other term
thank you it's getting late I don't know
how you guys are doing it
the other questions
representative Weber
so if we're talking I think I heard the
figure about eight hundred thousand
dollars in in funding going out
isn't it possible that people could
expend more than that in turn just in
preparing the audits
I don't think so uh I I think anything's
possible I I would never you know
undermine the ability of any
organization to be incompetent and
wasteful you know so yeah but I I I I
don't think that should is the norm
normal Norm
other other question you know keep in
mind if if I may because I think this is
relevant those Family Planning clinics
that show up with no connection to an
abortion Center uh financially or or a
physical co-location
their audit would be so simple I mean it
would be you know minimal minimal to the
extent that they got documentation
other questions
yes representative King thank you Mr
chairman it is my strong opinion that
all funds are fungible
and if the goal here is to stop funding
um healthcare providers that also
provide abortions why not just get rid
of the whole auditing scheme and just
say period if you if you have if you
fund abortions you don't get any money
period and the the whole auditing part
of this bill just seems to add like a
wrench in the gears
um and I'm just it just seems like if
the goal is really to just take the
abortion money away or a money for
abortion I'm not just get rid of the
whole auditing thing altogether
well I I tell you there's a political
calculation in the grand scheme of this
but I think from my own sort of feeling
of principles the way I would answer
that is I would not prejudge any vendor
uh I I would just say if you want to
compete for these funds here are the
rules of our of the road here if you
want to comply to make sure that we know
that what you've been telling us for
years is that there's no commingling I'm
happy with that that's the issue we we
don't want that co-mingling so
um so I'm I I don't want to eliminate
the possibility of competition and
contribution I just want to make sure
that we're clear that we want Family
Planning money dedicated to Family
Planning services
other questions
okay I see none thank you representative
Edwards okay thank you
also signed up to testify today are
Patricia Tilley and Meredith Toulouse
from Health and Human Services I believe
uh you've asked for five minutes if you
can keep it to three I'd really
appreciate it that's that's what we've
been trying to do all day and it's
especially given the hour
so
uh good afternoon again for the record
Patricia Tilley director of the division
of Public Health Services
Meredith Talus director of our division
of program quality and integrity so
thank you chairman for this opportunity
we were we can go through a couple of
the questions or that we've heard from
representative Edward's testimony I want
to start off by echoing his note that
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services
provides load and no cost sexual and
reproductive health care services and
information to All Families in Need and
these Services include birth control
information and supplies annual exams
physical exams pregnancy testing
referrals to prenatal care testing and
treatment for sexually transmitted
infections and HIV breast and cervical
cancer screening basic infertility
Services as well as help in planning for
pregnancies the funding that we use in
the Department of Health and Human
Services is something called title 10
funding it is federal funding that is
the the bolus of the funds that
representative Edwards was was referring
to in both state both in federal statute
as well as in state policy none of those
funds can be used for abortion services
that has been the case for the more than
um over 50 years of title 10 it's
roughly the same age as me
um in a course so we just wanted to make
sure that everybody had that lay of The
Land Before We Begin currently the
department has contracts with four
Health Centers to provide these Family
Planning Services those are msk Health
Belknap Merrimack Community Action
Program kowas County family health
services and Lamprey Health Care the
department currently does not have any
contracts with reproductive Health
Facilities as defined in RSA 13237 again
that definition was developed by policy
makers to describe entities that provide
abortion Services I think representative
Edwards did a nice job representing the
issues that we've had in getting
contracts passed through our executive
Council but I do want to make it clear
that we currently have four vendors that
are doing incredible work in our
community providing low income
individuals with access to birth control
birth control and other services
what we would like to note in this bill
is that hb615 introduces some
unidentified terms so I think we've
already heard that again from
representative Edwards testimony we have
one term in there called Family Planning
projects it's unclear in reading this
who that refers to does that refer to
anyone that provides Family Planning
services in the state does that require
refer to those that we have a
contractual relationship which is what I
think I heard representative Edwards
clarify so that's helpful we just needed
to understand before we could understand
the scope of this bill is who are these
Family Planning contracts projects I
think the other
undefined terms we also just heard about
were both the financial and Geographic
connection to a reproductive Health Care
Facility again representative Edwards
did a nice job to talk about the um what
could be misunderstood with the
geographic connection I mean one when I
first read that I thought is that a
provider in the same town as someone
who's in a reproductive Health has a
reproductive Health Care Facility and I
we understood that clearly probably was
not the response or the answer so I
think getting some clarity around that
within the context of this build would
be remarkably helpful and again
narrowing it down to financial
um connections you know as noted
um Meredith Toulouse and she can talk
more about this we as the department
went through and did Financial reviews
of all of our vendors at the time who
were up for a contract who had bid for a
contract that includes both reproductive
Health Care Facilities those entities
that provide family planning services
and abortion as well as our other
community health centers that just apply
Family Planning Services the result of
that review was that there was no mixing
of funds that the funds were used
appropriately by state and federal
statute that was identified mostly by
using times studies and other ways to
make sure that if that dollar the state
is pay is provided goes to this service
we could follow that to the best of our
ability and I'll just
um uh finalize right now before I hand
it over to Meredith that we are
concerned about additional barriers and
costly expense to our very fragile
system of reproductive Health Care in
the state this is fundamental Primary
Care for Women as well as men to be able
to have access to all of those screening
services and contraception our health
centers that we work with are really
walking a fine line right now and we are
concerned that by adding additional
barriers and additional costs to their
work we will no longer have a safety net
of providers for low-income individuals
so I'll ask Meredith if she is thank you
and again you're over the three minutes
already but I'll give you some time
director chose appreciate that uh Mr
chair so you can do it a minute in a
minute and a half I'd really appreciate
it I will talk fast I only have a couple
points to make
um one just to
um uh follow up on representative Weber
Weber's question and and representative
Edwards sponsor sponsor Edward's
response
um there is a bit of a chicken egg and
we faced that actually this year when we
went to look at the language of House
Bill 2 and consider bringing new
contracts forward at the end of fiscal
year uh 2022 we realized that we did not
have any reviews to do because none of
the reproductive health facilities
had been awarded a contract previously
so that may be a a language barrier that
needs to be resolved in the bill to meet
the intent the other point that I would
make is that it it does appear that the
requirement here is for an independent
audit which we assumed in our fiscal
note would be would be done by a um by
the hired by the facility or the
contractor not by the department and
then completed by a third party but the
language of the bill still mirrors some
of what was in-house Bill 2 which
required certification by the department
but if if a audit is being done by an
independent auditor and it's being
completed and it's being presented by
the by the to the vendor and to governor
and Council there's no longer really a
role for the Department to play at that
point because I wouldn't really certify
another entity's work or the audit that
they had completed
I bet I finished in a minute thank you I
wasn't actually timing you but it sounds
tight
any questions for these ladies yes I
representative Weber
so let me ask you a question that I
asked before uh do you have any idea
because you're more professionally
involved in this kind of work
what such an audit such an independent
audit might cost and whether or not you
can tell me how much it costs isn't that
cost going to come out of the monies
that we really would rather have spent
on actually providing services to a
vulnerable population
it it could cost any amount
um depending upon what vendor is found
to complete the work but if we're
talking about certified public
accountants they make more than uh what
many of my staff at the department make
and I can tell you that it probably cost
us
um maybe around eight to ten thousand
dollars per vendor as we were doing our
own reviews
this work I would estimate is going to
be more costly one because again we're
probably talking about
um
um people who are who are making more
and there's more overhead because
they're working for a private firm and
two it's it's an it's an audit whereas
we were asked to certify in a targeted
way that none of the money provided for
our contracts was used to subsidize
abortion either directly or indirectly
so we might have been more narrowly
scoped and and I'll just suggest that I
believe that there are some speakers
after us from our health centers who
probably can answer that question
other questions yes representative King
so I think the whole purpose of this
audit is basically an accountability
is what would be a cheaper or a another
solution that you would offer
I'm not sure if that when you say
accountability accountability for the
vendors to show how the money is being
spent that's correct
I think that perhaps that the lowest
cost option was the one pursued the
first time which was for the Department
to do the review which we did and we
provided the reviews
in October of 2021 and at the time those
found that
the money provided through our contracts
did not fully compensate the vendors for
the Family Planning work and if we
weren't fully compensating for the work
within our own contracts there's no way
we could be funding any other services
provided by those vendors and and I will
just add to that that even prior to
those Financial reviews it has always
been the policy both federal and state
policy to have strict contract
monitoring of all of the providers for
again more than 50 years
okay other questions
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you
also signed up to testify today is Susan
Pascal from Dubai state Primary Care
Association thank
you drive than I do okay thank you sure
um and I hope I don't mispronounced the
name I apologize if I do Sandra de
non-core
the one lovering Health Center is that
one of the centers you want me to
recognize okay
good afternoon
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today both in writing and to provide
oral testimony in opposition to House
Bill 615 requiring the independent
audits of reproductive Health Care
Facilities
I'm Sandra did Encore I'm the executive
director of the Joan G Love Ring Health
Center in Greenland
the lovering health center is an
independent non-profit Health Center
serving New Hampshire citizens for over
42 years we are historically proud
partners with the Department of Health
and Human Services for the provision of
Family Planning Services Under the title
10 Family Planning contracts
we are one of the reproductive
Healthcare facilities or independent
abortion clinics which we do not shy
away from saying directly impacted by
house bill 615.
as Written House Bill 615 is
non-specific and allows for significant
subjectivity in its interpretation of
vital language it's unclear who Bears
responsibility for the cost of the
required independent audits although
some of that may have been clarified in
testimony before me and for reasons
discussed in my written testimony audits
described in the house bill 615 are
impractical unnecessary and still left
to subjective interpretation and
inconsistent application of remedies
it's unclear what may be considered as a
satisfactory audit or what constitutes
indirectly subsidizing abortion care
physical or geographical segregation of
Family Planning services from abortion
care is not required under current law
including 2021's House Bill 2 and it is
not how health care is provided in the
state of New Hampshire
House Bill 615 inappropriately
introduces the opportunity to enforce a
physical separation of services
discussions at the executive Council
that led to the denial of Family
Planning contracts to the lovering in
2021 and 2022 can be interpreted as
requiring nothing short of physical
separation of services it is not an
overstatement to say that as written for
any reproductive Health Clinic who
attempted to re-enter the program House
Bill 615 is likely to be used to enforce
that requirement or make participation
impossible
I ask you to consider the segregation of
services which is the action or state of
setting someone or something apart from
others that cannot be realistically
accomplished without impacting the
lowest income and vulnerable citizens in
our state
segregation of services always
segregates people
adding barriers to receiving
comprehensive care exacerbating
long-standing inequities in health care
and further disenfranchising the very
citizens the program is designed to
serve legal abortion is part of the
reproductive Health Care Continuum in
New Hampshire it can be and is legally
and responsibly provided alongside title
10 Family Planning contracts under
current law there is a vast difference
between ensuring responsible fiscal
separation of publicly funded services
from abortion services and the desire to
permanently or temporarily deny public
funds to abortion providers
if the intent of House Bill 615 is the
latter to deny public funds to abortion
providers House Bill 615 remains an
irresponsibly subjected piece of
legislation to achieve that goal and it
risks access to vital services for your
constituents across our state thank you
thank you
questions
nice oh I'm representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um access seems to be a huge issue here
especially in the vulnerable
um it sounds like you're not getting a
contract created a big hole who's filled
that hole
at a program level nobody has filled
that hole so my understanding is that
the current contracts in the Family
Planning program at the state level were
previous contractors and there has not
been a significant addition of new
contractors
to the program
you're welcome
any other questions
okay I see none thank you thank you
thank you and I'm assuming
um Ms Pascal that the other person you
wanted to speak was Greg White yes
Lamprey Healthcare
[Music]
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee I thank you for your
time my name is Gregory white I'm the
Chief Executive Officer of Lamprey
Healthcare we are a federally qualified
Health Center with sites in Nashua New
Market and Raymond as well as a mobile
health unit and a number of integrated
care sites we are a primary care
provider and we are also a family
planning contractor others have
mentioned earlier in their testimony the
services that we provide so I won't
repeat them I would just like to point
out I think that we're caught up in some
of the language issues that others have
mentioned earlier in the face of this I
just want to point out that as an fqhc
we are subject to What's called the Hyde
Amendment that the federal level and are
precluded from providing abortion
Services we do not
we have repeatedly been required to
attest to this fact to the state we have
participated in the state fiscal reviews
as a recipient of state and federal
grants and contracts we are subject to
annual Financial audit we are subject to
annual audit in accordance with
governing government auditing standards
we have two separate program Audits and
we have site visits to review our
compliance from the State Department of
Public Health or excuse in the
Department of Health and Human Services
we spend in excess of fifty thousand
dollars every year on our Audits
and that pales in comparison the amount
of staff time it takes to prepare for
and participate in these processes
we have had a quote from our auditing
firm and independent firm that such an
auditing requirement such as we're
discussing here might cost us another
two to ten thousand dollars
my concerns here mainly are this is
redundant it's not necessary and um
crushing administrative burden on some
very scant resources so I'll keep my
remarks brief out of respect for your
time
thank you any questions
oh yes representative King thank you Mr
chair
you don't perform abortions at your
facility and yet you're still having to
do some sort of audits to attest to the
fact that money is received from the
states don't go towards abortion is that
correct the process that was uh
delineated earlier today uh earlier
earlier testimony excuse me we were part
of that we are one of the state
contractors so yes that we were part of
that
so we attest to that each year
and it still costs all that money just
to just to show that you guys don't
spend any money on abortions that would
cost us more money according to what was
being proposed here today we already
have an audit so it feels as if this is
redundant okay thank you
other questions
I represent the other representative
King
getting sandwiched
um
I'm going to ask you the same question I
asked the last group and that is if if
you don't audit how do we know that the
state money is being used wisely
so we are audited and we attest that it
is being used responsibly I can attest
to you every year we do not provide
those services in question were we to do
so we would lose our federal designation
which would effectively put us out of
business
follow-up
I think what's at stake here is taking
the audit out of the the solution
so if there is no audit how do we
maintain the accountability
I would be happy to attest to the fact
that we are not delivering those
Services sir
okay thank you thank you representative
Weber
and just to be abundantly clear
the proposed audit here is an audit on
top of the audit that you're already
being audited by is that correct there
all is already an audit every year there
is a financial audit every year I am
unclear as to what the process would
involve for the audit that's being
proposed but yes it would be in addition
to
other questions
okay I think we're all set thank you
thank you for your time
and uh now uh I think Ms Pascal
are you ready is this a good sign
thank you
thank you I'm here for Christine
Stoddard from Bi-State Primary Care
thank you sir okay um who represents all
the health centers and I I will be very
brief because our points are to do with
cost and access to care which I think
Patricia Kelly Tilly and Meredith
Toulouse and our health centers have
covered adequately so I will hand out
Christine's testimony and I hope you
have no questions for me I hope they
were all answered by our health centers
all right do you want to Define any
questions then in the event of irony or
are there any questions I guess that's
the quest
I think we're all set okay thank you
while she's doing that
um next signed up to testify is uh Kurt
welper
from New Hampshire right to life
right no
thank you
you have a bunch of microphones thank
you Mr chairman there you go
for the record once again my name is
Kurt welper I am vice president of New
Hampshire right to life and I'm here in
support of house bill 615.
uh
as you already know from my previous
testimony
we consider
um
abortion to be a violation of
fundamental human rights and as such we
believe that
to use taxpayer dollars to support that
in any way
is a violation of the rights of
conscience of every taxpayer who
believes the way we do
and
we're aware
of many cases
where the largest abortion provider in
our country
has
agreed
that they have misappropriated funds
specifically Medicaid funds
toward the performance of abortion
and
from testimony of people who have run
Planned Parenthood clinics
we know how they do that
so we think this uh independent audit is
necessary
one of the reasons independent is
important to us
is that all these other clinics are
going the same excuses the same ones you
hear Within These Walls over and over
and over oh we're audited this way in
that way in six ways from Sunday
and then
a Planned Parenthood say oh yeah well we
did misappropriate nine million dollars
or whatever
and uh but those are never convicted now
they never get convicted
because they always always plead
and
they have non-disclosure agreements
we also know that roughly 90 percent of
the people who under a Planned
Parenthood and that's the only one for
which we have information from their own
annual reports
seeking Pregnancy Services
end up with abortions
it's hard to sit here and say to you
oh I believe they can do that with
totally separating their funds none of
the money that you give them as we've
heard none of the fungible money that
you give them gets directed toward
supporting abortion
so that's it
okay thank you Mr welper
any questions uh yes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
if this bill were to pass and be signed
into law and
um an independent
audit was done which showed no
co-mingling of funds would you and your
organization support
um
allowing these organizations to have
account contracts for family planning so
as I said my previous testimony the
answer to that question would be no
right but that hasn't got anything to do
with this bill because this bill doesn't
do that
right what it does do is it establishes
an accountability sequence
that we think is far better than the one
we have and I will just say to you that
part of the reason is because
we have seen in the past where
requirements for inspections of clinics
and things like that that were supposed
to be done
we're not done we're not done year after
year after year
they may be being being done down but a
lot of that has to do with our efforts
to make them happen
follow up follow up
I'm curious why you would support this
bill if even if there was a clean bill
of health given about co-mingling funds
that you wouldn't support these
organizations getting contracts anyway
what is the purpose of it what is the
purpose of this bill it's to increase
the
or establish I think because it is a
better word
a level of accountability that I don't
think they have now
thank you yes representative King so in
your opening testimony you basically
make the case which is what I said
earlier that all funds are fungible at
the end of the day
um and um sure the the money might not
go directly towards abortion but if it
helps pay for you know the electricity
in the building and the Staffing and all
these other things then
that's money they don't have to spend
towards those things now they can spend
it towards abortions so
to me it does seem like uh to Riff on
what the other representative asks why
would you support this bill if you know
at the end of the day even if this bill
passes all funds are fungible and matter
of fact this almost seems like it would
hurt your argument because if this bill
is Law and all of the abortion providers
say hey look we're following the law
here and it shows you know by the book
we're not committling funds it really
kind of weakens your argument in the
future if you say hey uh let's just end
it all together so it seems like I just
don't understand why you would support
this bill why not just go right for the
right for the throat which is just
completely end all money for abortion
providers period what was the said the
phrase that representative Edwards used
in his testimony this amount of
political calculation involved in all of
this
so I see this as an incremental way
of reducing
State involvement
in the in abortions
if we could do better
I would
but we can't
thank you any other questions
hey I see none thank you very much
next signed up to testify is Kayla
Montgomery from Planned Parenthood of
Northern New England
good afternoon everyone
um
my name is Kayla Montgomery I am the
vice president of public affairs for
Planned Parenthood Northern New England
and New Hampshire we posed this bill I
will try and be quick
um I recognize how late it's getting and
I have to go pick up my kids in 10
minutes
um can't be late for that definitely you
only have three so it works out well
um so we are a three-state organization
main Vermont New Hampshire we have 15
Health Centers across our three states
uh four of them are here in New
Hampshire two of the house hunters in
New Hampshire provide abortion care two
of them do not but all of them provide
essential reproductive health care so
we're talking about birth control cancer
screenings SDI testing and treatment
particularly important now as STI rates
are really on the rise in this region
and we do it all on a sliding scale fee
if you come in and you can't afford
Services we give them to you for free
a little bit of background about Planned
Parenthood and our involvement in the
state of New Hampshire we have been in
the New Hampshire Family Planning
program since its Inception in 1972.
with the exception briefly in 2011 and
2015 we were out of the program for a
couple of years and then of course now
as we are not in the program
so as it was mentioned House Bill 2
required Financial reviews and Planned
Parenthood in Northern New England
complied DHS made that clear that we
were forthcoming with all requests and
we heard from a representative
after the reviews were completed in the
summer of 21 that quote there is no way
our contract dollars could be
subsidizing any other programs at those
facilities we heard that after the
audits were complete we heard that just
now today
um and of course regardless of these
legal assurances that were provided the
council rejected these contracts four
different times and that was 80 percent
of the program
so we have not been in the New Hampshire
Family Planning program since June 30th
of 2021 but we are still in the federal
title 10 program we are select Medicaid
and we hope to of course one day get
back in the New Hampshire title 10
program
so of course we are still Bound by these
federal and state laws uh the Hyde
Amendment and other regulations
regarding funding so we have long
established by long establishment in 50
years long established guidelines
policies trainings
requirements in place that we do now
even though we're not in the program
because we have other reasons to
maintain these guidelines So for 50
years these systems have been in place
no state or federal funds are ever used
for abortion Services as we heard
so a couple of questions that this leads
us to
um in we've heard a lot around Financial
Audits and we too at Planned Parenthood
of Northern New England do a yearly
Financial audit PPN e is bound by the
exact same Federal IRS laws that all
501c3s are any organization that
receives over 750
000 in federal grants must conduct an
external independent audit every year to
ensure compliance with our federal
grants
you can find these right on our website
you can pick up your phone right now and
look at it ppnme.org about us you will
see the last few years of audits I
didn't bring them with me I didn't print
them out but you can find them online
right now and that brings up some
questions and representative Weber also
asks these questions are these reviews
in addition to what we already do
um do we have to do these audits even
though we're not in the program so those
are your wrap up in the next minute or
so sure um just a couple of other
questions uh I had a lot of questions
around the geographic requirements but
as the sponsor said
um I I'll save my comments on that until
we see an amendment on that
um the question that was already brought
up around contracts better qualified
Health Center this they contract with
PPN e
um for instance a federally qualified
Health Center does wonderful care but
they don't do specialized reproductive
care something like um which this was
brought up earlier a lark a long-acting
reversible contraception from the IUD
it's a very popular form of birth
control because it's the set it and
forget it method you put it in and you
can have birth control for six seven
years but you can't just go to a CVS and
get that it's Specialized Care and so a
federal qualified Health Center will
contract with Planned Parenthood or
another reproductive Health Care
Facility because we are we have the
inventory we we have the Specialized
Care to do this or you know a removal as
well this is care that not everyone can
do
another question around there's a
Medicaid statement in there it appears
as Bill Bill might violate the federal
free choice of Provider laws that they
don't let Medicaid patients come to
certain medical providers I think that
section needs a little bit of clarity is
just not clear also it's unclear to me
whether this applies to private OBS that
aren't funded by state or federal
government that also perform abortion in
New Hampshire there are a few of those
and this also came up but it's unclear
who pays for this audit do we have to do
this audit even though we're not in the
program
and what about the sites at Planned
Parenthood that don't do abortion so our
Exeter and dairy sites do they have to
do the audits as well so all in all just
a lot of questions here
and I will just say one thing because it
came up about lobbying and about money I
just want to say that I'm not sure where
the information came from the um the
person that was
brought up by a previous person about
their work Planned Parenthood hasn't
been here for three years so I'm not
sure where that information came from
and of course my Lobby reports are
always available online if anyone wants
to see those lobbying reports and I just
dropped mine off actually thank you
happy to take any questions I'm
representative Shapiro
thank you have you done any side-by-side
estimates of how much an additional
audit would cost versus how much you
might get in state contracts to actually
provide services from people I haven't
but of course the state contracts are
getting the the pot of funds is getting
smaller every year or it has been
there's been a dramatic reduction I
would say
um so it's we're not talking a lot of
money so you know eight thousand ten
thousand dollars on a an audit would
certainly impact that we want to be able
to provide care for people
um you know like I said we give away
millions of dollars in free health care
services to low-income people in New
Hampshire to keep the state healthy and
we want to make sure that the money that
we get goes to those Direct Services for
helping people and not towards audits
that are already redundant
thank you
any other questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you
next signed up to testify is Roy Dennehy
from New Hampshire right to life
uh thank you so much chairman and the
committee I'll make it very quick very
um concise here
um this bill continues the policy from
the last legislative session
uh when Planned Parenthood was denied
taxpayer funding to provide abortion
services
Planned Parenthood has consistently made
false statements that this lack of
funding has hurt a women's health care
as a point of fact abortion is is not
Women's Health Care
it is specifically
to
um to kill a pre-born baby that's what
what abortion is as a public service the
New Hampshire right to life organization
has published a directory of dozens of
inexpensive and free health care
providers in New Hampshire that would
not affect that were not affected by the
lack of State funding and I just have a
one example here of probably a dozen
right here in my hand
um
the taxpayers of the Granite State
should not be funding planned
parenthood's abortion services
and that's it thank you thank you
any questions this gentlemen
see you done thank you
and the only the last bank card I have
of someone who signed up to testify is
from Jason Hennessey from Amherst New
Hampshire with New Hampshire right to
life
thank you Mr chairman
so my name is Jason Hennessey I'm the
current president of New Hampshire right
to life and I'm here to speak
enthusiastically in support of of the
bill before you HP 615
this is about this is a controversial
subject obviously about 70 percent of
New Hampshire rights agree with some
sort of restriction on abortion
so the question is then what do we do
with our tax dollars
so this isn't you know this isn't
something like whether we pave a certain
Road or something like that this is this
is more about uh what some people think
is the largest human rights uh violation
going on in the state right now which is
abortion
so this this bill codifies the hp2
language and I just like to respond to
something I heard earlier that there
there has been separation you know if
somebody wants to pay for my utilities
at home
um and or per Taps pay for uh my rent or
something like that that would be
wonderful
um but that's what co-mingling the funds
does it when you have you know if you
have facilities and utilities being paid
for out of one pocket obviously it's
going to be supporting the stuff the
abortion stuff that's going on in the
other place
uh something I'd like to point out is
that planned parented over the last year
since the uh Family Planning contracts
were were denied
has closed six facilities
presumably as a as a result of the of
the denial something interesting is that
five of them were in Vermont
So based on the evidence there I'd like
to ask you know is this money really
being spent on New Hampshire purposes or
is it being used to subsidize
out-of-state things because it's one
entity for Vermont made in New Hampshire
I'd also like to point out that New
Hampshire denying These funds did not
stop the funds from coming so Planned
Parenthood received half a million
dollars from the federal HHS as part of
the title 10 program
and in terms of I've heard a lot of
questions about the audit and the cost
and if you look at their last audited
statement the they spent about they had
a total budget of about 28 million
dollars
only 20 million of that was actually
spent on Services the rest of the 8
million were spent on things like
lobbying and administration and
fundraising so if you can't find five
eight or ten thousand dollars out of you
know eight million dollars then
uh I don't think that's the state's
issue
so with that uh
I just wanted uh uh let's see
yep so with that I would love to take
any questions
thank you any questions for this
gentleman
okay oh no okay I think we're all set
all right thank you thank you
and that is the only other person I knew
to testify on this bill anyone else who
wants to testify on hb615
seeing no one I will close the public
hearing on hb615 those are all the bills
we had noticed for today it's been a
full day thank you everybody for
sticking it out and um I am going to
adjourn the meeting we are scheduled to
come back next Wednesday February 1st
and do it again so thank you all
drive safely